[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the chess world is buzzing as the 2022
feed a candidate's tournament is
underway in madrid spain the top
qualifying players from around the world
are bringing their best for a chance to
fight for the title ian naponnayaki and
american fabiano carawana are co-leaders
with a half point lead over the field
going into day two the stage is set and
the challengers are ready to put on a
show
round two of the 2022 v-day candidates
coming up next
[Music]
so
[Music]
good morning everybody and we are here
it is round two of the most anticipated
tournament of the year the 2022
candidates tournament to determine the
challenger to the world champion magnus
carlson we have some of the best players
in the world fighting for this spot and
to bring you all of the action i am
grand master alejandro ramirez here with
my good friend grandmaster yasser sarah
juan yeah hello alejandro good to see
you again wow we had a lot of fun
yesterday it was a
wonderful wonderful round it's
everything that you wanted from the
start of the candidates it was
uncompromising it was fun we had games
that went very long and every single one
of them was a fight absolutely hello
everyone thank you for joining us as we
return with our coverage of the
candidates round two it certainly lived
up to all the hype all the billing that
we could possibly want four extremely
hard-fought games featured two winners
and let's take a look at our standings
after round one alejandro did the honors
please as you said it yes sir there's
two winners in the first round and that
was those were fabiano caroline and jane
formula she who sit pretty at the top of
the standings
one point each at 50 with half point we
have young sister of duda rajabov
richard rapport and alireza firouza
meanwhile the losers of yesterday's
games hikaru nakamura having lost to
fabi and dingley wren losing to yann
nepomniacci they are currently
struggling with zero points let's review
the games of uh yesterday
let's start with duda against rockport
and i think this was a very crucial game
tons of people are saying these two
outside chests but quite outside chance
to win this tournament and why criticism
to do that not strong enough yesterday
he wasn't able to convert an advantage
that a lot of people would have thought
that is a decisive one that you need to
convert those games should have been
good enough no question and because
they're rookies what a victory might
have meant for one of them exactly uh
meanwhile in the game between dingley
ren and yana pomiyachi it seems that the
chinese player starts again in a
disastrous fashion in the candidates
losing with the white pieces it was it
nerves was he unable to overcome jet lag
we do not know what we know is that he
was not present in the game yesterday
and just got steamrolled by his opponent
by nepo a wonderful game by uh nepo
indeed and in the all-american matchup
and this was a crucial one as well of
course remember that according to
regulations people from the same
federation must play each other on the
first rounds and this one is of course
the only one in the tournament karana
played against nakamura and what a great
victory for fabi fans it really was
because hikaru got a very even position
right out of the opening he fought his
way back and then he made this really
tough decision he castled short putting
his king in harm's way and he frankly
never recovered it just was too
difficult after this king was way too
exposed and in the last game of the day
we had kimura java playing against
alaresa ferruja a dining brook of a game
alireza sacrificing the exchange for
incredible positional compensation right
but timur you know that
the moment that you knock at his door he
is going to answer furiously because he
was actually the one on the verge of
winning he flipped the script absolutely
so kudos to teamwork showing very very
good chance yesterday after being
surprised in the opening and let's take
a look at the format alejandra it's good
old classical chess played over a very
long tournament an eight player double
round robin that means 14 rounds of
chess over in spain and the classical of
classical formats 120 minutes for the
first 40 moves 60 minutes for the next
20 and 15 extra minutes for uh the
remaining part of the game but you also
get an extra 30 second increment
starting from your move 61. three time
controls no draw offers before black's
40th move nice price fun nobody's
interested we want to become a
challenger and what about the schedule
the schedule is also quite long as we
have three rounds and a rest day three
rounds in a rest day and that's gonna be
our pace we are currently on round
number two saturday june 18th so our
first race day will be on monday
and good morning christian nice to see
you bright and early here in st louis
what do you have for us
great to see you guys good morning yasir
good morning alejandro and good morning
to every chess fan around the world
watching one of the most exciting and
important events of the year but let's
uh have a look at and see how these
players got to uh where they are and
where do they stand in terms of ratings
as we see dingley rand in the top
position 2806 he actually won 20 rating
points in last couple of months by
playing some tournaments in china and at
the bottom we see yamashita duda only 56
rating points be below the top seed
needless to say this event is a very
tense one very compact
field we have on our hands and let's see
where these players land in terms of
experience we have one fabiano caruana
the most experienced player in this
field this is his fourth candidate
tournament and he needs to make a splash
dingley ran and dingley ran with uh
three appearances at the candidates
hikaru nakamura janna pognashi and timur
rajabov on their second appearance
richie rapport yanshi staff duda and the
young ali reza firuja making their first
appearance and let's take a look at
their age as well or as we like to call
it their experience we have the most
experienced player in the field that is
teemu rajabot 35 years of age hikaru
nakamura only one year below him at 34
years of age needless to say this two
players perhaps this is their last rodeo
we have jan nepomnyashi 31 years of age
he fabiano caruana and dingley wren 29
years of age and of course at the bottom
you can see one ali reza firuja only 19
years of age and actually he turns 19
today he came into this event as a young
18 year old and right now happy birthday
ali reza happy 19th birthday we are
looking forward to call all the action
we have an exciting event on our hands
thank you christian and alejandro what
about today's pairings come on give us
the match-up let's get right into it it
is richard rockford with the white
pieces playing against alireza farouja
hikaru nakamura will try to bounce back
from his defeat yesterday against tamu
rajabov and in what has to be the key
matchup of the day wow yanni pogbachie
will be playing against fabiano karana
fabi with the black pieces that one is a
match-up between the winners of
yesterday a win by either one of these
players might catapult them already at
full point ahead of the field
duda will be playing with the white
pieces against dingley wren to round up
today's matches the players may not care
but the money
it's a nice spell five hundred thousand
empires it's not bad it pays the seconds
yes but this is not what the players are
fighting for the players are only here
for one spot and one spot only it is to
challenge this man magnus carlsen for
the world chess championship and that
one will be next year to be determined
where exactly exactly and there can be
only one absolutely wow i'm still kind
of
well
absorbing all that happened
yesterday but i can't emphasize enough
the match-up of
the two winners today yes if you start
two-and-oh
in the candidates your chances of
winning has to be enormous like just
flat out fantastic so one of these
players can pull off a win
and
not much
between them there
10 games only one win wow
the only one i killed them the only one
i can think of was johnny point beating
fabian zagreb with his fashionista where
he was worse then
he lost
his way
and
nepo got off to an amazing start like
3-0 he had some incredible start faded
in the second half that's right it was
one of our grand chess tours but a lot
of draws between these two players
remarkable nine dragons and never
blood has been shed
yeah that's remarkable and i'm also
surprised that only ten games between
these two players we saw the head they
had to head between hikaru 35 33 draws
yeah
seven to six and they're under uh way
but as we just review our project
predictions
you and i uh
i have to say guys i'm looking pretty
good nobody's talking about it good job
good job it's round number two it will
be okay guys but what round we have on
our hands yesterday the tournament
couldn't have started uh better but you
guys mentioned one of the pairings the
games of the day probably the one
between yane pomnyashi and fabiano
caruana but what do you think about one
ritchie rapport versus ali reza firuja
that one is going to be a slugfest and
ali reza actually is once again playing
with the black pieces he's starting with
two blacks in a row we know what that
means he's going to have two whites
later on in the tournament after the
halfway point this is a very very
important game for both of these players
and i'm sure they're both going to
bringing the heat
yes indeed and i'm looking at this game
between jan and fabio and i can't help
but smile
because
as a scholastics player you know this is
going way back we all learned that
didn't you learn the joke of piano as as
a junior scholastic this is what you're
supposed to do and these top players are
that this is the playground today yeah
it's a funny thing that the joko piano
which is
how do you put it it's a beginner's
opening right it you you play e4 they
respond with the same move they move the
night out you attack the pawn you defend
the night you defend the pawn it's
pretty basic but it has re it has led to
an incredible complexity yeah at the top
level of chess and it's become such a
battleground i love seeing these kind of
positions i know that favi plays this
with both white and black with
incredible accuracy i want to see what
nepa brings because
nepo did not face the joko piano italian
system in the world championship he was
only playing spanish exactly
i guess magnus calls it right didn't
work out for him no he got advantages
but it didn't seem that he got exactly
the understanding of the positions
enough to really
break through and press magnus yeah and
did not uh didn't he play the joko piano
in their last game but i think by their
last game last one
he was trying to win but he definitely
had it uh as an option for a potential
uh needed wheat that is very true right
so i want to see what he brings yeah
this is going to be an interesting one
and this particular
version of the joko piano which we have
to talk about and apologies to the
viewers but
the joker piano at the top level
is so incredibly confusing
yes
it looks the same
whether you play
d6 first a6 first castles first bishop
a7 first same thing for the white moves
right rookie one first or and they're
all different right they might
transposing to each other they might not
transposing into each other you're
allowing different variations for black
and you're allowing different variations
for white depending on your move order
right and it is
very puzzling it's a mush yeah it's
really a mush christian back to you guys
check out this game the one between rich
report and ali brezza and i told you it
is going to bring it e4 c5 knight f3 d6
are we headed into an idor let's wait
and see d4 take on d4 knight takes d4
sure
boom
queen takes d4 have we seen this ever in
the canvas we know knight takes d4 is by
far the main line in this variation
queen takes d4 is actually considered
not to give white any uh slimmer of an
edge in uh this variation knight to c6
is definitely an option knight to f6 is
also an option we can even go a6 at some
point this knight from b8 is going to
target the queen on a d4 and it does
feel like you're losing a tempo now of
course the idea lies in the nuances of
the position after knight to c6 you have
the option of potentially tying the
knight with the move bishop to b5 but we
very often see the move queen to e3 and
after that with the absence of the
knight on d4 this long castle most
likely is going to be bringing the heat
because with a rook on d1 and this
construction e5 very often is going to
become a breakthrough so this is a very
very intriguing start to this game let's
see how alireza will respond to this
queen to d4 and as we can see there a
lifetime between these two players and
i'm sure we're going to see a lot of
this matches going forward one win one
loss and one draw in classical chess
this is a very very tense and important
matchup and let's not forget ali reza is
playing on his birthday we don't know
whether he cares too much about his
birthday there's definitely not going to
be any cake today
no cake for you what what what by the
way uh
did you ever play somebody on their
birthday
actually no uh i do i played once but it
was a you know like a for fun tournament
more than a serious tournament but i've
never played a serious game of chess on
my birthday just never happened my
birthday is on june 21st and summer
somehow no no no no no no no tournaments
and you played an opponent
who had a birthday
yes yes i have felt bad about that oh
okay
okay
because it's very strange i played about
4 000 tournament games 4 000 can you
imagine and i only played as far as i'm
aware
one person on their birthday and it was
at the world team championship
and uh just the before the gong sounds
the arbiter comes on and says and by the
way we'd like to congratulate miss
judith polgar on her birthday i was like
judith i didn't know congratulations
well done and she said yes sir
you can give me a present by taking
anything you want
off the board
and i remember bobby fisher said he
could beat the woman's world champion
with night odds
but i wanted to recognize the great
achievements that women had made so i
removed her life
i took her night from g8 she said give
it back and i go no no no no and it was
a fight but i very reluctantly gave back
her night and her first move was knight
f6 to make sure he didn't take it but
happy birthday ali raising yes uh some
players actually like playing on their
birthday i think hicaro's the most
famous one for saying that he enjoys
playing on his birthday he has had a lot
of success uh partially because his
birthday actually lands usually during
the london chess classic a traditional
tournament that we had part of the grand
chess tour and he always did very well
on that day very very nice i just taking
a look at hikaru's game for a moment as
a timor rajaba
repeats the berlin variation
that uh
that um fabi that he carl played but not
against
what happened because without bishop
exists because without bishop takes c6
so after d3 bishop c5 bishop takes c6
was the game of yesterday of yesterday
bishop takes c6 takes c6 knight bd2 but
in this one we're playing ibd2 directly
and that does change things 92 here is
actually rather rare uh it allows not
only d6 which changes the character of
the position i would be able to take
with the b pawn right instead of
being forced to capture with the centro
exactly or you could play the other line
which is knight d4 i think castle's also
aligned by the way but
uh knight d4 i think is quite common
knight d4 seeking to trade off what
oftentimes isn't the great knight on c6
uh so knight v4
tickles the bishop so i'm assuming takes
takes knight f3
and something like c6 no no i he i think
bishop b6 is the move
bishop b6 right away right it's a really
nice trap actually because really
obviously bishop b6 you cannot take on
e5 oh don't tell me that
i want to take why couldn't you take
this one hold on i messed this one up a
little bit
how did this go i haven't i'm gonna have
to leave the christian good morning
saint louis queen how did this go queen
he said so what if you go c6 wait wait
you're threatening queen bee for check
that's what it was something like
something like that it was like queen e7
oh my gosh that's an amazing double
attack was it [ __ ] the knight and the
bishop there we go i i knew i had an
idea
you didn't get to expect to get
challenged this early in the morning
okay so knight d4 is one step yeah and
is that the live
uh
i believe that it is 94 has been played
that is the live and he has gone id4 yes
okay
so sometimes i remember a little my
opening is good for you good for you um
our number one see dingler in i mean he
must be wondering what the heck is going
on this is uh
two years ago he again as mentioned
earlier on the show
lost in the opening round against his
compatriot
uh and started the candidates with a
loss he starts with the candidates with
a loss against nepo
needs to bounce back i mean i know it
sounds
dramatic and hyperbole and what have you
but
is today the day of the joco pianos by
the way because i mean uh well look at
what i'm seeing here we have
castles rookie one not a6 not bishop a7
but a5 and as you were saying each one
has a very subtle
uh unique flavor with different um
points sorry let's not get too much into
this i just wanted to make a mental note
of how different the joko pianos are
based on the subtle differences of uh
move orders yeah i want you to remember
what's going on in this game and then
compare it when we eventually go back to
the fabio game all right and see how
they're completely different scenarios
even though they played almost the same
moves exactly well first thing that is a
very
visual
is that this queen somehow came out of
the center went to a7 to put pressure on
the f2 pawn and this diagonal towards
white's king
now after the move
a5 a4 the queen on a7 has a double
purpose a little bit more space
and the potential for queen a5 trapping
this bishop on a b5 game continued
knight g3 queen a5 takes
and i almost i dare ask a christian here
are we still in the throes of a theory i
mean
this
they played it very quickly we must be
it does seem like uh
the last move for white this move by
young
bishop
uh was the novel approach the novelty uh
in this particular case d4 was played
before which makes a lot of sense
obviously you're going to try to strike
in the center taking on d4 uh
perhaps this is the idea of bishop to d2
even though i generally don't want to
take on d4 but especially with the
bishop on d2 that's also going to target
the queen so that might be a hidden idea
behind the last move on of the unstable
duda bishop to d2 but d4 was one way
knight to h4 apparently was the main
line by a quite a big margin knight goes
to f5 and then all sorts of sacrifices
are coming on h6 or a g7 and of course
rule two
e8 usually is being played and after
knight to f5 at some point you will have
to try
to kick the knight away or try yourself
to strike in the center with d5 and
reroute this bishop to f8 to be closer
uh to the king quite an intriguing
position but this bishop d2 was
responded by dingley wren quite fast
actually i have to say bishop to b6 was
played
not waiting for white to play the move
d4 and kick the bishop back just bishop
to b6 on his own accord now what is the
idea behind this move i'm trying to
understand and i simply don't see that
quick queen i'm not a big fan of this
move bishop to b6 i have to say queen b5
to win upon
but pb5 doesn't work that's a problem
well i was unlucky because that's the
problem that's the problem and you could
have done queen b5 before which was by
the way the best move according to the
computer
is the best move uh
you have a sixth sense about these type
of things this type of uh pawn attacks
if i might uh say like that but take a
look at what's happening in um this game
so in this one between richie rapport
and ali reza actually not a lot of
things have happened but
instead of queen to e3 which we touted
as one of the main lines he decided to
go for bishop to b5 now black has a way
to achieve an immediate end game with
queen to a5 and take on b5 and then take
on d4 but that's just not a good end
game for him so he decided to go a6
bishop takes c6 b takes c6 and now we
see this idea of a c4 and we've seen it
from jan shishtav duda trying to get
this structure against richie rapport
yesterday this type of marotzi bind
later on structure b3 is going to come
potentially the bishop lands on a beat
waiting for e5 and then focus on the
pawn on d6 this is and we were asked
yesterday what trends are we going to
see in the candidates well this one this
type of uh morality bind structure with
the pawn already on c6 could potentially
be a new trend that is developing for
this particular candidates
another one
asi karu nakamura is obviously showing
this idea with an early knight d2 and
then probably he was ready to go knight
to b3 maybe that's developing into a
trend as well but right now after knight
to d4 knight takes d4 c3 bishop to b6
and d4 immediately while this one is
blowing up it's going to be a very
exciting affair and i mean i'll let you
guys take this one away
versus fabiano caruana i have no idea
what's happening in this one this move
knight to g4 is a novelty and is a
novelty that was played instantaneously
by fabiano carowana
i wouldn't be happy seeing this move
knight to g4 as white seeing fabiano
just getting ready to launch an attack
on the king side like that thank you uh
christian i just wanted to follow up on
what you have said alejandro and we'll
do it right now we're going to make a
comparison of the two games
of
the joco piano the first comparison was
ian versus ding loren here it is on my
board boom a very very different game
from the one you're about to see just
kind of check where black's
queen is look at the kings uh very
nicely behind the pawn shield and then
suddenly boom this is also out of the
very same opening in a completely
different animal
nothing in common yeah and i think the
only recognizable part is the structure
in the center the d3 e4 against d6 e5
right everything else has pretty much
been played differently and in the other
in the other game it seems like john
shishtov is playing for the center slash
king side right and dingle around is
playing on the queen side and here it's
completely the opposite uh roles black
is completely going on the king side and
white is the one that's pushing phones
from the queen side
completely different and also just to
compare so yesterday we had the game of
fabi
versus hicaro so fabi is white played
bishop to g5
that was met by h6 bishop h4 g5 by black
and the and the white whites uh bishop
actually ended up
on g3 where it was constantly being
attacked by blacks expanding pawns h7 h6
by fabi just kind of um well
take
took the g5 square under control but the
bishop said your bishop's not coming to
g5 your turn knight to d2s i'm happy
says john
what
g5
g5 i do know g5 i know is a game uh has
been played many times
uh i've always played it himself before
i know that much that g5 has been played
before and that b4 i know the move here
is knight h5 i know that knight h7 has
been played as well but knight h5 i
thought was just considered to be the
better move
knight h knight h5 eyeballing i'm
bilingual
square i just not aware of the move
knight g4 at all seriously right and uh
the move b2b4 also you know when i see
my opponent playing uh pawn to g5 like
this i'm dreaming of one day
occupying the light square so i
for my
my taste
the move knight uh d2 to f1 to e3 going
for those outposts would have been my
knee-jerk uh choice but the move b2b4 i
understand
uh from the perspective that black's
going to have a problem with this king
one day yeah he's not going to leave it
in the center and he's going to go
somewhere
b4 basically discourages you from from
castling but then you
talk to me about knight g4 that looks
like a very peculiar move it's a very
favi type of preparation it looks risky
it's probably
extremely sharp and very deep
and he is not afraid of playing uh
positions that are perhaps technically
unsound
but where he feels the refutation might
not be human be so hidden yeah that it
would take a super effort yeah
and we we gambled like that in one of
the games in the world championship
match in 2018. good thing that you
brought up this word gambling yeah
because a lot of amateur players ask me
yes or is there bluffing in chess yes of
course and the answer is yeah absolutely
but bluffing at the world championship
yeah we did feel we did feel that
it wouldn't be responsible for magnus to
go down this line that there was no way
yeah that that a human
faces this
in a game and that he figures it all out
over the board over the board and plays
it and magnus thought for like 30 40
minutes and bailed right immediately no
no no no not not doing it uh and you
sense a rat yeah you said across the
board it says that there's something off
right
you see the guy over there like please
go
give me my chance no i'm not going to
show you i'm not going to let you show
me your homework but it is an idea that
only works once right because once
you've used it
then they'll look at it and thoroughly
rook e2
makes sense i mean you're pressing
against the f2 square and then the
question is why on earth did you play
the move knight g4 because of this
follow-up queen f6 with the threat of
capturing twice
bringing the king forcing the king to f2
so that g5 g4 will win material
this feels like
the the best the better prepared player
the better he's going to win but the
better prepared player is fobby i mean
there's no doubt about that uh nepo is
burning time favi's playing instantly so
it's kind of obvious
okay so i see the threat so i'm going to
protect against knight takes f2
and this whole g5 g4 i'll play this
rather
can i say it passive move but i feel
i've almost obliged it's passive but at
the same time
it does put a
question what are you doing what are you
doing like are your knights on g4 your
bishop's on a7 your question f6
everybody start getting f2 right i'm
gonna
over protect that word i'm
i'm actually going to protect it just
enough right
and then one day one day i'll play h3
and the knight will not have a square to
retreat to okay so what would be
the most i mean
once you've launched knight g4 bishop a7
queen f6 once you've gone
this far
you start thinking to yourself
how do i continue the aggression
i do not know let me pause right away
okay let's look at a couple of the moves
i am reading the chat and you are
welcome to join in the conversation join
us on twitch join us on youtube we uh on
on the chat
uh i'm looking at what it's saying that
d4 is a move in this position a computer
uh suggested i don't i'm not using
instead of rookie too
well let's jump to christian yeah and he
can answer it for us uh christian
well you guys are not using engines but
you are i am so i was looking uh i was
browsing through the lines after d4
which does seem to be the more critical
approach queen to e1 by the way was
played and as yasser was pointing out
you start smelling the rat right so you
don't want to go into the most concrete
lines when you're facing this type of
preparation now d4 probably after um he
takes d4 and e takes d4 is almost forced
because right now white has a big threat
and that is to go a b5 and this knight
is going to feel very very uncomfortable
also the center is going to feel very
uncomfortable after that now the idea
behind b5 after the move d4 is that very
often this bishop will not be able to
capture on f2 so imagine for example
after b5 we exchange these two pawns and
this bishop opens up the rook will be
hanging on a1 that's a typical motif in
this type of positions you have to take
on d4 and after that e5
uh sacrificing another pawn seems to be
the best way forward and after this i
was trying to look through the lines dx5
is one of them and then you're not even
recapturing any of the pawns back you
actually go knight to e4 yeah if you
don't know what you're doing uh from
home then good luck trying to navigate
this type of positions now an
interesting idea would have been knight
from g takes to e5 and take a look at
this lines take on d4
bishop takes d4 knight to e4 knight
takes f3 g takes f3 queen to g6 knight
takes d6
discovery check double discovery check
king to f8 by the way 1.1 knight takes
f7
check this out right now the engine is
saying zero zero after saying all
throughout this line plus one point five
plus two so this is the type of
preparation that fabi usually has in
store he goes very very long through the
lines he uh only finishes when he's sure
that he's completely lost or completely
uh winning and this is exactly what
we're seeing right now after rook to h7
the engine jumps back to 1.3 but this is
a weak engine imagine what the engine
that fabiano caruana is likely using
what type of insights that type of
machine can give him so we don't know
the precise assessment after rook h7 but
i'm sure probably we will find out in
later days as far piano carolina will
express his feelings about this game no
way i am not getting 10 feet
exactly near exactly this kind of uh
position that's why he played queen e1
and immediately answered with queen to
g7 a very peculiar spot for the queen i
have to say is the fianchetto uh queen
knight to f1 and now castle sure you
just uh
your queen and now you're going to
castle like nothing happened
it's alien chests from what i'm seeing
right now uh true that for me uh
when i saw the move queen e1 and i
thought okay i gotta do this to avoid
those
enormous complications that christian's
talking about so i'm going to go
queenie1 and then right here i'm
thinking to myself
to quote maurice ashley what is the most
hyper aggressive thing i can do i mean
you know like am i taking on f2 am i
playing g g5 g4 am i playing h5 am i
playing bishop d7 in order i'm looking
at the hyper aggressive and then almost
instantly came queen g7 i was like okay
i'm completely thrown off
by uh black strategy knight f1 this one
i cannot at least understand the knights
going either to e3 and or in this case
more likely to g3
castles
once again if we were in some kind of
like suicide mode or what have you i
would have expected to move f7 f5
castles instead and i'm expecting in
knight g3 i think we've actually caught
up with the players
and this is a crazy position i uh uh i
can only say once again that
it's about preparation and in this case
uh fabby's preparation is either
fabulously good or
uh
questionable well we'll take a look uh
this is the type of positions that he
enjoys he enjoys out preparing his
opponent getting to something wild and
complicated and trying to outplay him
he's going for the win sure even though
it's round two you feel that this is
four forward prep yes yes we have some
social media let's take a look as uh i
said you can join us on our conversation
we have uh youtube we have twitch and
from youtube today david trottier uh
what do you think of the idea of feedick
creating a 960 rating
absolutely why not the fide has a 960
world championship and don't forget
wesley soh defeated magnus carlson in
oslo in a match for that crown and just
absolutely destroyed him i was there by
the way and it was really wonderful uh
the norwegians had turned out on moss
all of these really cute norwegian kids
had their face painted with the
norwegian flags and they got their
little norway flags and everything was
really really nice the table had set and
magnus had won the semi-final wesley had
won the semi-final so
the coronation was about to begin when
wesley just played
out of i mean he went like 11 to six i
mean it wasn't close it was a real
smackdown to sex you're being nice to
magnus
was it worse
it was bad i didn't realize it was that
i'm actually going to look it up
speaking of that tournament world
championship match what happened to the
chess uh 960 world championship matches
because that was 2019 and i don't think
anything happened after that i
understand it was the pandemic 2020 2021
but i don't think we have any plans
right now of holding a world
championship and that's a pity because
that was a lot of fun i'll tell you one
little story about that i was actually
with fabiano caruana in norway he was
facing magnus carlsen and
we had no idea how to approach the
tournament right
my role wasn't very specific like what
am i going to do there are we going to
like prepare for chess 960. how does
that work right because you don't know
what position you're going to play up
until 15 minutes before the game
actually starts and that's a world
championship match so we went there okay
i'm just going to be your body hang
around and try to ease the tension in in
that regard but as we got into the match
uh we started actually prep
preparing during the games uh before and
after and it was quite interesting to
see you find out the position and then
you start preparing the first game is a
complete mess because you didn't have
enough time to see exactly what's
happening and by the way the engines are
more or less clueless
of what to do in those type of chess 960
positions and then by the second and
third game because they play the same
position throughout the day so they have
a position at the start of the day and
they have multiple games they play a
position throughout the day by the end
of the day you actually know
what to do and you know the preparation
you know the opening moves it's quite
interesting i'm definitely looking
forward to see more tournaments of chess
960 and a rating would make a lot of
sense for that absolutely if you're
gonna have a world 960 championship you
ought to have a rating uh what was the
score 13 and a half two and a half
again my goodness thirteen and a half to
two and a half i knew it was bad that's
pretty bad i didn't realize it was that
kind of bad so when i say all of these
norwegian kids with their flags i mean
we're talking tears
it was not badly came in
norway
it was not a good look
and remember that if you're a fan of
chess 960 uh we have our tournament
chess nine lx coming up in september
some of the best chess players in the
world we were mentioning fabiano will be
here we'll have some of the top
americans participating in that one
field still to be determined fully but
it will be right after the slingfield
cup so no break for us we'll do st louis
wrapping and blitz featuring featuring
uh not this one but thingfield cup will
feature mac that's what happened carlson
here coming to the saint louis chess
club and right after that i mean like
two days later
the chess 9lx yeah by the way i'm
talking about deja vu this is a word
that we're going to be using a little
bit take a look at richard rapport's
game for example
for a moment and i'll be darned
yesterday it almost seems like richard
was on the receiving end
of this move c4c5 right boy he learns
quickly doesn't he very very quickly i
mean look at what he just did it's a
very similar structure
yeah yeah but there is a huge
few differences in my opinion right a
lot of the times when grandmasters
compare positions to another we grab a
position that we've seen before contrast
it to one that we have right now and say
okay what are the differences between a
and b who does it favor exactly and of
course this is a much better version for
black than what we saw yesterday for a
few reasons i think and i one of the
main reasons i believe in this position
is that
you don't have the pair of bishops as uh
white uh yesterday
black didn't have that advantage of the
pair of bishops right it does today
because of big trade because of the
trade on c6 and i didn't commit to this
move g6 which i felt was just
a lemon
yes no other way to put it lemon
true now having said that forgive me but
97 kind of feels a little tortured here
i mean
you know you you
i'm a simple guy you say to me
where do the pieces belong i go well you
put your knight on f6 you put your
bishop on e7 you put your bishop e6 you
castle and then you think what what's my
plan what am i going to do next 97 is
this a case of too much talent
i think it's fine uh because the only
way that i can imagine exploding a
slower
development move like 97 knight g6 is by
playing the move c5 and which is not to
mention that i'm wondering if the move
97 came with a bit of a um strategical
threat itself
because
there is the chance that black goes c5
right himself yeah puts his knight on c6
and then one day
maybe not immediately but one day
occupies the d4 square that's fair but
i'm just saying that knight e7 in some
ways seems to invite the move c5 and
again uh much like we did yesterday uh
we do have to just suggest that uh queen
check and uh capturing this pawn
might get yourself in a
bit of trouble i don't want to go in
this direction which is why ali reza
played the move in knight g6 and i'm
anticipating takes and we're going to
see something very similar in terms of
these split pawns
as you said black does have the two
bishops
okay
uh it's a game it's a game i think that
converted yesterday where it was obvious
white was better i think this was a bit
of a game okay now
i wanted to uh pick your mind a little
bit about the move d4 this early uh move
by uh hikaru uh this was the teamwork
game with knight to d4
but he's not played right
he just got no no no no he he he played
the move d4 some time ago did no but
oh did timor get stopped timor has been
thinking for how long
sometimes some time 20 minutes now on
this particular move and another 10
minutes
to come up with d4 okay
so for sure timor has been surprised by
this move d4 talk to me about the move
d4 for a second what are what can
what is timor
considering
uh well let's take a look at this
position it's been reached inside in
in pretty high level profile games which
is why why am i a little bit surprised
because i am it's a known move in that
case right i mean i'm going through the
database i don't have an engine but i do
have a database and
this are not sloppy matchups it's great
kramnik nepal nakamura ronian
i mean
in the world get out of here i mean this
is a known variation right right okay i
am kind of wondering why he's thinking
because he hikar himself already played
this i just mentioned a car playing this
before
and he's uh
he's on a 20-minute tank uh the two more
common moves in this position are c6
which he's finally played right and e
takes d4 but c6 is the
the main line well i would certainly uh
have to agree with that i mean the very
very desirable d76 simply defending the
e5 pawn is what you want to do
unfortunately there are rules and it's
illegal so you first start with c7 and
c6 and visuals those darn rules they
hate that right i mean they're so yeah
they tie you up okay so then what what's
the main line after c6 everybody plays
d5 in this position d4 takes e5 yeah d
takes e5 but almost everybody takes that
bishop
okay looks reasonable everybody takes
that knight everybody takes that with
the queen and everybody
threatening checkmate on the spot
yeah i a castle defending f2 and then
the results are favorable for it's
almost always a draw except for one time
that fabi beat kramnik uh but besides
that's a big win yeah i actually don't
remember i don't remember i mean i'm
gonna have to look that up i don't think
it was a candidate's tournament no no no
i think that was some sort of uh rapid
rapid blitz or something yeah it was it
was not a very
relevant game and they're going straight
into that variation uh queen h5 is the
novelty as far as i'm concerned knight
f3 and a4 had been played before so this
is the new twist
by hikaru
well i must say there was a period in
his life
i think he was
let's say a mature team
that he liked to play queen h5 on move
two oh again well e4 c5 queen h5 yeah e4
e5 it's a song on h5 until somebody
finally
finally caught him and destroyed him
right yeah yeah yes who was it it was
either sassy kitten or it was it played
in beale and it was a russian player and
i forgot his name
and
i'll just show it very very quickly this
uh uh
it was so hikaru was white and it went
e4 c5 and acara went queen h5
yeah yeah c5 has done that no i looked
it up it was e4e5 queen h5 well that was
one game but that was another there was
another game right here and then i think
it was something like knight f6 queen
takes c5 knight c6 and
then kara got killed yeah yeah he lost
this one tavolo kitten
yeah from ukraine yo ukraine
apologies but all right that was uh
so
let's just say
it's a
old favorite uh this movie
certain players have certain uh favorite
moves like i understand what you mean
with that well you know like kramnik
always likes this move rookie one and
almost any position the kramnik rookie
won playing in the center uh kasparov
always liked fianchetto in his bishop
whether it was for grunfeld or king's
indian in his
move bishop g7 just like that that was
gary and queen h5 just seems to be
a move that uh
is in the quiver
of he calls now now that being said this
is a very logical spot to actually put
the queen on h5 yes it is it's not going
to get hit easily but more importantly
it's a tempo i am hitting this phone on
b5 and i must admit that if you have to
play a6 i would assume that everybody
plays queen h5 instead of the most that
we saw before a4 or knight f3 now in
this case because you were mentioning
that um
in the game of um richard okay he played
97 with maybe a sly
strategic threat of c5 and knight c6
maybe queen h5 has a sly
strategic i like
right a dream position yeah if i could
is i would put a white pawn on e5 and a
white knight on d6 and that vision on c8
would be a septic septilicus a septic
bishop for the rest of the game so maybe
the move queen h5 has the idea of going
for such a setup where
if i could get
okay i you're being cooperative and i
appreciate that
but this is what i have in mind
uh this might be something that timor
should stay
far far far yeah you would have to solve
your problems already quite tactically
you'd have to hope that d5 works or
something like that right it might it
might but but you have to make sure yeah
because if you are one tempo away from
losing this game the knight gets to d6
you are not recovering from that exactly
uh but let's take uh let's go to
christmas go to christian christian what
do you have first well uh the stormy
clouds are definitely gathering around
this game and around this position
because the more i look at it the more
complex it gets and we know that fabiano
has probably spent a sizeable amount of
time analyzing this position with his
seconds
not the same thing can be said about jan
nepomnyashi and he might be in some sort
of danger right now we see knight to e7
already thinking
and developing a 30 minute advantage for
fabiano caruana one hour and 24 minutes
for yannipom yashi and
now h3 was the move that i thought about
first it makes the most sense i really
don't like this knight on g4 especially
coupled with the action of the bishop on
a7 against the pawn on f2 i don't like
that i want to free up my rook to move
it anywhere i want to probably go to d2
maybe go bishop to e3 as well to
exchange the dark square bishop h3 made
a lot of sense but let's take a look at
the main line proposed by the engine
which is the move d4 now this is a big
decision and perhaps this is what yana
pomnyashi is right now pondering the
problem is once you play the move d4 you
know that you're sacrificing a pawn and
you don't know exactly when you're going
to take it back so after e takes d4
the very unnatural at least
to my eyes with this knight on e7
already on e7 is this move a bishop to
b2 i understand you're getting ready to
uh if you black takes on c3 to get the
bishop on c3 and that makes a lot of
sense against the badly at least
awkwardly placed queen on a g7 for at
the moment but what if black just simply
goes knight to c6 well after knight to
c6 it does seem like you're going to
have to contend with the fact that
you're going to be upon down for a
little while but what if black goes to
move d3
bishop takes d3 and now taking advantage
of the fact that your bishop is on b2
and i have a lot of ways to block any
sort of openings of this diagonal for
example if you go knight to g6 with the
bishop b2 already this knight is ready
to jump to f4 with devastating
consequences so you have to feel at
least a little bit concerned if you're
white at this point with this awkward
placement of the queen on e1 the rook on
e2 probably you have to go rook to d2
you don't want to make too many moves
with the rook and lose a lot of tempes
with every single piece of blacks coming
your way and the way of your king so
definitely some stormy clouds gathering
around this position now for example
what if you go h3 kick the knight away
it makes a lot of sense right knight to
f6 for example and now knight to h2 is
one of the ways but what if you go d4
finally this knight is out of
g4 also the queen is no longer attacking
the pawn on d4 not putting any pressure
in the center like that it feels like
the most natural approach and you're
also not losing a pawn you're not
sacrificing anything if you take on d4
i'm just simply going to take it back
you don't have enough attackers against
the pawn on d4 but i think this is what
fabiano is looking at g4
and let's take a look at some of the
variations in this one knight to h4 for
example is probably going to be met by
bishop to e6 now if you take on e6 it
does feel already like you're worse with
the white pieces because not only that
the rook opens up and this is going to
be a very nice attack against the pawn
on f2 but these knights are a little bit
misplaced right now with the pawn on e6
controlling nicely the important square
on f5 this is the square that these
knights are uh aiming for unfortunately
oh by the way we have a move guys none
of this scratched this right everything
i spoke at the beginning
is likely to happen because he did play
the most critical move d4 and by the way
i'm expecting fabiano to immediately
respond so keep an eye on this game guys
but the more i look at the position the
more complex it gets and if you don't
have preparation in this position right
now you might be in serious trouble but
christian we have a question for you
from this position
because you mentioned captures on d4 yes
bishop to b2 which looks really good yes
then you went knight g6 in order to play
knight f4
yeah yeah with d3 sorry you went d3
first day three first yeah because if
you go knight g6 i think i can take and
that also keeps the bishop close that's
a problem right also i want to attract
this bishop to d3 so that knight f4
attacks two pieces everything everything
so far is clear our question is this why
is knight h5 not almost winning it looks
so strong
no you're kidding me right no
well i kind of like i protected f4
was played it takes d4 was played by the
way i am actually shocked that like a
move like e5 doesn't win here e5 open up
all my bishops knight fe five
even according to this
pretty weak engine black is already
better after e5 wow zero zero
oscillating between that and minus
something like that this is my
understanding i say yeah
i think i i i am going to sacrifice like
i will sacrifice knight takes e5 go
ahead i just want to see the enter
nevada knight takes e5 i want to play
knight take c5 as a sherman yeah knight
takes rook takes
great moves and then i go i don't know
queenie four or three four
still zero zeros what
and i guarantee you fabiano has this in
his notes but like wow it looks
looks great for one it just looks
winning right it looks winning but it's
not the the queen's this is all the
pieces
are sleeping i mean bishop c4 queen g64
again
i understand it looks like alien chess
fabiano very often plays alien chess i
remember a game jeez was it from the us
chess championships for or from the
american cup
uh he showed us this crazy line where at
the end he just sacrifices a queen for a
piece and the game goes on
because the other queen is trapped
yeah there was that one but there was
also against nakamura it was a
two-year-old it was against john burke
this was preparation against john burns
that's what i said yeah john burke in
his u.s championship championship yeah i
remember queen sacrifice from uh grand
chester he likes to play right
and we're watching the two leaders fight
it out in this complicated variations
against fabiano carrada is absolutely
complicated he that was actually taken
quickly on d4 with the pawn instead of
playing with bishop which was also
tempting now now i also thought c takes
d4 was very dangerous because you cannot
don't tell me yeah
bishop takes you
get out of here well the problem is
bishop takes d4 you very much would love
to take the bishop and claim okay you
won a pawn but wait wait wait wait wait
that's a double hit uh so it means that
after bishop takes d4 and probably got
to play rook a3 right again i don't
believe anything of what you're saying
no
first i'm going to throw in knight h5
and by the way he took on d4
it's a completely different line right
knight c6 by the way knight c6
completely free first
if you go queen h8 now i'll take on d4
i'm going to give you my piece okay yeah
you're going to give me the checkmate i
love it
what you got to you got it you got it i
mean it's
so is it rook a3 no bishop b2 and h3 and
let's go they should be not working oh
my gosh and you just put a knight on e5
how did you guys get to that position uh
we did it in a different way altogether
uh after takes on d4
we took the pawn right instead
that's a bad move yeah yeah and then and
then
we started with knight h5 gaining a
tempo to push the queen backwards we got
here
and then
alejandro is pounding the table
that how can this not be good but maybe
it's not maybe it's not maybe it's just
not enough
it feels like it's almost enough but
you're missing a light square bishop i'm
missing something yeah wow but we did
see the move knight c6 which was another
move that you christian pointed out
would likely be uh the move and
well uh fabi did not hesitate so but
guys yes i just have one question how
good is fabiano caruana's preparation in
general because i cannot think of the
last time anybody surprised him out of
the opening and he's surprising people
left and right almost every single game
he's ahead on time because he knows the
position because he managed to uh swing
the game in his favor when it comes i
remember
just world class i remember one time he
got
surprised yeah yeah he was playing he
was playing this guy magnus in london e4
yeah and the guy went c5 and he stopped
and i was like whoa
i don't know you could move one right
yeah
i remember i was playing uh shaq mommy
darup i played d4 and he was playing
grundfall
and ben and i spent the entire morning
okay studying greenfield i went d4 he
went c5
what i went d5 he went f5
and i stopped for like 15 minutes thank
you guys that's not a groove
i mean my preparation went out the
window on move three it was like what
that was terrible i played e4 sacrificed
the house and beat him that was that was
good uh talk to me about knight c6 uh
alejandra so abby said fine beyond my
understanding you created a weakness on
the d4 square i'm going to attack that
weakness with three pieces my queen on
g7 knight on c6 bishop on a7 what's
happening well the the pawn is actually
pinned right so d5 first of all the
desirable d5 probably not i'm not even
sure if it's that desirable right you do
kill your bishop but i understand that
the bishop is coming to b2 but the main
problem the recording is the rook
uh if i was gonna do any no knight h5
you're not required to play queen h8 you
could then go queen g6 yeah this is the
main difference between this position
and the ones with the knight on g6 or
their bishop is hanging on d4 right yeah
knight h5 will be met by queen g6 there
will be no problems okay just a second
okay so
uh again the desirable bishop b2
shall we just take a quick gander this i
also don't think there's a choice
do you feel that there's another move
for black that's not knight takes d4 oh
my god no i mean uh white's bishop
white's development is superb d5 is
coming even like a simple rook do you
want and look at these pieces which are
again still in their barracks they even
haven't
taken yet you have to have to take them
okay so knight takes 54
and unfortunately that comes with the
king of the temple
yes again that is a check
sadly
now knight i mean we could take
everything on d4 the queen comes to d4
we'll play rook c1 and we'll claim
compensation right but that is not that
convincing
i'm not even sure i have full
compensation
i i'm still reeling from the game of uh
alireza yesterday where he sacrificed an
exchange and i i got i felt tasered
that game really
that game really threw through threw me
off um
i'm trying something really really
awkward here
uh bishop takes d4 knight h5
the thing is even in those positions i'm
wondering how well black is um black
student because you think with the
bishop right you want to take with it
yeah i'll take back on d4 clear
i know knight h5
first of all again queen h8 is not
forced nobody is not forced i could play
queen g6 there's nothing right that i
see is wrong with it there is some
argument right to be made for bishop a1
it's not that ridiculous no you get a
bishop
a rook by the way a very good and a very
good bishop too a very good bishop and
control over the e5 square
i would call that
slightly better for white but close to
full close to full compensation
absolutely absolutely no no no that's
your bailout that's a bailout option
probably if fobby doesn't need it
because he's had this position in front
of his computer
and
okay let's look at the more okay we just
take everything everything everything
any i mean that pawn
stands out like a sore thumb on g5 but
it's the only thing that stands out as
this war thumb i'm underdeveloped a
little bit but right but
okay uh
i'm
i'm wondering is it that easy for you to
develop your queen side
because if i play bishop e6 just to
point it out you take take and at the
end of the day c7 will be hanging
precisely whether it's
throwing in rook d2 or not i don't think
it's
necessary to analyze right roxas 7 will
be very strong yeah but winning my pawn
back just feels like
you're being too cooperative what is
your threat though
that's that's that's kind of
it's a good question i mean i'll bring
my bishop out right
and if i go rook d2
i'll hide i think this queen hides on e5
on e5 even well that's really rubbing
salt into the wound right because i
think that if you go rook d5
yeah the rook's okay but it'll get hit
yeah i was
thinking of hitting the knight and
forcing it back to
but now that you've already occupied e5
you're going to go back to f6 and
that's actually okay right i don't have
six looks nice the queen on e5 is very
very stubbornly placed uh christian what
do you have for us bale is out
well there are two players that got
surprised in today's round one of them
is of course uh
yanni pognashi but another one is timur
rajabov who is actually pretty much in
the same situation when it comes to time
spencer up to this point and yasser you
were mentioning this move queen h5 as
one of the favorites of hikaru nakamura
well we have it on the board and it's
actually a novelty in this game so let's
see what happened we got all the way to
this position this is following the main
line that you guys discussed that game
between fabiano caruana and kramnik uh
was played with the move knight to f3
that was the most played movie in the
position as well as a4 trying to hook
this over extended pawn on b5 but uh
better than uh hooking the pawn on b5
and offering in exchange is actually
attacking it so why not queen to h5 it
makes a lot of sense now
let's see what the right move here is it
seems like it's d5 which is a very very
difficult move to make another pawn
sacrifice after that for some uh elusive
uh compensation because after uh d5
queen takes d5 you have to play
something like queen bishop to g4 and
actually sacrifice another pawn allow
white to potentially take uh on b5 i
understand you have this move bishop to
e2 coming on the ball you have the two
bishops cutting the board in half you
have this bishop on b6 attacking this
pawn on f2 so bishop p2 is a real threat
but white can continue taking pawns
white can also play uh for a strategical
purpose with the move knight to b3 and
after bishop to e2 i'm going to say okay
i'm going to give you
that exchange but i'm going to get all
my pieces out and potentially this is
what might uh be uh some how his
preparation hikaru's preparation from
home now he did not see any of that
because black played the move queen to
c6 defending the pawn on b5 makes a lot
of sense rook to e1 was played
instantaneously
right now and this has a clear plan i'm
gunning for the square d5 i need to get
my knight there the way i do that i'm
going to go knight to f1 bishop to e3
we're going to exchange that and then
get the knight to d5 if i manage to get
that dream position uh on the board and
i'm just simply going to be uh killing
you strategically right now with the
white pieces so team or a job of one
hour and eight minutes and counting
right now hikaru nakamura one hour and
56 minutes almost an extra hour for
hikaru on the clock this one is going to
be a very very tough defense for timur
rajab but he had a similar situation
yesterday against ali reza he was out
prepared and after that he managed to
turn the tables and became
well found a way to get a better
position in that game let's see if he
manages to turn the tables in this game
against ikaru as well
fascinating stuff thank you christian as
we get ready for our first break we want
to tell you about cue boutique what do
we got for our viewers today well
remember that across the street from the
st louis chess club we have the world
chess hall of fame which is depicted
here in this logo with their giant king
the tallest chest piece in the world and
this t-shirt commemorating mind art and
experience the current exhibit
commemorating the 10-year anniversary of
the world chess hall of fame here in st
louis is available at qboutiquestl.gov
all of these purchases really help all
of our projects here not just at the
club but in the st louis chess campus
which we include of course the world
chess hall of fame they put amazing
exhibits all related to chess art and
music it really is an incredible venue
if you have not checked it out i highly
highly recommend you take a trip down to
st louis and see it 10 years young my
goodness how the years have flown by i
remember the opening
ceremony uh to commemorate the hall of
fame but here are our standings as we go
on our commercial break yep these are
our standings fabian yacht playing
against each other they're at the top of
the leaderboard having won their first
game and we will be back in a few
minutes to catch more of their game
[Music]
by now you guys probably know there's a
lot to see and do in st louis but when
it comes to the art scene
there's more here than meets the eye
from lao meyer sculpture park and the
city garden to the stunning cathedral
basilica one of the largest mosaic
collections in the entire world
so if art is your thing
st louis is on display all year long
ooh
now that's an exhibit
saint lou is always exploring
can you hear it
it's the sound of hope
and health
and strength
it's the sound of compassion
of open doors
where people and machines are in tune
and miracles occur
it's the sound of personalized
healthcare
and active communities
it sounds like life
and it's what you hear
when you really listen
a st louis public radio journalist's
most precious possession isn't a notepad
camera
microphone or recording device their
most precious possession
is credibility
a journalist's work revolves around the
truth
finding it
verifying it
and reporting it
great journalists work hard to find the
facts and put those facts into context
examining all the arguments and
including differing opinions
amplifying fascinating voices from our
community
telling captivating stories
offering facts that may have been
omitted
we work every day to earn your trust for
news turn to st louis public radio
we all know st louis is a championship
sports town from the 11 time world
champion cardinals to the stanley cup
champion blues
but i bet you didn't know about all the
championship places there are to get out
and play here like the world chess hall
of fame westport social and topgolf and
now even our own mls team so whatever
sports your team is into you can always
bring out your a game in st louis
oops sorry
lou is always exploring
[Music]
st louis university celebrating its
200th anniversary offering world-class
education in the heart of saint louis
slough attracts students and professors
from around the globe in 2015 slu
partnered with the saint louis chess
club to start a top-tier collegiate
chess team on the very first year of the
team's inception slu obtained second
best university at the pan-american
intercollegiate chess championships
higher purpose
greater good
st louis university
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to stay in
chess the candidates edition we have
these standings after one round of play
two winners fabi and jan at top and
guess what folks they are playing
against one another and
uh
alejandro and i just throwing our hands
in the air and going what's going on
because we just don't know
and uh what a game
right into it definitely let's do it we
have a new move by network it finally
seems that fabiano carrana is going to
think in this game because he has been
blitzing out his preparation all the way
to move 16 and finally his move rook a3
has caught him off guard it is
not a move that i would have considered
right at all
our
instinct was it should be too and we
weren't making frankly speaking we
weren't really making white's uh
position work after knight takes d4
alejandro so
rook a3
but okay of this movie if i take on d4
anyway
uh i'm coming across i'm coming across
let's do it knight takes knight takes
stick with a bishop and that was
actually a pause there because
there's there's some
maybe some details yeah okay
you might consider taking with the queen
for the tempo
but it feels so natural too exactly the
queen
um in a position where bishop b2 can hit
it right
okay so
seriously i it's not a joke
i want something along the lines of a
knight f5
and a rook g3 kind of thing
uh
i'm going to start
with
maybe
maybe an awkward move let me let me let
me play an awkward move you're going to
play knight e5 because you're a nice guy
i'm going to drop back with the bishop
and where i really want to go i'll give
you a heads up like i'd love for you to
play the move bishop e6 i don't know if
that's a tempo waster or not
and
what i'm really really hoping for
is
compensation
for the pawn based on ideas of rook g3
and i know it's illegal but yes i would
play rook g3 and f4
i'm upon down i do protect the d3 square
you've got good looking minor pieces for
the moment
but
there is a
wobbly king it's a wobbly king but is it
really that wobbly you don't have a pair
of bishops it's it's not a very clean
pair of bishops in the sense that i feel
that black spawns are doing a good job
at stifling them especially the big pun
c1 right now by the pawns on g5 and h6
and i have the feeling that at some
point soon if we go down this variation
i'll be able to play something along the
lines of c6 and d5 and try to kill the
other bishop i i feel you i feel you but
uh
how do you say i'm trying to reach into
the mind of nepo uh which is harsha's
hunger i mean
dangerous yeah yeah yeah i mean
the the guy i have the most trouble with
lavon erroneous he comes up with ideas
that are just you know like uh crazy but
when i look at the move rook a3 uh
pardon me this is the last move and i
said okay what could he possibly be
thinking
he's gonna see he's seeing the trade
happening on d4 right
the third rank is going to be cleared
for the rook the moment i get to play
knight f5 as well and so that was why in
this line that we were looking at i was
going
here
hoping for rook g3 now you were
mentioning that there's no reason for
you to have to play bishop e6 you could
play for what did you say c6 and d5
yeah i thought c65 at some point i i
didn't mind actually losing the tempo
trying to kill the bishop trying to kill
the bishop i didn't mind losing the
tempo okay well let's do it then so take
take
six
and uh i
bring this rook which is actually not
doing uh a lot
and i assume
and now uh i've got to
i mean it's taking me it's taking a
while but you got there yeah yeah it was
like it's like the puncher who winds up
winds up larry christensen's guy it
carries a big stick you know but when he
hits you with f4
you could uh yeah it could be over it
could be over
well uh we'll let this do right
on slow and we'll go over to christian
and what do you have for us christian on
hikaru's game
well i have to say guys we are probably
living right now in the era of alien
chess because i mean these players all
come with all sorts of like alien
preparation we've seen fabiano and by
the way i love the move rook to a3 by
nepo taking the rook out of that
diagonal very dangerous diagonal
potentially getting it ready to swing on
the other side and okay you're losing a
pawn but you are going to lose that pawn
anyway so i like the move rook 283 and
also it throws him off he throws fabiano
off of his prep and right now
we're going to play mano amano and this
is exactly what i think nepo is uh
trying to achieve with that move to a3 i
really like it now let's talk about this
game between hikaru and timur rajabov
because i was going through the lines
and obviously timur has been off book
for a very long time hikaru is not and
we left it off after the move rook to e1
now the best move according to the
engine and this is why i'm saying we're
living in uh the alien chess era is
because as a top elite level player what
you're looking for within your
preparation is to give your opponent
very difficult exams over the board and
if you manage to do that and you are
more informed about the subject matter
as you go into these type of
complications then you're going to be in
a prime position take the full point
home now the best move for black in this
position
to uh continue is the move f5 wow sure
f5 you you might uh be able to make a
point that this is a normal move you're
opening up the rook uh this pawn is
going to be attacked by the bishop next
if you manage to get rook takes the f5
bishop takes f2 is also a big threat
but check out the continuation
after f6 now if you take on f6 you're in
trouble because rookie rook to e8 comes
on the board bishop to f5
is the best move in the position the
idea being that if you take with a queen
on f5 i'm going to go rook takes f6 and
that is actually giving black the
advantage but bishop to f5 from afar
when your opponent is blitzing out his
moves it's pretty much impossible to
find so you're not going to play f5
you're going to fail this test unless
you're
some super engine who knows but he did
not of course he did not play the move
f5 he played the normal rook to e8 the
problem with alien chess is that if you
play normal moves you're going to end up
in trouble and this is exactly what's
happening right now this is just a
strategically dangerous position for
black because as i was mentioning
previously bishop to e3 is the idea you
want to exchange the dark square bishops
and then this knight is going to be
able to roam around knight to d4 jump to
f5 get the rook swinging on the third
rank and trying to create an attack also
you have a tremendous pawn structure
right now as white black cannot say the
same thing this b5 pawn is very weak
this uh backwards pawn on the d file is
going to be the target of my pieces you
are kind of in danger right now now
you're looking at this position as timor
and you see the move knight to f3 almost
blitzed out
not really blitzed out so let's take a
look at this and i'm not 100 sure if um
this is a bug
or a feature of this move knight to f3
knight to f3 was played after five
minutes of thing the first thing of
hikaru nakamura's game now is he trying
to entice him to say okay maybe i don't
have this in my notes maybe you can take
the pawn on e4 come on take my pawn on
e4 if you take the pawn on e4 if you
touch this pawn after bishop to d2 the
game is over bishop to d2 it doesn't
look very obvious right but
it does have an immediate threat you
want to take on e4 followed by rook to
e1 and then you're not going to be able
to stop me from going rook to e8
checkmate so for example if you go d5
knight to g5 finishes the game right now
because i have too many threats i'm
attacking the rook pawn on h7 pawn on f7
the best thing you can get right now as
black is to play queen to g6 exchange
the queens and then lose an exchange you
don't want that this is completely over
and by the way this was not played d5
was played giving up a pawn just like
that after 20 minutes of a thing
pondering the option of potentially
taking on e4 probably uh getting to the
conclusion that that is too much quite
easily and now he decided to go d5 but
what is this what if i just simply take
it take it take take take
take
isn't this just a pawn up
i am going to go bishop to e3 next move
i am going to follow it up with rook to
d1
i i don't see it
i don't see the compensation
i i think right now hikaru is in prime
position to maybe uh bounce back with a
victory as early as round two is it so
clear though what is this bishop takes
the bishop
sure rook d1 rook d8
yay
let's go first of all i can also go rook
to d4 that's another
if you don't mind instead of bishop e4
go rook to d8 sure first okay then
you've got to go up to d1 and then let
me go
there should be no now you can go bishop
i like these transposes yeah just one
suppose i'm sorry so if you want to get
to this position you can right but why
is black work that rook d4
f5 so what if i go here first look d4 f5
how easy is this still
you have to be very fast f5 yeah f5 is
already plus two wow after knight to f3
so this already finishes the game pretty
much really if i trade and i i think
your runs are too big you you have to
spend too much time defending all your
all of your life let me try f6 instead
of f5 like f7 i can go rook to d5 and
work you're i understand you're going to
get a d6 pawn but you're going to lose
one of them and that's just a technical
right loss right we we accept that so we
think our f5 was an overreach yes
probably f6 is a good move bishop to c6
but that's the thing how easy
is this position to defend it i have a
feeling that you have to make very very
precise be scared to actually get when
you were close uh to equality and you're
dropping quite severely on your clock
right now uh 20 minute thing for that
move d5 i understand and again he was in
the same situation yesterday
timur so we know he can get out of it
right we know that he has the capability
to do that
let's see and by the way it does seem
like maybe this move d5 surprised hikaru
and that's another uh good thing about
the move d5 sure you're sacrificing the
pawn but maybe
this surprise might be worth it and
timor who knows maybe he's going to
escape
that that ending is so hard for for us
to judge uh christian because our first
instinct was that black should be doing
fine
that the d-pawn you know it was easy to
kind of it'll collapse oh yeah it'll be
collected one night harvest it but uh
well if it's uh better it's better move
d5
you just learn not to argue again yeah
exactly we should uh
you know
okay uh
that's one of the ways of avoiding the
strategic uh
yeah the clam the big clamp bishop to e3
knight comes to d4 is the practical
choice it's it's a very practical i like
it
me too now the question is
uh you look you looked at queen it takes
d5 is kind of like
the move another question i have is
takes i assume you would take right and
how about the these apples i mean
queen c4 something along those lines
queen to c4 queen c5 bishop e3 might
exactly you you don't want to um
allow bishop to e3 queen to c5 i see
well you are tickling bishop to g4 i'm
not happy about that yeah which is why
queen takes d5 is better yeah all right
very good i want to go back to fabi's
game because rook a3 again this will be
our marquee matchup the players have
kind of drifted down the line we thought
about
alejandro knight takes default it takes
you got to do it you got it
nothing to discuss knight takes d we
didn't think bishop takes was better
than queen takes and bishop takes us
played quickly right h3 i need to get
rid of this knight which is kind of
pestering me
and h3 on the board and we went knight
e5 i dropped back with the bishop
and
we got to a position
that was like this and suddenly
it's like the fairway you know the rook
on a3 is looking across the board and
it's going if i could get to g3 that's
where i belong well it worked yesterday
for him
yes it did
he he demolished
kingside
did a nepo uh with an attack that went
with g5 there was a
rover a rook up and over and here we're
seeing it again
deja vu
by the way it was a wonderful line by
george carlin have you ever heard of
vuja day
vuja day
is that uncanny moment
that you have when you realize none of
this has ever happened before
george carlin it was just genius
rook the g3
again you had mentioned c6 as
a way of kind of closing off this bishop
but i gotta tell you
uh i
i wouldn't want to be in fabi's shoes
after you see this move king h1 you see
ideas of bishop takes g5 and f4 and it's
easier to play the attack than the
defense
no i i can't disagree with that right
five is going to be
have to be precise and it is a nepo type
of position and i think he's going to be
happy about that he gave up a pawn has
the initiative can play quickly
he loves this type of kr
kind of chaos yeah yeah stylistically
this is very much nepo right so i think
he'll be thrilled to be playing this
position today there was a guy ben
larson we accused him of being a coffee
house player and he was
but boy what a great coffee house player
i mean he had tactics everywhere and he
was really really an enjoyable
force in the world of chess because he
would be sacrificing when we we we would
be defending squares and defending our
structures
bent would be like why don't you play h4
hype
it's like go away go away leave us alone
no no it's a good idea
let me show you and uh this is a nepa
position
he likes his count absolutely not
position yeah um let's uh let fabi's two
here a little bit whether he wants to
put the knight on e5 on f6 i'm sure that
he's looking at plenty let's go to
christian see what he has in store for
us
i'm not going to uh comment too much
about the specifics of the game i just
want you guys to take a look at the
journey of black species yes and we're
going to start with a queen right queen
to b8 queen to a7 let's keep going a4
queen to a5
this was the moment we actually left
this game and this is by the way the
game between yanshi
and dingley wren one that we haven't
spent too much time on because
it's quite a tense position right now
but not a lot of things are happening
there is a dance a strategical dance
that's happening right now so let's take
a look bishop to b6 we were quite
intrigued where is this bishop going
let's take a look where that is going
queen to c2 king to h7 queen to a7 back
okay the queen did something on a5 i'm
100 sure what it provoked perhaps the
move c4 maybe now i'm going back
i'm going to go back
and i'm going to play c5
locking my bishop up like that is that
how you play chess apparently yes
because you still have one pawn that can
move once again to c6 and then that's
going to open up not only the bishop but
also the queen and this is exactly
what's happening right now
we have this position on the board a lot
of maneuvering has happened white is
definitely getting close to playing the
move f4 the move that he wants to play
in the position open up and try to get
some sort of initiative on the king's
side now at the same time when that
happens the position might open up i
like this move queen to d7 so
the queen left from d8
b8 a7 a5 a7 d7
you could have played queen d7 in one
move
instead of that you did you how many one
two three four five you played 27 in
five months quite interesting uh journey
this queen had right now and getting
ready to meet f4 with the counter attack
in the center d5 this is exactly what i
think
the discussion is going to revolve
around so very interesting position i
have to say the two bishops right now
they're closed but they have the
potential to be open later in the game
when d5 which is going to come on the
board at one time or another now i can
also get ready to play that move with
the move knight to e7 knight on g8 right
now is not doing anything as long as i
managed to stabilize the position on the
king's side and repel your attack
because your attack is coming with f4 if
i manage to do that
i have to say i'm starting to like the
prospect of the two bishops coupled with
the fact that i also have some targets
on this side i have the nice b file open
and d5 is going to come with a lot of
consequences for the position and the
white pieces i'm starting to like being
chances in this one remarkable i wasn't
i wasn't looking at d6
i was looking at knight e7 right g6 g5
knight g6 i've looked at that i looked
at f5 i actually played this structure a
lot it's a funny thing that chess kind
of transposes uh itself right even
though i've never really played e4 e5
i'm a career i'm a sicilian player for a
very long time specifically sebastian
cuff in my younger years so i faced the
roso limo a lot i played a lot of these
lines bishop b5 you take on c6 i have i
usually talk with the b-pawn nowadays
people take with the d-pawn and i got
all these kind of structures where you
have the pair of bishops with this
particular setup of c4 d3 e4 against c5
c6 d6 e5 fascinating struggles and you
never aspired for d5 yourself you
aspired for f5 i aspired for f5 for g5
very often you get the f4 square i want
some important games there are never in
my life i should be going for uh d5 but
the chess evolves well there you go uh
uh i have a question from the
join the conversation and i think this
is an interesting one because i know my
answer for this one and i know my answer
for the previous candidates
do you think that there are any players
that are out of place in this tournament
and would you replace it with somebody
like mvl wesley chris chuck levon geary
et cetera et cetera et cetera et cetera
for sure players are missing but guess
what the eight players that are here
each and every one of these players
deserve to be here they earn their spot
there's no question that lavonne
aneesh mbl would fit comfortably in such
an exalted group as we've got but look
there can only be eight players in the
candidates you can't have a 16 player
candidates but yes
there are some personal favorites lavon
mdl i mean i love all of those players
but these guys deserve it yeah and i
think that perhaps in previous
candidates because of the way that
qualification cycles happen because of
wild cards because of many different
factors we have had players in the past
where you think yeah he's strong but
what is he doing in the candidates right
uh is he really going to play magnus
carlsen and win right no very unlikely
yeah very unlikely and in this
particular candidates yeah you still
have a couple of players that if you
imagine a match for example carlos and
rajabo i don't think anybody's really
giving taymor a big a big chance a big
chance but they were still a top player
but then you look at the the other
rookies and you say okay richard rapport
plays out of his mind
the tournament of his life he becomes a
challenger you go well this is a very
young man yeah very very creative
2017 something he can do something he
can definitely do
another very another very early
again all very young they're their
maiden experience if you will yeah and
um if they win it would be a bit of an
upset but
then again i i kind of like to say i
kind of i would like to see it and play
and i feel that for this particular
candidates um replacing somebody like
duda or rapport with yiri or with mvl i
don't think it's a big difference geary
and mvl are not particularly in shape
even though mvl has done better in the
past couple of months exactly uh he had
a year of just bad results yeah he
wasn't very pleased with himself he also
hasn't been really playing a lot of
chess and the chats that he has played
hasn't been particularly impressive he
participated in the grand prix didn't
come close richard carlified in the same
tournament exactly and that fabulously
right right so
and this year i don't feel so
no i mean no i i love the group that we
have i just wanted to turn our attention
uh please for just a moment to the game
of richard and alireza because for me uh
this position after bishop e3
i love these uh strategic strategic
fights and i love this milk bishop e3
controlling some very important key
squares and i thought
that
my favorite thing in chesapeake beside
giving you checkmate
is actually developing the tempo
i love
just attacking your piece
forcing your your piece to move and i
get the development and if i can do it
again and again and again it's just i
win the game so here i thought the move
bishop e3 was a prelude to castle and
long so that i could develop with tempo
and attack the bishop on d6 well
look at my surprise
that he went castles and i was forcibly
reminded of yesterday's game where
hikaru castled king side and moved that
we really really didn't like and in fact
it turned out to haunt him he never
recovered and and instead of castling
queenside your take would you have been
like me
eager to play the move knight c3 castles
and knight
uh
a4 or would you take the same approach
that richard took
i would have castle along so fast
it's so hard
i would have forgotten that i could
castle short
is that legal you would have asked
yourself i could actually play that
you know grandmaster experience in the
structure is that even though the king
is on the side where the rooks want to
be it proves very useful at defending
pawns especially especially the b2 pawns
right right so that was just a different
approach all together by richard and i
mean power to them f7 f6 is not again
the first move that comes to mind for me
i mean
to my way of thinking the e5 pawn looks
pretty well defended you would play a
move like f7 f6 if you really were
thinking of
you know
putting your king on f7 f7 f6 rook c1
and uh
my first instinct is that i prefer white
because of the the the damaged pawn
structure i understand the two bishops
uh just feels that uh richard's got a
little pull what's your uh
i feel that if anybody has a pool today
it's going to be richard and remember
today is happy birthday happy birthday
to ali reza perugia 19th birthday nobody
wants to lose on their birthday that's
just not nice especially in the
candidates
19 so qualifying at 18 at 18 i wasn't
even a grand master
i mean getting to the cannon i remember
when bobby fischer
got the grandmaster title at 15 by
becoming a candidate
right oh very nice and i said
that is a record that will never be
broken never nobody nobody could
possibly become a grand master before
the age of 15.
judah bogart
we've had so many people do it that now
it's 12 years you beat bobby's right i
beat bobby's record
damn yeah i think he was like two two
months older than i was but juden was
younger than me right judith was awesome
wow okay and by the way after rook c
alireza defended the pawn on c6 with the
move rook a6
does not look very good
that does not look very good it is
definitely seizing the defensive right
it does hold on because of the bishops
right right but
what an ugly move
it feels peculiar well definitely
christian return it to you this is still
such a
better and improved version of what
richie had yesterday
agreed because there's the absence of
the light square bishops and that's why
you can put the rook on a6 there's
nobody going to attack it there's no
light square bishop that is going
through it it's a much improved version
of what he had now i understand white
still has the pressure definitely still
has the strategical pressure he's the
only one that can try to accommodate
black's position especially because of
that weakness on c6 but again the
absence of the light square bishop the
fact that uh black has uh the bishop yes
sir you were mentioning that yesterday
that black has the bishop and you were
writing this a very nice speech and then
alejandro pointed out that white also
has the bishop
so that kind of cancels uh each other
right and the speech was wonderful
really right up until the point that the
obvious was stated it was a beautiful
speech i have to say thank you thank you
very much
now but i want to uh point your
attention to this game and i'll let you
analyze it sure we discussed d5 ideas
knight to e7 ideas followed by knight to
g6 rook to ba to focus on the b2 pawn
after bishop d2
guess what the move
that dingley wren chose was and i'll
give you one choice before you see that
fortunately i saw the movie you saw the
movie unfortunately i i haven't seen the
move but i would guess it's g5 i mean
that's the logical move in the position
what you mentioned from your example
[Music]
you play g5 before you go f5 as the most
ambitious way of playing if white gives
me the ability to play g5 you play it
automatically he did and so he did we
have g5 uh on the board right now f4 is
no longer an option
what i see right now is a weakness and a
square on f5 that i should try to
capitalize on and the way to do that is
somehow get the other knight from h to
the knight on g3 is already nicely
placed there the knight from h2 to go
all the way to f5 the square the
transition square that i can use is the
square e3 now how do i get there rook to
b1 it seems to be the computer's choice
followed by knight to f1 knight to e3
and knight to f5 stop you or at least
get ready for your pawn storm on this
side how do we assess
this position guys i mean i'm totally
biased i like black i like black i i
love the structures for black is they
gave me such good results that it's
difficult for me to see this objectively
i love black's position i know you're
not worried about the bishop b6 at all i
don't care uh i mean i just don't care
no he doesn't no he doesn't worry i
really don't i literally don't i worry
he doesn't worry yeah what about the
bishop of v6 for me the the square f5 is
the main deal right i have a septic
bishop on b6 which means that if i lose
control of f5 my game is over you will
win
but it doesn't really get there from my
experience by the moment you're prepared
to go knight e3 i play the move f5 right
and then i solve all my problems
well from my perspective it's about
breaks right right okay
so as white
i'm basically nursing two breaks f2 f4 b
b2 b4 b3 i'm not really touching the
queen side because the last thing i want
to do is play the move b4 and invite c5
takes b4 and this bishop on
v6
suddenly becomes a god uh i can't play
f4 thanks to your
last move g5
for me
i go okay
uh i'm going to have to completely take
a different turn and approach this
position from the
from the fact that i've got to fight for
the light squares i love what you were
saying christian about transiting the
knight
through g4 to e3 and eventually to this
promised land of f5
g4 is a bit difficult
so for the moment g4 you'll take twice
so i'm going to play an ugly move rookie
one will i thought you go 90
maybe not i'm not sure uh i was going to
go queen d1 my queen on c2 is doing
nothing and i was thinking that okay on
a good date maybe i'll pop out with
queen h5 but really what i was thinking
i was going to try to do is go knight to
g4 to e3 to f5 but i feel like i'm
playing for equality as well that's
right right that you're not really
playing for the advantage here no i the
the promise of an advantage has kind of
faded so now that your queen is on d1 no
longer defending the pawn on d3 i want
to get my knight to f4 fast so knight g6
knight g4 and maybe i catch you with
knight four how do you defend
exactly well unfortunately
it's getting worse and worse uh bishop
c1 will be awkwardly met by bishop a5 i
want to be able to play knight e3 i
don't want to take
on
well
tactically maybe you do maybe yeah is
this completely crazy so because i think
i'm going to take with the g pawn
g-pawn is this going is this awkward or
negative king g6 guys
i have a bishop that's doing nothing on
b6 give it a job
now yeah or before come on right now
bishop died no no no no no but king oh
bishop to e8 oh king g6 you're not gonna
take the knight what how do you defend
it well i understand i'm not gonna take
it immediately no you're not going to
take the night i was going to play it
slow bishop the air and queen of seven i
don't see the issue
you're still not gonna take that i still
are gonna take the knife but you take
and then go rook g8 and you're gonna
yeah no i'm gonna be happy
i don't know about this no that that
that why are you but now i can take your
knight
i take your bishop and i take on h3 and
thank you very much for oh you take on
f3
oh so i have to move my king yuck
right
maybe that wasn't
well the game goes on yeah it's it's a
melee i'm not 100 sure
who this
favors but uh
the ding for ding after
losing
how crucial is it for him to bounce back
i don't think we can overstate the
importance of this game for dinglery
right the way that his candidates
started last year was so disastrous
starting zero out of two
did he lose the second round as well
yeah oh my gosh yeah so he he really he
was out of the tournament before it
began that's all that was the problem he
lost to i think he made a draw and then
he beat favi and even then he was still
not really in contention right actually
finished uh the first half either on
minus two or minus three i forgot oh my
gosh uh so fort ding
this is a huge
huge tournament he's going out of china
which has been very difficult it's been
very difficult to do especially coming
back lockdowns endemic lockdown so he
really needs to take this at this
opportunity losing on the first round
okay hurts but you need to come back at
some point i think he looks at this game
and he says look
this is actually a decent opportunity
very very decent i mean
this is a very double-edged position in
which black got a lot of moves in right
that perhaps he shouldn't have and
indeed it's very hard for white uh to
play moves like f2 f4 again the brakes
are not on white side
and it's going to be a fight for these
light squares and the queen on c2 needs
to
return into the game if you don't mind i
just want to see what is going on in our
marquee match up between our two two
ornament leaders
we left it at bishop a2 and
not bishop e6 and not c6 d5 a different
approach altogether zhabi played c5
makes
sense cement the bishop
defends the bishop okay
takes and uh
do you want to take with the pawn or do
you want to pick up a tempo against the
rook that's
that's always the question
the other thing is that actually the
rook doesn't have a great square i was
about to say where is my word
moving after bishop it takes c5
just a second let me just put this on
the board wait a second yeah okay
so b3
would be a lousy square oh no b3 is okay
sorry
uh
b
rook b3 is okay because bishop e6
will be met by knight f5
and uh and
a2 is hanging yeah a8 behind me the
opposite of what i just said a2 is
defended i can play rook takes b7 on my
next move i'm a little confused what if
i play queen f6 here rook takes a7 it
takes b7 i understand things b7 uh but i
mean first of all i wouldn't be
completely unhappy about uh bishop a2 i
don't i don't know why i'm unhappy about
taking that one also right but after you
take on b7 can't i throw in knight d3
isn't it going to be dangerous for you
at some point
probably
i would start with knight d3 even i
think
okay i don't know let's just uh throw it
out there quickly knight f2
oh
[Laughter]
is that if that's really good then i'm
going to oh because bishop on a2 is
hanging
there's some trickies right rook f2
bishop a2 maybe bishop e3 works yeah it
could be one of those
you know blunders turned brilliant
right right
oh dear although i'm not sure my e7
check is a big threat at the moment
don't forget that
that when i play the move bishop e3 my
rook is no longer pinned so knight e7
check is definitely on my agenda
wow this is really intriguing okay it
already happened but do you mind if i
just ask a question
forget my queen side
like okay
i'll try you got it you got it if i had
maybe ah
c4 maybe some idea like this is what i
was
kind of aspiring yeah like so something
similar oops excuse me something similar
to what we have looked at previously i
don't mind the the b pawn yeah but c4 is
actually
the problem the problem i think that
crushing the bishop on a2 would be
difficult for white to meet well let's
we have a tweet we have a tweet let's
let fabby's two over there he wants to
take on c5 with a partner with the
bishop uh from youtube our
number one fan here patrick patrick how
are you feeding return to the older
style of candidates with match-based
tournaments like fisher one so the
knockout system that we had candidate
matches for example in kazan i guess
yeah uh would that significantly affect
the odds of someone like ding win oh
that's a good question
personally i love the match play i like
the match
the problem always with the matches was
the organization of the matches so hard
and you would have
you know 12
organizers bidding for the match between
lavon and rhonian and magnus carlson and
then zero knitting for the match between
yes or sarah and robert right like like
what you know so it was very very
awkward in the past uh for the fide to
organize match play i love the match
play when you think about the world
champion being world championship being
a match you kind of think well i need
some training in match play if i'm going
to play magnus and match right how did
you feel about mini matches like in
kazan 2009 i think 2009 no but
that would make ding's chances of
qualifying worse you think so oh yeah if
a match is a six-game match
ding is a big favorite match is a
12-game match
the favorite of of dean goes much higher
the match is a two-game match like it is
in the world cup yeah and it's an
immediate knockout
ding doesn't become a favorite after
three such matches of two
games uh each i have to explain i do
think that the longer the matches go the
better for ding specifically right i
remember match
it was 1974.
the winner of the match gets to play
bobby fischer
very good
victor corchenoy
anatoly karpov
played the finals of the candidate
matches
how many games did they play
24. are you serious 24. wait the final
of the candidates the finals at the 1974
and it was three to two karpov one plus
three lost two it was that close it's a
24 game match
bobby fischer forfeited and anatoly
karpov uh won so imagine how long those
matches were but why was it 24 i have no
idea
right no it was the first to six and a
half
uh
or was it with the first five and a half
pardon me um
bobby fischer defeated uh mark taimanov
zero but it was a it was a six game
match no i think it was a 12 game match
or a 10 game match in the first five and
a half and he won 6-0
you have to score five and a half i
thought that it was a six game match he
won and you had to play them out anyway
bobby fischer won against ben larson six
to nothing no no the match was over i i
understand that i think they were
originally scheduled to play ten games
the first to score five and a half i
have to
uh my great predecessor that was
completely awful and then uh in the in
the semifinals against tigran oh pardon
me the finals against tiga and petrosian
uh that was a bit longer and uh
yeah and uh tigran actually uh
stopped bobby fischer streak of like 21
and 0.
yeah one was a forfeit by oscar pano in
the inter zonals but uh wow
okay um and and just to please chris up
to that question i i do think that it
would decrease if we go back to the mini
matches version of the candidates it
would decrease uh players like dean's
chances quite a lot let's take a look at
the world cup which is mini matches
right magnus didn't even win it
in a lot of tries right he just right he
got knocked off by duda anything can
happen in a mini match in a two-game
mini match four game mini match
absolutely anything can happen and
speaking of kazan 2009
gelfand won that in that mini match
version of the candidates and he was uh
by no means the rating favorite no to go
and challenge vichy and but after he won
that he gave on on the fight of his life
yes he did
he just got lost the match in the rapid
tie breaks and if i remember correctly
he had a winning position right in the
rapid tie breaks as well and he could
have clinched the match so
in a match uh situation and uh this ties
the previous question as well is any of
uh the players here not worthy of being
a contender even a guy like rajabov
in a match in a 16 game 14 game match
anything can happen he can come up with
incredible preparation and give a player
like magnus a very hard fight and this
is exactly what we want to see and this
is exactly what we hope to achieve uh
through the system that we have right
now so i think there's no mismatch
interest especially in a world
championship match as well as the
candidates but yes i do believe that
ding
ding's chances to actually go to the
world championship would diminish if we
return to the 2009 let's say version of
the candidates
thank you christian and of course our
schedule this is the pace
three
rounds of play followed by a free day
all throughout
and there's our schedule as we are in
round two saturday june 18th we've had
all kinds of formats throughout the
years i think that nothing has stood out
to me that is much better than the
others i like the tournament format of
the candidates i also understand it's
incredibly grueling it is it is an
outstanding tournament compared to
everything else just because both the
time control are is so long
and the quality of the play and the
you have to be in the best form of
violence yeah exactly i uh i'm cheating
a bit but uh you asked the question i
answer on a break you had asked me do i
was there somebody i held a grudge
against
and by the way before i get that yeah a
shout out to reddit our chess on reddit
because i did ask them uh it's a forum
on the internet that yeah you know they
have a lot of questions for us if they
had anything directly for you yasser
there you
go a user
uh a grudge a grudge yes yes or sarah
one hold a grudge against someone if
someone who yes exactly and uh
so because i got a chance to really
think about it my first instinct was no
but then i remember
1973
the washington state junior championship
was held in walla walla washington
and the players were billeted in the
organizer's home and we had our sleeping
bags and we just kind of slept on the
family carpet there
and i started really strong like three
out of three something really really
good and my dear friend
john donaldson
took my pillow
and stuck it into the freezer
i had this very and everybody was
waiting for me
to come to the sleeping bag so there's
my my pillow and i like face planted
this frozen pillow
they cracked up and my my tournament
went south
that was the worst part it actually
worked
and so i was really angry with john for
a whole week
it was brutal
so this is this is this is the actual
way of beating these top players
put their pillow in the freezer they'll
never recover that is funny we're going
to take a break and we're going to see
you on the other
[Music]
we're the side
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
when you visit st louis you'll probably
want to watch the cardinals or the blues
what about after the game
heading back to the hotel would be a
major error
instead boogie through the city and
discover the music that gave the blues
their name at the national blues museum
broadway oyster bar or even the
legendary blueberry hill so whether you
love the cardinals the blues or the
blues come play with us
and you guys know i can't play this
right
st lou is always exploring
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody we are here round
number two of the candidates this is the
tournament to determine the challenger
for the world championship match and so
far we've had two decisive games in the
tournament fabira karana defeating
hikaru nakamura with the white pieces
and yandere ponyachi doing the same to
dean loren but with the black pieces
they sit at the top of the leaderboard
and importantly they are facing each
other you're looking at a huge huge game
and that's 2-0 it's just going to be
hard to catch they're giving us a thrill
it's not a quiet
game by any stretch of the imagination
tons of things are happening let's jump
into it exactly well as you will
certainly uh gather jan has sacrificed a
pawn
uh to try to take advantage of the
weaknesses around
fabi's king after we left the position
just after the move c5 we saw uh b take
c5 bobby was thinking should i take with
the pawn should they take with the
bishop he decided tempe is important he
took with the bishop the rook went to b3
keeping in mind that bishop on a2 is
defended a move like bishop e6 is just
going to be met by rook takes b7
after the move b5 this is kind of what i
wanted previously i'm going to ignore
the queen side i'm going to jump to with
knight to f5 which is exactly what uh
ian has done as he's prepping
a rook to slide over to the king side
he's going to want to move his king in
order to make the move f2 f4 possible if
white can get in those moves it's simply
game over
rook g3 king h1 f4 game over black has
to be
accurate
how is uh fabi going to be accurate well
my first instinct is that i can take
this knight on f5 whenever i want uh so
maybe i can move my queen to f6 first
unless i have a direct problem all right
let's let's look at the obvious queen to
f6 you have possibilities of playing
something like knight h6 first of all
i'm not really sure that they work out
right away and second even if you do get
in the move rook they don't work right
away right because the rook on g3 is
undefended right uh but even if you did
it's too many pieces so i'm not afraid
of h6 sacrifices
let me just show the audience
i mean it's it's it's one of those
combinations that when you make it
you're feeling so gosh darn good about
what you're doing
until you have that cold shower uh
that we all experience we played the
move rook g3 now what you're saying i've
already given up to jesus and you're
going to give up a rook and when he
takes our rook
we get the bad news kind of like kind of
like wesley pointing out you're in check
you can't take that
you're in check uh but okay uh
fair enough you go queen of six
it was in fact played yes all right i'll
i'll slide my rook over inviting uh you
to win a second pawn okay let's do it
okay
now
didn't take that much convincing uh
bishop f5 ef queen f5 right i am i'm
assuming i mean i'm not really compelled
to take this bomb but i also don't see a
reason not to exactly okay so
i love my bishop on a2 but
you know you're always always asking
yourself these very salient questions
where will my piece be stronger if i
have a white knight would it be stronger
on f5 would it be stronger on d5 should
i start with the move bishop
uh
no
who's defending the mission
it was one of those wonderful
combinations
where i go bishop takes g5 attacking the
queen
okay then in that case would you believe
plan b i'll move my king wow
okay where's where's my mouse so that i
can move my chain
do you see yes on the right side all
right yeah okay i think i have a
battery it should be then we do okay we
will
we came prepared i saw that uh battery
document yeah they're ready we got ready
oh
am i overlooking knight d3 yeah i didn't
really know what you were gonna do i
just did
gosh darn it i apologize i'm overlooking
knight d3
oh well
this makes it much harder for me to
achieve my desired
f2 f4 yeah because knight d3 is a real
threat i mean you are forking too many
things and i don't see enough initiative
to just give up that much material right
so
what is white's move here
well h4 will
okay
let's just take a look what will h4
produce or not
again i am having problems with my mouth
so i will
may have to uh throw it to christian
while i get uh
a battery repair h4 let's do it well it
says christian maybe he can take it off
from in this position uh
this is very sharp and i want to know
what the computer thinks of nepal's play
so far me too sure yeah why not guys i
mean i was actually looking at the game
between the ashish and ding but this one
is extremely interesting as well queen
to f6
the computer actually wanted to take the
pawn on a4 so the way uh he was doing it
was take on f5 take on a5 take on a4
rook to g3 and now it was just a battle
of 10ps because i need to get off the g
file and you need to get off the g file
as well with your king in order to play
the move f4 so the way it happens is
like king to h2 and i get out just in
time to avoid this move f4 be ready
whenever you play the move f4 to take it
take it and then just challenge you on
the g file with the move rook to g8 so
this one does seem like black is still
in control of the position and he
doesn't get checkmated if somehow you
manage to open up the b1 h7 diagonal by
playing the move f6 then probably black
is going to be in trouble but
fortunately the queen is doing a
tremendous job for the simple fact that
there's no knights on the board there's
no knights for white of course there's
one knight on the board in the center
but there's no knights for white if a
knight would be on the board and would
land on d5 that would be game over
that's not going to happen there's no
clear way of you getting this queen out
and this pawn despite the fact that it's
doubled is going to go to a3 is going to
be nicely protected by the bishop on c5
and it's going to be a tremendous asset
later on in uh the game demanding the
attention of the bishop on a2 to
restrict it from going to promotion so
the pawn on a4 is quite an asset right
now despite the fact that it's doubled
this is what the engine recommended now
if you go
queen to f6 and rook to g3 is the move
that you guys were mentioning and of
course right now we can still go into
the variation with b takes a4 but you
want to take this other pawn right on f5
not uh on well
but why would you take this pawn this
poem seems it was free
i understand but this one is free as
well this is this is the question that
he needs to answer and to ask himself
which one
is more free than the other and i feel
the pawn on a4 is freer i guess than the
pawn on f5 because if you take this one
this almost acts as a shield for my
position at least the way i see it
because bishop to b1 at times if you do
take and open up this diagonal could
come and could invite a danger around my
king now if you take this one there's no
consequences
and i will put the pawn on a3 and there
will be consequences but for white so
this is the way i see it i see this pawn
as a shield i see it as more of a
liability for white if you take it then
i'm just simply going to go h4 and i'm
going to hook your pawn and try to open
the position like that i'm going to
invite later on the king to go to h2 and
then go f4 double uh that attack and uh
continue the avalanche as follows so i'm
not 100 sure if taking on f5 makes a lot
of sense
i like this a pawn much more than the
pawn on f5 and of course he doesn't have
to take any of them by the way he played
the move queen to f6 but at some point
you need to get rid of this knight
because this knight is like tarantula
around
my king getting ready to jump uh into
the attack and by the way after rook to
g3 you have an immediate big threat that
is knight takes h6 bishop takes g5 is
going to come and you know the king is
just going to be completely in shambles
so
knight to f5 an interesting decision
sacrificing a pawn queen to f6 rook to
g3 is not on the board so right now nepo
still has the option of potentially
saving this pawn on a4 by exchanging it
or by pushing it to a5 that's going to
lose a tempe for himself so
big moment right now how are we doing on
time 43 minutes one hour and three
minutes uh now
the way i see this position is also it's
a battle of uh styles but i feel like
this position actually is advantageous
to both players we know nepo is
comfortable in this type of situations
but fabiano also is extremely
comfortable uh with his king being under
attack but him being able to calculate
to the maximum and this is exactly what
he's seeing right now all these
variations that we've been discussing
he's seeing those he's seeing the fact
that he's uh in time to get his king off
the g file and save himself and nurture
an extra pawn or two so
this is an interesting uh battle right
now between styles between two players
that are clearly in shape and it's going
to develop nicely i agree uh
wholeheartedly and uh christian if i
could just stay with you for a moment
there so my approach to
nepo's position is i want to open up the
king side and the more i'm looking at it
after the move queen f6 i was playing
rook g3 without too much consideration
h3h4 let's go let's open up yes let's
open up the game let's start like that
yeah no i like the move h4 and this is
definitely
the best movie is to take it
really yes
wow oh man that's that's never going to
happen i i don't see fabiano taking on
h4 wow
you might see it out of necessity
because you don't want to allow one
you don't want to know
was played none of this is going to
happen english too king h2 the idea is
obvious right yeah
but almost
in not only invites but forces uh black
right now to react and react in a
decisive manner and i think we might be
going towards the variation that we
discussed
bishop takes f5 then take on a4 i might
as well munch on another pawn right and
then
right in time get off the g file
so i don't see it like how do you how do
you continue the attacker that's the
question i like one thing especially
christian that you've mentioned i
actually prided myself i thought that i
had a real real problem going from the
expert class to the master class that
was like a ceiling i just hit my head
against for like two years it's amazing
i couldn't get to the 2200
and one of the things i just for our
non-american viewers we have the expert
category which is 2000 to 21 21.99 21.99
2200 is the master class and
when i became good i became a master
player i began to realize that i could
use my opponent's pawns as a shield
like when my opponent got his pawn all
the way next to my king sometimes it was
a really good idea not to take it
because that pawn blocked my opponent's
attack so what uh christian was saying
is in these positions where you play
bishop takes f5
e takes f5 often times you really don't
want to take the free pawn because that
opens up the position you want to play a
move like king h7 so
yeah i remember uh feeling like very
proud of myself that i had the knowledge
to
to play a move like king h7 it is funny
how chess evolves because a lot of times
we get questions you know who was the
best world champion and stuff like that
right i always feel it's simple it's not
only impossible but you shouldn't
compare uh
different arrows yeah even though we are
sitting in the same desk to me that's
such a ridiculous notion because i
learned that as a kid in a book a book
tells you there's a concept called the
pawn shield right you don't take the
pawn that's defending i didn't have that
book when i grew up right because like
it was just like you guys you guys made
that knowledge for us right right right
and when i think about the databases and
the engines today i just see that the
generations of players today are so much
more advanced so much more knowledgeable
that that's that that that's a part of
their dna that they're called and the
openings what has happened to theory is
just simply exploded i feel like a child
in my understanding of theory
when i thought i was well prepared i
went 10 moves deep
now it's like if you're not at 30 you're
out of your toast you're you're you're
gonna get killed good old days yeah h2
kg but i'm not i don't know is that
christian was mentioned that you have to
take on f5 and i didn't see it that way
i saw it in the way that i should take
this knight
when it's most pressing okay i love the
move king h7
uh are you afraid or not oh sorry you're
the king h7 gets out out of everything
right h6 and bishop takes i see all of
the threats the white house they involve
f4 they involve up in the g file they
involve targeting the h6 pawn get this
king out of g8 so what if i continue
with that f4 as christian
uh you gotta i think i have to say right
bishop takes now for sure you're never
touching
uh you you may capture the knight but
you're not not touching that pawn right
no not at all i guess we'll transpose
back into it because if you do go f4
maybe i do have to take on f5 now that
h6 is attacked yes okay so something
like this uh
and again i'm not 100 sure you want to
take this pawn but we we were here
uh
this position it seems like it seems
like you're going to get there anyway
right and the question that i had was
rook e5
uh playable the trick i had in mind
was if you take well
bishop to d6
that is that that's
the geometry is beautiful it's beautiful
but it works right it works for black oh
bishop that's that's let's start to the
audience bishop you have missions
a sterling uh
why is this a sterling reputation i got
two bishops
but you do at the end of the day have
this enormous apartment which is
something that
christian was harping upon you've got i
didn't i've never thought of it that way
by the way a free pawn
yeah that this pawn is more free he said
than the other one
i've never heard of that he's like okay
i got two free pawns not just one but
two no wait a minute wait this is not
earlier
by the way let's go back to that one and
maybe we can use it aboard the answer
yes we can also start with rook the hg3
first right so all the way after rook
takes e5 rotation three first what do
you capture back
i can throw in work c5 you can take on
c5 yes but rook g2 is probably i'm
probably going to regret this
it's too vicious convinced no i i still
like your so take on g2 you take i take
on c5 or do i give a check first
wait wait wait wait just a second can i
go rook g8 first you can but i don't see
how it changes much i think we'll go to
h1
well it does because
can you go to h2 i don't think so so you
go to h1 but now after taking on c5 i
have queen c6 as a big threat
no i mean i don't know this feels like
my bishops aren't working and my king is
too vulnerable
they're not working because of the pawn
on f5
md exactly yeah the bottom f5 is keeping
my king safe you know exactly
wow
uh
my goodness
that is
there's no trickies here bishop takes f7
ideas
no trickies
rook one more time rook takes er
takes g3
pause pose pose
wow
you can also take with the queen
oops on g3 you can take the with the
queen on g3 wait i wanted to take on f7
why are we starting here what
why did i call your bluff
okay rook takes e5
what are we doing wait a second kill me
first rook takes e5 yeah pawn takes e5
right bishop takes e5 just move the
queen just move the queen what but i was
thinking f7 was hanging okay let's move
to e7 but then you go ah but this was my
dream
when you go f6 and queen e4 i'm not sure
about this bishop check and then you'll
kill queen e4 there you go okay so let's
move it to somewhere better bishop takes
e5 queen c6 i think you have to go allow
the pawn on f7 to be lost right wow
that's a lot of firepower aimed at your
king but perhaps that's why we didn't
take on e5 i mean look yasser is not
giving material very often
very often be careful with this guy let
me do my little dance over here i feel
like i'm getting killed here no those
bishops
um you have to be careful with the
asteroid well when you see these kinds
of lines you know
both players are calculating furiously
here oh my god i got it context bishop
takes rookie guys guys guys one ques
exactly yes very good alejandro yeah you
see you saw it
rook takes yep
bishop e5 and i think rookie 8 might be
a problem now there
again the geometry is beautiful any
queen trades and there's a bishop g1
lurking
not only that but if you take on g8 and
i take on e5 with the route yeah
now i'm no longer
an exchange up i'm only a pawn up but
what i do have is control over the dark
squares yes and you're busted because of
that yes yes bishop d6 is coming the
only move is uh queen to g3 but i have a
feeling that after
rook to e3 you might be in big trouble
i wholeheartedly agree it feels like my
king on h2 in a very strange way is far
more vulnerable than the king on h7
thanks again to the pawn on f5 shielding
uh the bishop uh the light square bishop
wow great stuff everything that we've
seen so far kind of goes in black's
direction true uh it feels that knappo's
position is dangerous for black but not
even
we haven't made it work no no i agree uh
with that wholeheartedly king h7 were
pardon me king h2 we're expecting the
move king h7 or leave it for a moment or
bishop takes f5 or bishop takes it we'll
leave it for a moment let's go to other
games because we have a lot to analyze
exactly and
and uh actually christian has his eye on
one
absolutely i do have uh well i have my
eyes on all of them but one in
particular and this one between yon
shishtav duda and ding li ren because
it's so important for how this
tournament will continue moving forward
because one of the favorites right now
after losing the first game with the
white pieces
is having a dicey position with the
black pieces that is dingly ren i'm
looking at the position and more and
more i'm starting to like white two dust
position because of the last few moves
and we left it off after this move rook
to b1 and my idea and what i thought
duda's idea is as well is to go knight
to f1 knight to e3 knight to f5 and we
actually preferred black at this point
we said black probably has more options
to continue um expanding his position
either with 97 followed by f5 after with
knight e7 followed by knight to g6 and
getting that knight to f4 a lot of
options for black we didn't see too many
options for white and actually this uh
flank situation right now on the queen
side we thought is uh favorable for
black because we thought the b2 pawn or
at least i did is a weakness in fact it
is not and this is exactly what duda has
showcased with his next few moves rook
to b1 tremendous plan to uh play active
on the queen side b4
take on before rook takes b3 now i'm
going to have this past pawn which once
again could become a liability because
it's being attacked i do need to focus
some resources to the defense of the
pawn on a2 nevertheless let's see how
the game continued bishop to e3 queen to
e8 rook to b7 and now queen to d8 i feel
like the last few moves
definitely have been favorable for white
black hasn't achieved much it still has
that option of playing f5 or knight to
g6 knight to f4 but even if you do get
the knight to f4 how are you going to
continue after that and i see a clear
plan or at least for the next few moves
for white that is either queen to d1 or
rook to e1 doubling up on
and by the way he played the move queen
to d1 the best move by the engine as
well as the best practical chance
because not only that you're opening up
the avenue for the rook to go to b2 and
connect the rooks like that but also
once you do that this queen nicely opens
up and if you don't pay too much
attention if you don't keep this bishop
here like the engine wants bishop to c8
i don't see that move easily coming on
the board unless ding is ready for a
repetition bishop to c8 goes back bishop
to e6 rooks go back i don't know if the
ding right now is in that mindset of
potentially making a draw so i don't see
bishop to c8 coming on the board but if
that doesn't happen then you're going to
have to allocate a lot of resources to
the defense of the seventh rank the
queen has to stay on d a the bishop has
to stay on c7 if you remove this knight
well at some point i'm going to start
thinking about pushing my a pawn a4
followed by a5 or bishop to d2 a5 i'm
still waiting for you on this side what
are you going to do on this side
the way i look at this position is right
now white has an easier path to
improving his position what do you guys
think
oh i can see some very nice moves a4
rook b2 knight g4 as you were saying uh
and black has to carefully time his f5
break if or put his knight on f4
uh it's easier this exact moment i think
white's task is a little easier and this
is our lifetime result i was very i was
very happy with ding's position a few
moves ago it feels like it's gone south
and i can't really pinpoint
where i thought he should have played c5
maybe maybe that's what it was and open
up the bishop on b6 oh yeah but also
surprising for me that only three
classical games between these two
powerful players right really not
playing a lot yeah and uh so far they
learned the better of one win for him uh
i just want to turn our attention to
ikaro nakamura versus timor rajapat that
is a game that just stopped it's sort of
like we left it quite some time ago
right here we saw this move d5 we
thought queen takes d5 was white's best
best choice
and a likely
slightly favorable ending for white
apparently uh icaru felt that that would
not have been enough for him but then
when we saw the move queen c4 this is
where we instantly stopped we gave the
line a rest because we thought bishop g4
is like
full compensation two bishops and
initiative whatever
with this on d5 seems like it'll fall
one day h3 bishop d7 and wait a minute
i'm looking at moves like rook
e8 and queen e2 and i'm starting to
think why does
uh icaru think he's better at all and
then he played a movie that really
surprised me queen of three i thought he
was going to play knight c2 play bishop
e3 make a quick draw call it a day
whatever queen f3 losing more tempe what
is he doing alejandro
rook here i guess the bishop has to go
out somewhere um you got to play it
right guess bishop nice
i kind of want to play bishop i form a
little word tactically but
if i play bishop e3 it's just
ugly ugly ugly so bishop f4
and there's no i mean i'm worried about
rookie too
we need to we're i'm worried about the
house exactly
somebody can crash the party right right
but
i mean
does he really want to play bishop e3
well it seems to me like
white has lost a lot of tempe
after this pawn sacrifice and timor has
full compensation let's continue
around the horn for a second here and we
just spoke about it uh openly for
ourselves but let's jump with our
audience right here
in this moment after b4 i thought the
move b4 was doing black a great service
a favor if you will let me take
with the c pawn in order to open up the
bishop you're welcome to play rook tags
i will play bishop
to
c5
and this just felt like well
black for choice frankly despite giving
up a bun right what
i i blundered upon oh a4 yeah
you really think your rook is gonna
wow
i mean i've been sitting here for so
long next to you
good point good point okay
uh it is a pawn it is a pawn okay i
first not going to be trapped nobody's
going to attack it you're right well
that is you're not going to get your
palm back
either for a while
not for a while interesting okay he did
not do this right and because you said
well well black got caught on the back
foot
and
queen e8 queen d8
and we are up to date with the players
but now we feel that
dude's position is easier to play more
than the position
play recently last few five moves
queenie d8 bishop c8 they've gone dude
this way easily
what's going on through dinglerand's
mind now taking consideration the
following last candidates that he played
he starts the tournament losing to wong
khan his countrymen his countrymen then
in the next round he plays maxine vasher
lagroff loses that game too gets
annihilated right now
now you're playing against dude and
things clearly are not going your way
right i mean he is a very strong player
he's starting to realize that the move
queen eight queen diet cannot possibly
have been the best way of playing right
what's going through his mind how does
he recover right like you know you you
you're almost like watching yourself
from afar right you see your hand making
a move and then you're asking yourself
well why did i play queen e8 yeah so
that it can go queen d8
no something is a little bit off and
then you start to think okay i'm not
playing this well
uh i should make an emergency exit here
and i start looking for a way of like
pulling the plug and finding a forcing
draw
which means i start looking at the most
forcing moves and i start thinking about
queen uh pardon me f5 by the way we do
have queen
on d8 back to e8
he's
he's building up for f5 but i think he
wants to do it when his queen is on g6
in the meantime duda says okay you just
get on with whatever you're doing i'll
put my roof on the b file double up on
the on the on the d on the d file um
a much easier much easier position
for a duda to play
i've seen so many games of these soviet
championships over the years and i've
seen this um
anatoly karpov way of playing
the knight h2 queen f3 knight g4 knight
f5 bobby fischer as well
and i'm just thinking that uh
well white white has a a much much
easier time well we'll again
keep an eye on that and finally richard
and our birthday boy our birthday boy uh
alireza firuja
this king funnily enough made it to the
center which
makes me wonder why they're in newcastle
right
exactly uh you made it back to the
center king e2 and i do like very very
much what richard has played knight h4
is such a
cagey and
precise move because you can't play g3
right now knight h4 you cannot play g3
because bishop g4 check check
and the moment i play f3 you
capture yeah i snap that
and at the end of the line the d3 is
hanging is hanging and i'm an unhappy uh
camper which is why he was forced to
play knight takes before which by the
way
something i wanted to do i did i did i
did because i had a very clear idea
which was after g3 knight g6 i really
really want to play the move a4 badly
so i'm thinking that if it's my turn
i'll play b3
and maybe on a good day bishop to c5 and
i'll try to lasso
the pawn on d3 on b4 that's very nice
and if you capture i wanted to take with
the rook
now i'm hoping to get this type of an
ending
where i've got the outside pass pawn
i think my king is going to be close
enough to the c pawn and i'm hoping
that i'll be able to
[Laughter]
let me rewrite that in my speech in this
case
i i kind of believe this end game yeah a
little bit better a little bit the only
issue i have with the variation is that
unfortunately after a4 it is slack to
move i'm not compelled to take on a3 yes
i was wondering if you could just play
b3 and hold the draw a little bit easier
whoa whoa whoa well just a second let's
go i will i'll try to anchor the bishop
on b6
and then maybe on a good day this guy
and
yeah perhaps i'm not on time
it could easily be a timing issue it's a
timing issue right does the knight get
to d7 or c8 on time right like for
example i could play ninety seven here
depending on that pawn on c6
anticipating
that v6 i'll play
rook somewhere actually rook fa-8
d-a-a i don't know why i said f uh rook
d-a-a and it actually does come with the
threat of knight c8 is it yeah because
you're gonna depend on the
okay i you
yeah
what am i trying to do just answer the
question what am i i'm trying to win a
pawn
at knight c8
i will take it i guess yeah and in this
case the rook on a3 is protected yeah
okay
uh
i think richie's got a little something
something maybe right yeah maybe it's
not the most but something something
i've seen
magnus squeeze blood from stone and uh
well that's what we expect from the
candidates right if you're going to be
challenging magnus carlsen then you need
to be able to squeeze things from no
advantages
the way that favi did yesterday against
hikaru exactly jump back to our marquee
match-up game and see
and see if more game more moves by the
way uh fabi showing some real insight uh
b five times
i stopped myself b5 takes a4
rook g3 okay
king h7 and wow queen to d1
he is saying that hey look i i am a
little bit worried about this pawn and
all of those other lines that we've been
trying whether it be with f4 h4
can't kind of came up empty-handed
so okay let's see
how
black's going to deal with queen
d1 so is there a secondary threat or is
it just queen takes a4 i think that's
the primary
unless knight h6
rocks your world and i don't think it
does
uh yeah that's it i'm just
just putting my pieces may be on better
squares e1 but that that begs the
question if it was a one-dimensional
approach which is give me your pawn
is there any reason why the queen might
not be better on a5 as opposed to d1
well you start giving me a lot of
squares i think particularly giving up
the d3 square
well not not right now not right now but
my bide you in the future i i don't know
but besides that i wouldn't say that
there's a a bigger issue maybe the movie
queen d1 does have a secondary idea i'm
starting to why something like bishop
takes g5 this rook 2 goes somewhere
queen h5
ah
now that's crafty right okay
uh that's the old
hidden uh so we want to play bishop
takes g okay i'm gonna make a move it's
not
necessarily and that's the problem with
f4 christian that was the problem with
f4 it was just overly a simplified
version of what we're seeing right now
queen d1 is just keeping a lot of
options still on the table queen d1
assumes that you are not allowed to
touch the pawn on f5 after bishop takes
f5 e takes f5 you're not allowed to
touch that pawn so i'm never going to
lose that he's actually playing this as
a slow game quite an interesting
approach sure attacking the pawn on a4
a3 most likely will come on the board
now do you want to uh recapture that
opponent a3 probably not right i don't
think you want to take that because
that's the knight on e5 in that case is
going to live there forever and i don't
think you want to see that you want to
attack it at some point with f4 you also
want to keep options as alejandro
pointed out bishop takes g5 that's a big
big threat queen d1 is hinting that i
might be looking that direction so for
example
after a3 maybe get the rook off the uh
d1 h5 diagonal maybe i mean you could
play rook tape too but
this is not as subtle at all
not only that but i also uh i'm hinting
potentially at an exchange sacrifice
right yeah that it really does tell
exactly that's
the idea that's the big three h5 that's
the big when you play rook c2 but you
were mentioning
maybe rook takes c5 is an intriguing
uh if that pawn wasn't on a3 then bishop
b2 so you do have to take on f5 i think
after yeah i think i think at some point
soon this knight will have to be removed
but i'm thinking that when you played
the move a3 in this particular position
um
and i play bishop takes a3 winning the
pawn
i really feel kind of bad because truth
be told
i invested a lot of energy i rook to g3
king h2 and i was telegraphing for the
longest time that i'm playing for f4
and then if i have to play bishop takes
a3 and as you were saying christian the
knight on e5 lives forever
on e5
uh going to get bigger
right yeah yeah you're giving up too
many ideas right this knight on e5 is
long-lived
no more f4
and
i don't know how much better black is
here but it's just but it's it's it's
his side of the table and he's enjoying
uh the torture
um
wow uh queen d1 we haven't seen a3 i
just want to ask you about the clock
times uh
times right now 43 minutes for fabiano
still thinking after queen the one 35
minutes for yon napoleon an unusual
situation for an april actually such a
fast player and this is their
head-to-head in classical chess only one
win for yandere pomnyachi coming in the
grand chess tour of zagreb honestly was
2019 maybe 2018 and against bobby in a
craziest fashion cup in which
favi actually was simply
better or maybe he lost his grip he lost
his grip in time pressure and just in
the complications fell apart and nine
draws a lot of draws typical for these
kind of players
but i wanted to say in that win that
nepo had yes it was a clock issue too it
was a clock issue definitely right i
mean nepo is known as a really really
fast player
and both of them were the most recent
victims of magnus carlsen they were they
were the challengers they were the
challenges the last back-to-back
challengers here you do have to say that
one match was closer than the
other even steven for a while
but a loss is a loss a 483 were
expecting
any other uh
uh
yeah join the conversation everybody
says send us some questions yes please
remember that we are on social media
we're on youtube we're on twitch we're
on reddit and we've got moderate mods we
got mods uh so send us all of our
questions tweet at st louis chess club
uh join our questions because it is a
long tournament and one of the beautiful
things that this allows us is that we
can actually go in depth to a lot of
these games that sometimes i feel when
we're doing rapid especially blitz we
don't get to see the subtleties and the
beauties of some of the ideas and
because of the even longer time control
in this particular tournament we can
converse with you we can actually answer
your questions and take a look at what
you want to take a look at so join join
our conversation share more stories
share and a lot more stories i mean the
people are demanding sorry okay okay
well guys
let me have my question please jump in
my hand at asking you guys a question
all right
how good is yan shishtav duda in reality
we know coming into this event he's the
lowest rated player
he's uh
been touted as not enough for this
tournament to win it
by magnus carlsen by a lot of critics
also by his rating situation right but
how good is he because i've been
studying this young man and i've uh seen
him up close at the recently concluded
grand chess tour in poland the one that
we're seeing footage from i've
interviewed him and i'm sensing that his
rating could be a bit deceiving right
now by the way he won that tournament
so
i'm looking at his reading situation
right now right right
27.50
but
when did he hit his peak i'm looking at
his rating chart right here his peak was
in
january 2020
since then sure he went all the way to
27.50 a rating loss of eight points but
he hasn't played a lot of tournaments
we don't know i don't think we can
assess how good ian shisht of duda
actually is
so i'm going to go ahead and actually
give him quite a substantial chance
at upsetting the field and potentially
getting close to winning this one
everybody is not counting him as a
potential winner i'm going to go ahead
and give him a slight chance what do you
guys think well hold on timeout where
are these haters coming from i mean the
dude is only 24 years old
grooving exactly we just had a two-year
hiatus this whole pandemic messed up
everybody's schedule
dude i didn't get a chance to play in a
lot of over the over the board
tournaments 24 years old enormous talent
he just wins a grand chess tour
um event
yeah
he's really really really good
and
maybe you know he's ready to make that
bounce to that 2 800. and once again he
knocks out magnus in the world cup
and wins it as well yeah
it's it's hard to say pretty damn
impressive it's hard to underestimate
duda because he's so good
how good is he in comparison to the
candidates at this precise moment i
think is the most pressing question
right because
he has so much room to improve he is so
young 24 ridiculous i know i mean come
on and and
including two years lost basically right
yeah you played a tournament here
tournament there speed match online yeah
line whatever but it's not the same no
it definitely is not the same doesn't
have the experience of playing
consistently the way he was doing before
the pandemic
i i just don't know it's really hard to
say for me this is the biggest wild card
right i think that for me young sister
of duda is a bigger wild card than
richard i don't see that richard's
opening preparation will hold up in the
candidates that is just my opinion it's
a personal opinion some people share it
but that is my opinion of the chances of
richard for duda i don't feel he has
that problem
dude his main problem in my opinion is
conversion
and
you get the good positions but he's not
converting you get a good position but
where does it go yesterday it was a
clear example of this problem
again i'm going to repeat what i said
about yesterday's game it was a clear
example of the problems that people see
in these players relative to the other
candidates of course not compared to me
relative to the other candidates
that they struggle with richard in
opening prep where he gets some
positions that are really dubious you
really shouldn't be getting this
positions of the candidates at this
level yeah and then duda shouldn't be
letting that position go it was a very
very very comfortable advantage at that
point well one of the things that i
always and as we look at their
head-to-head match-up two wins were due
to not bad one loss and two draws
against
richard um
and yesterday's result was a draw i just
wanted to say that i felt that i had a
i was hardwired differently i i was a i
was very unlucky as a chess grand master
in the sense i came from the united
states i went to europe and i was
playing in these round robins and they
had a completely different opening
repertoire my repertoire was designed to
score 90 percent yeah because i'm
playing in all of these american opens
and playing in a round robin versus
playing in an open like you want to win
the feed a
grand opening uh swiss yeah and you need
an 80 score yeah there's a bump there
right
um you playing the candidates you don't
need an eighty percent score no maybe
sixty was six sixty four sixty percent
amazing score right yeah
so uh but then when you come to the
candidates it's also another level of
opening preparation that's completely
different than playing in a tata steel
and
your your repertoire has to be
not just good it's almost bulletproof
yep
and you really really have to believe in
your opening so experience matters a lot
and to complete your thought
yasser speaking about opening
preparation
duda to my knowledge well
might be the only one that has multiple
seconds with him uh there in spain we
have uh gregor gayevsky as well as his
longtime coach miton camille he's the
one coming up with two seconds fabiano
caruana to my knowledge only has
chucholo for example with him at the
canvas not only that but also he's
taking his physical preparation quite
seriously he recently trained mma mixed
martial arts check this out look at him
look at him right here planking look at
him punching i like what i'm seeing
i like what i'm saying
oh my goodness he's taking everything
seriously in preparation to this event
and this is what i think he is
undervalued all right well if nothing
else works he can beat up everybody
beat him up beat him up let's just catch
up on the game of ding and lorraine and
adudas as we've been uh we left it after
bishop c8 the rook was dropping back
queen slid over to e8 i thought the
queen was going to g6
duda doubled his rooks and indeed queen
g6 now the question is what's our next
step we do have a pass pawn on the a a2
is it ever going anywhere
well he said
no
it's okay i'm going to i want to meet
f7f5
with a series of trades and then i want
this knight to take the place of its
colleague maybe get to e4
rook
and there's a lot of tuning and throwing
without any
blows landing
what is what is black's plan
with the last few moves i don't know
right and then king g8 well there was
also this dance with the queen right
the 88 g6 rook seven and king james well
christian pointed out that the queen
went to b8 to a7 to a5 back to a7
and all the way uh once again so a lot
of uh dancing and prancing but no real
uh blows being like is he just saying
he's keeping the position he doesn't
want to spoil is he playing for rook h7
i feel like at some point rook h7 will
really force me to go to f5 and i will
be very happy to be forced to go to f5
like well
not to lose a pawn so
say a3 and i go rook f7 rook f7 to h7
and what how do you get to f5 i'll put a
bishop somewhere on
d2 c1 i'm not really sure which one of
the two squares and the thing is in this
kind of positions with your um
this terrible bishop on b7 i will
consider
going for something like this
it's a pawn sacrifice but look at that
uh your extra pawn first of all is a
double pawn yeah
is not the cleanest extra pawn but
okay
and you have to take it if you don't
take it you're just oh yeah well why did
i play h5 and h4 and if i if i have to
chase you to f5 well very very
intriguing and christian
what else have you
uh i know you're looking at all four
games but
one in particular
i was looking at dudas mma moves for the
most part
our discussions he can improve his form
a little bit
he's on the right path
now let's take a look at this game
between hikaru and timur and as you guys
were mentioning this one is developing
into a very slow game very reminiscent
of what actually happened in timur's
yesterday's game against firuja if you
rush at some point had over an hour
advantage on the clock so did hikaru and
take a look at the situation on the
clock right now 35 minutes for hikaru 32
minutes for timur rajabov so
they're very closely matched up right
now in terms of time and i have to say
the more i look at the position i
understand why it is a pawn up
nevertheless with the two bishops and so
much activity all the pieces are playing
a very nice active role right now for
black i'm starting to like black's
chances as well black chances for
equality enough equality um as
compensation for the last pawn and one
way to do that to continue is to take
and then immediately get rid of this
double pawn as well as create more
weaknesses and avenues for my pieces to
get to your pieces and that way uh seems
to be before forcing not necessarily
forcing but inviting this raid if you
take take now you have to contend with
the fact that your b2 pawn is a weakness
my queen is going to be invited around
your king via d2
this is not looking great for hikaru and
i'm not sure hikaru uh likes these type
of positions where he has to defend he
generally likes to sacrifice a couple of
pawns and then get uh on the offensive
get dynamic play right now dynamic play
is in favor of black i understand still
upon down but i like black's chances i
like the trend for timur rajabov right
now
all right very good and uh
just before we take a break and we'll
see on the other side of the brick i
want to just ask a question
alireza
he starts with two blacks now he's
slightly worse in this game but if he
saves this game
and you know he's like uh two
extra whites
coming in the remaining 12 rounds
that's got to be worth something
yes it's worth something i would say
that
white and black
affects different people differently for
example nepo
you know of course in the world
championship it's a different thing
but for tournament play right
is nepo really that different with white
and black no no he wins with black loses
with white all the time right so
i still want to see where alireza fits
in there he is not so far a player that
relies on preparation he's not a player
that comes in with this you know fabi
type of crap right he just beats up
people
he's the type of player that gets any
position tries to outplay out calculate
out tactic out
blitz right your opponent so i'm very
curious on what he is going to do with
his whites and i think a big part of
this tournament the entire tournament is
how good is alireza's prep
so far
today he got a little surprised by
richard and let's be honest it was
difficult not to be surprised by the
move queen takes d4 seriously i'm sure
that otherwise i had analyzed the night
or
yeah an enormous debt yeah yeah and um
in yesterday's game well
he was the one that surprised uh timor
with excellent prep including an
exchange sacrifice wow yeah that was
great a lot of this tournament will
depend on that what is all the rest are
going to do with the white pieces in
in the second half
we'll answer all your questions
on the other side of the break
[Music]
welcome to the chess capital of the
united states the st louis chess campus
in the heart of the vibrant central west
end has established itself as a premier
global destination for chess and is
comprised of two unique non-profit
institutions
the chess club and scholastic center of
st louis is recognized as the top chess
facility in the world and plays host to
all major tournaments including the u.s
chess championships and the sinkfield
cup one of the strongest chess
tournaments globally
tournaments are broadcast online to more
than 150 countries led by an expert
commentary team of grand masters
the chess club is an educational
organization committed to promoting the
game of chess with a specific focus on
bringing the benefits of chess to
children throughout the st louis area
research shows children who play chess
exhibit improved analytical skills and
increased confidence the chess club is
highly engaged with the local community
bringing scholastic chess programs to
more than 100 schools providing hundreds
of classes each week
directly across the street from the
chess club is the world chess hall of
fame this one-of-a-kind cultural
institution invites visitors to
experience chess in imaginative ways and
is home to the u.s and world chess halls
of faint
cutting edge exhibitions feature rare
historic chess artifacts paired with
world-class art innovative programming
explores the intersection of chess art
and culture visitors can enjoy
interactive programs designed around the
exhibitions and monthly music in the
galleries
the world chess hall of fame is nothing
you expect and everything you love three
different galleries and a premier gift
shop highlight the culture history and
creativity behind the game come visit
play chess leave enriched
to learn more about the st louis chess
campus visit stlchestcampus.org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back everybody it is round two
of the candidates and here are our
pairings richard upward is playing
against ali rest i fear ruja in an
endgame and hikaru nakamura is currently
up upon but unclear if he is better
against teamwork rajabo yande ponnacci
is going all out against fabiano
carolina but will it backfire we're
about to find out as well and meanwhile
john shishtof duda is currently thinking
whether he wants to take a draw against
dingley red because we have the
potential of a threefold repetition in
that game right now right now let's see
if the polish player decides to do it he
doesn't have to they've already reached
move 40 okay so they got another bunch
of time yeah 60 minutes for the next 20
minutes yeah so he has plenty of time to
think about his decision and knight g3
would be the claim it would be the claim
93 would be an automatic draw if you
wanted to this is the most shocking
thing to me i'm looking at the position
yeah and i only realized just now that
this is move 42
this looks like move 20. yeah i know
what you mean right
this doesn't look like move 42 this was
extremely shocking to me no i agree
they've made time control they're the
first to do it but okay as we wait to
see will duda
accept the draw in this exact moment
you're telling me that jan went all out
these are our two tournament leaders yes
and they are playing a donnie brook of
the
game
fabi has these beautiful minor pieces
and this last move
is an indication that something has not
gone according to plan
plan bishop b2 i did not see that move
coming you set up all of your pieces
queen on h5 rook on g3 you're hinting
that this bishop on c1 will be open by
force with f4 with h4 with bishop g5 mat
with whatever exactly and then you move
it out of the diagonal right in fact as
we were coming on air you and i were
having a discussion just about
this
rather funky exchange sacrifice and we
actually thought this would work out
in white uh pardon me in black's favor
after bishop takes f7 where did we go
after that we just traded queens and one
day three and exactly it was hard it was
actually difficult to defend against we
were not very happy that we were facing
rook b2 but in this particular case you
can actually take on c5 right i was
worried i was worried that if you take
on c5 the end game with the bishop
completely stuck on h5 it's still not
very fun oh man well like if i played k8
and i played like a rocket game
well maybe even c4 actually
maybe c4 let's just push the pawn right
one of these moves
yeah no pushing baby pushing baby yeah
well just if you take on a6 c3 let's go
baby
of larry christensen getting you from
behind
well said rook c7
and we have a result the duda against
dingler and game has finished in a draw
dude that said no more i don't have
anything better than a draw in this
position we were analyzing a little bit
uh during our break and we didn't find
too much for white we did think it was
kind of even so that game has ended as
the first result of the day and now
bishop b2 let's get to it because
this really does feel like nepo just hit
a brick wall yes and he just said i have
an admission
i have a confession a confession
my confession is i don't think that f4
or h4 were moves that were helpful
i'm planning
to capture twice i want to
capture the knight on e5 which is
defending the pawn on f7 and then i want
to take it now the first thing that went
through my mind
is what about rook takes b2 right i mean
do i really want to face
these beautiful minor pieces now the
problem is i could win back the exchange
but at the end of the day
i win the exchange but i lose f7 and
that's not what i uh signed up for
so uh i could play a3 and just play the
position
yeah
knight g4
knight g4 okay
um let's say somehow i don't like my
rook and my
my king sorry you're not threatening
bishop d6 but let's go you take queen
takes p2 yeah
how does this go because if you take
with the queen
yes then group g7 at the end of the day
you're you've got your own nipples my
own little nibble right right right
right it really comes down to who gets
who first exactly i feel it's black
actually
uh how
bad good is it because
at a certain moment if i ever get bishop
b one check i understand you've got a
perpet but this and more right
right is it more
i can't see it
i don't know and we started with
knight g4 if i had played
with rook yeah the thing about knight f3
is that if you play rook takes that then
i defend that too and then i'm and then
i'm golden yeah i know i like that guys
yes that knight on e5 is worth more than
a rook yeah that's that's
right right yeah well you you you
okay i get it you plop the pawn on a3
and you're right now i can't start
thinking about nibbling on uh either f5
don't you definitely not f5 right now
but i can take on f2 first so let's
let's
okay okay okay uh you give up i'm not
really happy about giving up the ac boom
that was a that was a juicy
that was a beauty it was indeed
g4 okay you know what no i'm going to
take a slower approach yes
this
this is the the fast approach
yeah this is too fast i'm going to go
after rook b7 rook g7 and just try to
protect like that
you know one of the things that is so so
difficult about chess
is we get positions that are favorable
for us and we start looking at forcing
forcing forcing exactly
patience
what
fabi did yesterday against my pick
hikaru was amazing i mean he showed
incredible patience at the end we knew
it was all white but but the way he did
it and the way he extracted it he went
about his business i think just simply
brilliantly and
really you sometimes you just have to be
patient now after rook g7 but are you
happy
the rook is kind of
weird the
night
i don't know if you're happy i'm not
thrilled
what is what what is white's move crazy
let me ju
i've never been a big fan of king h2
when my opponent has a dark square
bishop i always thought but the king
might have been better placed on h1
uh i'm i'm trying to in
induce you to play queen takes f5 to
which i have the brilliant
response
yasser what is the brilliant response
the brilliant response is
wow
never saw that
thank you very much
uh
okay i defended the f2 pawn maybe maybe
i'm not even a fan of my queen on f5 can
i h5 i beg your pardon let me go queen
a6
i got ahead of myself
he's already taken my pawn i haven't
even been able to defend it exactly yeah
but there's issues right g4 might be an
issue
i don't know if it is or it isn't g4 wow
black does get his
own licks in here as you like to say
g4 keeping keeping your stick on the ice
huh g4
the canadian canadian
well you're staying in the game right
you keep you keep your stick on the ice
uh you've got a chance to
put in the
uh pump
all right guys i'm going to spoil the
party
all right all right please we have it's
time to spoil the party the giant
christian just go after look to be it's
fine everything is fine after rook b7
uh with eight take on f2
take out
f2
take on a3 all right now
let's squeeze you guys a little bit okay
how do you get my key you have all the
dark squares no i was trying right i was
trying to make knight g4 work but i
couldn't because you always have g3
correct
so if knight g4 doesn't work maybe you
have something else
my g4 doesn't work i have something else
now i feel kind of dumb
yeah this does not work because i have
g3 and it definitely takes f7 is also a
big problem queen xf7 also yeah i'm
falling apart here right you're not in
time
but you have another way to get to the
white king a hidden way indeed no way
really yes d5
d5 is the move almost finishes the game
oh my god queen to d6 is coming
not only hitting the king on h2 but also
the rook on a3 also defending the pawn
on a6 wow he did not see that he played
the move rook to e8 yeah but we're going
to see none of this
very difficult very very difficult move
to see
wow
d
five yeah okay that rocks our world
what's the engine think of this move
christian
and by the way after d5 it was minus two
or something along those so
very very strong wow look g8 still
maintains an edge but it's not as high
as after rook takes b2 so you see rook
takes b2 you understand that most likely
you
have a way a path forward to make this
work but you have to see d5 yeah no
d5 is very very difficult to see
wow
this bishop takes f2
rook takes a3
and the e5
what a again the geometry is amazing the
geometry and also the fact that you do
have to calculate bishop takes f2 bishop
takes f7 you have to calculate so many
other things and then to arrive on the
move d5 when you're honestly calculating
forcing moves knight g4 you're
calculating knight f3 if they don't work
so they kind of give up yeah
but as you say none of this happened
because he played instead the move rook
g8 to e8 and then the question was
how does the engine like this move uh
christian
but it's well is that right it likes it
uh it's still an edge for black i still
feel like fabiano is in control it does
maintain control of the position you're
not allowing any rooks on the seventh
rank you still hold
full control over the dark squares but
this bishop survives so the bishop on b
to the dark square bishop that will be
able to challenge the knight on e5 later
on in the game or perhaps even now is
going to survive for the moment so this
is by the way bishop to c1 yeah
it forces a repetition there's no other
move by rook jean and rook jade already
played uh at the very least they
actually repeated the g8 bishop to b2
was played right now moved
32 12 minutes for fabiano 21 minutes for
ian napoleon
must be
thinking look
i need to have something here i'm a
couple of pawns up i feel like i'm very
close on the edge on the brink of
actually winning this game the second
game in a row and taking a commanding
lead into this event if i win two games
in the first uh uh two games then you're
the clear favorite and i think you are
mentioning some numbers uh off
of the broadcast yesterday what were the
numbers if you win this game so coming
into today's game by the numbers by the
models that uh chess numbers uses uh
fabi after winning game one has a 28
chance of winning the tournament uh jan
has a 22
chance of winning the tournament after
round one according to the models
now
should fabi win today's game his
expected result or his expectation would
be 45
wow he would jump on it's almost bobby
versus the field if he goes plus two
conversely if yon
were to win the event he jumps up to
something like about 38
so that's a big this is a big result for
you as a chess fan yes
how much do you like these numbers i
love them really seriously i i
i love sports i love uh basketball
baseball football all right i love i
love your question what were the
warriors odds of winning the nba finals
when the season started very very bad to
a thousand
i wouldn't have guessed that that was
what is that i would have guessed
538 uh odds of the warriors winning no
way wow no way so many injuries think
wait how didn't i know that i would have
bet like
at the beginning of the season at the
beginning of the season yes that's fine
that's right i mean you take one i'll
let you know christian you can you can
bet right now
next season's coming their odds are
going to be something like one way one i
remember this this was unbelievable i'd
love to see if we could get the video of
this i was a big fan of ucla you know
bill walton went to ucla as a big fan of
bill walton by the way we are we're
repeating in the fabiano game rook g8
played and bishop c1 would
not seal the draw because the rook was
on f8 right at the beginning of the
repetition but bishop c1 i think forces
rook g8 no question about it which
basically seals the draw wow okay so
ucla was this they won all of these ncaa
championships they were there's a big
national title
and they're winning the game and then
the other team has to foul
and there's one guy on the ucla team
who has hit every free throw he ever had
in collegiate basketball he was 1 000.
he's on the free throw line if he makes
the two shots it's game over
clank clank
you see la loses
i nearly killed myself
i was like how
how does a guy who's 1 000. he never
missed in his life
the biggest game of his career he clanks
two in a row seeing numbers can't show
you right right but that's why i say i
love the numbers i love
and i like the fact that in chess we do
have these statistics how do they do
head to head how do they do in rapid how
do they i always take them with a grain
of salt especially specifically there
was one website that has been really
relying on numbers for a lot of things
and i find them completely off like
completely off reality really yeah yeah
it's like not even close to reality the
models just in your opinion don't work
and what they don't know about the
website ratings remarkably accurate yes
uh ratings i find very accurate but uh
that's i think different than
okay then models in a way
well most of them do rely upon the
ratings but what was the website that's
okay i don't have to oh you're gonna
like hey we're gonna have lawsuits here
it's alejandro riveras he lives in saint
louis serve him here
[Laughter]
okay uh did we get a draw
he did not grab the draw nipple he is
going for it no no i don't think he's
going to go no he played bishop c1
there's no way guys there's no way
there's he has to do he has to repeat
he's down
somebody finally woke up and told the
truth you're down two pawns
there's no way to do it bishop c1 and
has the draw
uh the arbiter's coming over uh rook g8
would be
the threefold okay uh there is no
three-fold on bishop c1 again repeating
that the rook started on f8 when we
started the repetition and then he went
rookie so it should be two technically
not yet there yeah but fabiano will be
kicking himself for this one i have to
say i think so yeah he had great
preparation he showed his cards early on
he wanted to play for a win with the
black pieces and by the way we have
confirmation that handshake has
been done in that game the game is over
half a point split for each players uh
this one is going to be quite
interesting now
let's
not forget about the game between
richard rapport and ali reza absolutely
because
ali reza
might be in serious danger
of being uh much worse if not
technically losing the white case much
in in the in the same game much more
active than the black king not only that
but all of both of my rooks are much
more active than yours yours are playing
a defensive role this one defending the
pawn on d4 the rook on a6 depending upon
on c6 my rooks are ready to pounce
towards your king if i manage to double
them up on the seventh rank is game over
you cannot allow that ever in any under
any circumstances so i will be able to
find a mechanism in which i'm going to
attack your pawns make use of the fact
that i also have the idea and the threat
of potentially going into d3 e5 hiding
my king behind the pawn i have to be
careful about your d-pawn this is uh the
key of the position right now but what
is alireza's plan that is the question
and with only eight minutes to go
let's not forget they don't get an
increment in this one the next eight
moves nine moves right now for ali reza
are actually going to be uh the decisive
factor whether he manages to save this
one or actually just collapses because
right now i have to say from a practical
perspective the more i look at the
position it seems like richie has
tremendous chances of taking the full
point home i couldn't agree more i love
everything about white's position there
his pieces are much more active the king
on g8
also gained the kind of uh flew by us uh
is the game of hikaru versus timor when
we left that we just thought that
the
that timor had more than sufficient
compensation for the pawn he was down
and after the move queen d5 i know there
were some discussions about b5 b4
earlier as well the queen d5 and the
players kind of very quickly went into
the ending almost
per force
uh strong knight
yeah
versus bishop i think white but
minimal pretty minimal i think
but the majority of the king size fries
more than enough counter play i think
you have to play you know you have to
put your pawns on dark squares and then
once you've done that
what is your follow-up exactly that's as
a question from white's point of view
i love the fact that the knight is very
well defended
and
rather reluctantly i'm forced to
consider playing b3 and c4 in order to
make a pass pawn myself if i don't do
that my queen side majority is basically
looks pretty but doesn't do anything
right in the meanwhile on the king side
uh the black has played king to g6 maybe
on a good day he starts to think about
g5
f4
and he starts to say hey look i've got a
majority as well don't don't think it's
just play on one goal
even-ish yeah i think it's one of those
positions where everybody takes white
but objectively
probably much you're not going to be
surprised by a draw once again to remind
everybody we do have two results already
yes two draws in the book uh yesterday
we had two winners
and uh those two winners did draw the
game and we think
that uh
fabby's gonna be kicking himself
question for you you've worked with fabi
fatty
you're going to have disappointments
you're going to have successes yeah and
you've got to whisper
you're only mortal you're only mortal
you're only moral you know you got to
bring your guy down when he's too
excited and you got to bring him up when
he's too depressed he's going to go back
he's going to see
ideas that christians showed us and he's
going to say gosh darn it
i missed it how does he overcome that
feeling of remorse
well that is a good question but i would
answer it in two parts the first is that
i know favi rather well and i don't
think he is going to be upset about this
one he will find that d5 is difficult to
find especially considering the time
that he had that going into the game a
draw with the black pieces against nepo
is more than fine absolutely that things
are going according to plan and i don't
think that he will be upset even if the
engine says whatever at whatever point
one two he's not that type of person uh
he's more of a realist when it comes to
this kind of uh of chess struggles that
the engine says what the engine thinks
but you know realistically who's going
to find that and i think he will feel
that d5 with 12 minutes to play on such
an important game and if you don't find
d5 you might be worse uh didn't merit
the risk
uh so i don't think he'll be upset about
that uh regarding when he is actually
upset about something he's done in
in chat wise
uh he he kind of he's a type of player
that
needs to
get his mind off things
he needs to disconnect from the
tournament i think they're going to go
watch a movie go watch him i think the
most famous story of the candidates of
2018 right he loses to sergey karjakin
crucial match two games to go two games
to go and suddenly the tournament is
wide open how do you draw that game the
tournament is over right uh but he
basically loses and blows the tournament
wide open how does he recover
watches a movie yeah the shape of water
shape of water good night's sleep and
the story right goes back the next day
and wins two games in a row crucial
games right so
five is a very strong player but i think
what sets him apart from a lot of
people that could be considered past
talent or maybe a little less talented
maybe a little bit more
yeah he has a cool head he's a realist
and he doesn't put
unrealistic expectations on himself
and to a certain degree i feel that
with 12 minutes after such a complex
game with 14 round tournament
risking it all to go rook takes p2 and
then hoping that d5 works at the end
it's not his style
it's funny that you should mention that
he's cool and patient under fire
because there was one gary kasparov who
was hot blooded yes i mean the guy you
know he loses a king and he's like
snarling we
he comes out firing
every which way i mean even you know to
his own uh
uh distress but
yeah okay hot blooded versus very very
patient very calm fabi uh
under pressure guys guys we really need
to move on let's go to the game between
uh richie rapport and ali reza because
ali reza down to his last four minutes
and a half and what did i say just a few
minutes ago do not allow white to double
up on the seventh round because you
busted if you do that this is exactly
what happened in the game we left it off
somewhere around here after king to d2
and ali reza went for this move suicidal
in my opinion rook to a1 you're going to
go hunt for this pawn and allow my two
rooks to double up on the seventh rank
are you kidding me that's not possible
no rook takes c6 rook to h1 rook c7 rook
takes h2k d3 all very natural moves
i think he's close to resignation
worse because if you play a move for
example what
is this
i take on g7 i go e5 and you resign no
no you have to you have to play g6 to
defend the your pawns okay it's ugly but
i don't if you don't play g6 you resign
i'll give you a check no no i'm not
saying i'll start pushing my pawn oh no
not that one really why not
this is also lost yeah i thought you
were going to go e5 no b4 why not rook
h3
g7 once you go here i go king to c4
if you cannot take this with check then
it doesn't do anything you allow me to
take on h7 and that's going to have
devastating consequences if you go d3
rook to d7
and that's it i'm catching this pawn
this pawn you will not be able to catch
with the king all the way to h8 i'm
going to take we're going to exchange
the rooks i'm going to take on d3 i'm
going to put the rook behind i'm going
to march the pawn and the game is going
to be over there is no way you can it's
too easy for richie report right now
wow i'm i'm sorry i i understand what
you what you're saying about b4 but
if i'm going to push a pass pawn i'm
going to push the one that's closest to
promotion so i'm sitting here looking at
this position and he played after he
played
the movie i'm gonna play e5
i think
which is also devastating right because
for everything that you said which was
takes takes takes and if you go after my
pawn then
this is this is where i wanted the king
protection
and i just have a i think a forced mate
uh once my pawn gets to e6 and i get to
go rook g7 where it is ali reza's
biggest weakness in which phase of the
game
wow and you're going to ask it at this
exact moment we're going to jump on this
ending but
we knew that everybody knew that right
most of the accidents that we've been
seeing with ali reza they happen in the
end game and this is exactly what it
feels like these players are targeting
right now with their opening choice and
with the way they assess and approach
the middle game as well they're very
happy to exchange the queens against ali
reza and this is exactly what we've seen
from rishi rapport by the way the end
game
was not a huge advantage for white no no
not at all actually but he pressed and
pressed and pressed and put some
pressure on time
and it's he finally cracked right that's
crazy but but the move rookie one to me
is such
a surprising move it really feels that
the pressure got to him you're not
fighting with that movement it doesn't
you could even start with a move like h5
there's no immediate threat well i think
he was fearful
that this pawn was going to get rounded
up by either a move like rook to b4 or
and or king d3
and he feared that if he didn't
that this rook would end up being very
passive
for the rest of the game so that
i mean
maybe h7 h5 was a better uh choice
because allowing the double i think it
was uh left polygayeski in his book
grandmaster preparation who uh
called the rooks on the seventh uh the
refreshment stall refreshment you
refresh yourself you get to go check and
take a pawn and another check and you
take another pawn the double the double
rooks and he's played this move king e4
just as
prescribed that is just
but
is this that easy anymore
what if i take on g3
really really seven well i have to do it
right rook g7 check okay king f8
king f8 gets mated no i thought so i
don't think so rook to e3 oh rook e3 oh
i was a i was just about to uh get the
score sheets
signed signed yeah oh be careful yeah no
you can't start with rook to f7 and then
go e6 the problem is you have to face
rook to e3 okay so i'll take on h7 right
just to bring you back draw you that's
fine king g8 i have to play king g8
exactly
now what is the most convincing there
has to be something that's very very
convincing the material is getting more
limited than i would like it to be okay
let's let's go king f4
just sidestep this rookie three business
yes then you have to play rookie three
so rookie three anyway let's go behind
the pawn why not okay and that was
important because i really did want to
play rook check and e6 so you've got me
there
so now put your king
can you have faith yeah that's fine
you know this
this is confounding
because
at first i thought it was really easy
like right yeah like you got no chances
where where's the win
i assume you go to g8 sure yeah let's
try to oh you have to go to g8 okay
actually maybe it's a good idea to even
show why not e8 why not get too far away
from the roofs if you don't get too far
away from the rooks then
look to b7 or up to c7 a7 anywhere else
and you cannot catch root to h8 anymore
right and now rook h8 is going to be
checkmate
um the mechanism is that you have to
stay uh within close range to the roots
okay so in this case i'm looking for a
checkmate from a completely different
direction okay i want to go uh rook f5
to h5 so let's go rookie one rook e1
makes a lot of sense gosh darn it let's
create some threats as well okay e6 6 d3
who's going to be first i understand you
have e7
yeah and then if i take
on e7
do i have the check mating mechanism no
but you also have rook g1 it's okay
it's fine this this end game is winning
okay um
all right where did i go wrong christian
i said that really fast i don't believe
it
wow
the king on age
the king is too far there's no way
that's accepted
you have to go
to the missouri tigers
and go to their chess camp and
you know every day you can become a
better player every day
that's always try for you
uh wow okay uh let's just uh refresh my
board for just a quick moment and catch
up with the players
because
what did he miss mistakenly well i think
e4
can you four i understand but if you did
was the thing is if you never have e6
right if you never have e6 right
wouldn't you rather push together
pawn well i i think i can set up a
position where i do have e6 though no
what i'm saying is earlier
e6 is hard to get to
whereas before i felt that in this
position i actually liked the move b4
okay i actually liked playing this pawn
to b4 i felt this was much more natural
because it's a pawn that's further away
from the king so that any time i trade
rooks anytime that i force something
there it is i think that that's exactly
the thing you said the pawn is further
away from the king yeah i was trying to
use the e pawn as a reading so i wanted
to put the pawn on e6 check check and
maybe
so i thought
uh advancing the e pawn gave me a better
chance of of earning a checkmate you
feel it did no yasser you you you are
also you both are correct b4 obviously
was
made
you both are correct okay and i will
explain you why yasser you definitely
felt like you should use your eve pawn
as a weapon yes to deliver the checkmate
or to grab a rook and i think he was
focused too much on the checkmate
because in this position
after the move uh exchanging rook to h3
what he played was king to e4 okay huge
mistake
this is not the right direction because
you're always going to be susceptible to
the rook e3 check
that's a big problem what is the king
doing on e4 so you just start with you
go six first or the other way that's so
simple exactly and right now you give a
check and the problem is it's just made
well you sound good enough there's no
mate king of 87 doesn't matter because i
go to g8 right but i go e7 correct yes
that's it that's that's the key that's
the mechanism that he probably missed e7
he was too focused on this idea of using
the
his route e6 go to f7 what i'm saying
he's not supposed to do what was the
christian e6 is just
in that case if you played the movie he
played king e4 instantaneously that's
the problem he was trying to pressure
him on time and he had two minutes and
45 45 seconds ali reza that is he had 15
minutes and only three moves to go he
was supposed to stop and think he played
e4 he got impatient and
right now we got to this position ali
reza made time control he has one hour
try to defend
this ugly looking but maybe defendable
position guys that's crazy that that is
crazy it's insane to me that richard
went to e4 when we talked about all this
because well it took us a while to
understand it but he is a candidate
playing this
to think about it yeah we have to go to
the javascript because he has one minute
left
and how many moves still has five moves
to make well that's a lot and things
have changed with the last move that uh
which we talked about so we could play
c4 bishop e6 to curtail yeah advancing
the pawn rook and you played rook d5
fascinating
you taking on these sex i assume that
check
um that's a sweeping assumption but yeah
i didn't see what his plan is on rook c6
grabbing a pawn
very nice
i'm going to come and he did it by the
way he did play your move rook c6 and he
said
chuck hey look uh king dt or king f2
instinctively f2
your instincts are are correct
and now
timor has facing the music there's a
bishop
and there's a pawn on a six that's a big
nibble that's not the music yesterday
the music is
his down to his last minute oh oh
there's an hg sighting too
so he could actually play rook here
you can't take with the king anymore
take the pawn yes come on i know you
want to take the pawn
stay true to yourself
first of all absolutely i will take the
pawn but i love the pawn on g3
my pawn on g3 if i can split your pawns
let me just show you what i would like
best
is some position like this you have to
take with the rook you can't take with
the king you would walk into a fork you
take with the rook
now your majority is crippled and i get
this but i'm going to go through ca
oh shoot
yeah i think i think
i think it might be a
fancy place syndroming here fancy place
and
i miss that i don't think about fancy
place syndrome but it's true the famous
fps
i i have suffered it all my life
just just just just take the pawn and i
understand rook v6 is tempting and this
is the reason i think hikaru is thinking
about this position right otherwise you
just snap
but rook takes a6 fancy play syndrome
yes
we've got we got it all
for those of you who play scrabble
take this down i have to say i agree
with the entire thing i just have never
heard of lpdo me either
what is that loose piece drop off what
no i was really happy uh about zeit
naught and luff and john
i was apparently our producers are
telling us
these are spinners so well shout out to
peter we miss him we definitely miss him
although
yeah okay but some of these look kind of
normal
yeah okay
all right so
hikaru i assumed too if he
took and there was a trade oh not not
rook d6 it was rook takes a6 there was a
trade i was so happy to be able to play
two more moves to make and only 20
seconds for rajabov
[Music]
um how knowing
is this according to the engines this
looks huge
plus three that's even bigger than i
thought after the move rook to e4 yes
rook to e4 was wrong
look the position is
it was already very bad yeah i mean it
kind of looks natural a strong engine
was saying it was very bad
okay so rook to e4 uh going after the h
pawn that looks very natural now
i would attack the bishop
i think you have to you can't really
defend this otherwise right exactly so
rook to d6 right just to that makes
sense uh force the bishop yeah where is
your bishop going i think it you cannot
allow me three connected past pawns with
knight takes b5 especially when you
don't have a single connected pawn so
you're never gonna queen exactly so i'm
assuming the bishop has to
uh maintain the defense
fantastic move rookie six that that
shocks the game immediately this game
yeah that's it no question
so
and he's done rook d6 that looks like
game to me
excuse me
five seconds
he has to make a move bishop to c8 was
played
rookies on the clock two seconds on the
clock
and was that move 40 then yes wow
he made it but unfortunately from a
position point of view he didn't make it
no well what is the what is the cleanest
here let's try to be accurate with uh
with white because knight takes b5 okay
rook takes h4 does come with a couple of
threads i do have rook h2 it is a little
bit annoying still
i understand i should be winning but
but there are three connected pass bombs
over there so you get your rook to h2
and then work b
and then you're never going to get to
play h4 and never it's a long time right
okay let's let's give it a a whirl
uh knight d4 or yeah i like knight to d4
actually
let me protect my pawn this way
i can always meet king
with some kinds of checks right drive
you back
i'm not so convinced about this yeah
what if i go bishop g4 and f5
bishop to g4 sorry we should before king
g505 my idea
bishop
to g4 and f5
it's actually not so easy right well
let's just see okay i'm i'm pushing
pawns all right i'll push my king
you push your keys
so ah but now uh knight check
drives you
hangs the b pawn i apologize so i
actually have to start with b4
so that in case you buy kg5 i can go to
knight at 3 chat
although you're you're kind of you're
making it easier
i mean my palms don't automatically quit
you know queen's so fast right right
yeah
okay uh
so he's actually not actually he's not
taking on b5 maybe that's why he's at
you're
and by the way yeah
uh in a number
where you're playing king g5 it might be
useful for us to be able to have a check
for i like icarus move i like carl's
move very much rook v8 i think it's just
much more accurate than taking on b5
immediately
yeah i agree because the bishop doesn't
have a very good square right now if it
goes to g4 or it blocks your own threat
yeah i can then go after your pawn uh
easily i could even take on b5 two
connected pawns are enough i can give up
e2
sorry
okay so the bishop has a lack of squares
and hikaru
the both players made time control
they'll each get awarded another 60
minutes for the next 20 moves
and let's take a look at the standings
as we'll uh catch a lunch break
well here's here are the players in the
dug house
yeah absolutely but hikaru currently the
only player without a point but he might
get a full one as he is uh on the verge
of winning in my opinion i don't know
what the computer says but in my opinion
he is on the verge of winning against
taymor rajabov and we still are waiting
for the game between richard rockwood
and elizabeth which despite richard's
inaccuracies he still has the upper hand
i don't know if it's enough to win but
he is the one pushing against the french
player and already we have the results
of fabiano caruana drawing against janna
pognachi and yanshi of duda drawing
against the lorenz so remember if
richard wins he will be joining the lead
yeah
jumping up uh for a three-way tie well
uh we're gonna take a break we'll see on
the other side don't go away as we
continue our coverage of the candidates
round two
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everybody and welcome to the
candidates the second round and we
already have two results on the books
for today's game two zeros two draws and
four two games spending yes absolutely
because janna pogba she had a barn
burner against fabiano caruana it ended
in a peaceful draw at the end right but
it really was an exciting game anything
could have happened yeah do that tried
to beat dingler and couldn't really get
past the fortress and they split that
point and we have two games remaining
richard rapport is currently pressing
against all the rest of russia
we think he's winning but we still we
still haven't figured out geometrically
exactly how to do so and we have
teamwork
barely holding on against hikaru
nakamura but he might actually not be
holding on he might actually just be
lost exactly so we got two potential
victories which would match our results
from round one and as we were on our
break uh wolfing down our lunch um the
question uh arose okay how should richie
win i mean we think that he's absolutely
winning
and christian we need to turn this over
to you and to just tell us what the
engine thinks
is the best play for white
well uh i have to say guys i've been uh
playing around with the engine a little
bit and still i cannot find the exact
method so right now the engine is saying
plus three point something that is a
decisive advantage we know that but how
does he want to get that decisive
advantage rook to g7 the first move it
immediately drops to 1.8 y king to f8
now 3.4 again look to c7 i understand
i'm presenting a checkmate you have to
defend against that the only way to
defend that is to go king to g8 you can
dance around with the rooks as much as
you want right
at some point you have to defend this
pawn on e5 and try to push it all the
way to e6 if you manage right to get the
pawn to e6 then you're going to be in a
winning position
let's try to understand why yes let's
make uh that looks like a great move
let's do something like this right we're
in the same position just with white to
move right now e6
this has a huge threat right now rook to
g7 so let's say you go i don't know rook
to king f8 okay check you cannot go to
e8 because that's
made in one move you have to go to g you
give another check now you go here now i
followed now you go here now i follow
you and once you get to f8 now that my
pawn is on e6 i have once again this
extra option of just picking up one of
your rooks with e7 this is it game looks
simple
very simple right but the problem is
after you do all of this beautiful stuff
and you get the rook to e7 yeah
black plays move rook to f8
okay and right now the engine out of 3.4
jumps to zeros
zeros
that's a draw
that's a draw you cannot go here why
because i will go look to f1 and by the
way the same thing happens if you go to
g4 i'm going to drop the rook to the
first rank or the second rank i think
that one equalizes as well
now
what is your next move
if i go e6
if you go e6 rook to
g1 and now you cannot hide my rook is
defensive so i'm just going to give you
checks just to perpetual uh you can take
my pawn that's okay well actually if you
take my point
yeah so you cannot even take the pawn
and that's just it's just perpetual
because my rook on e3 is defending so
you go to f4 you're not attacking the
rook i can still continue giving you
checks from behind
this is the problem i'm going behind you
and then i'm starting to have big
threats of perpetual it's a problem and
i'm not sure how richie
is supposed to solve it i i will dig
deeper and i will try to understand
whether he has any chances but right now
well chances for sure there are but
right now i'm not seeing the exact
pattern to finish this game
king e4 might have been
a decisive blunder allowing ali reza to
miraculously
save this game all right what is this
what is that
okay the engine says plus 50. so i guess
it's winning okay uh it's rook yeah i
got the right position right
yes you do so it starts rook h g7 rook
on h7 to g7 you have eight king fa let's
see what is more or less forced right
all right
and oh it's just b4
b4
yeah it eventually it eventually wins
wow so
b4
didn't see that one coming so what did i
go about
so we're dreaming yeah rookie one you go
there's there's many moves that went
here but basically
you gain a tempo you got rook h7
okay the king has to do
h8 he has to go to g8 right yeah rook
bg7 okay
right here i think on g6
okay so now
you're threatening something like rook
h8 i mean i am threatening yeah ricky
chad ricky sawing with a rook right
yeah this is just one
so what was the difference why couldn't
you do this with a roof on e3 man
[Laughter]
all right i'll i'll i'll get to that all
right let me see rook bg7 king of f8
rook takes g6 you have rookie 8. don't
ask me why but at that position rookie 8
draws and whether on e3 is winning uh is
a draw with the rook on e1 and the point
on b4 is waiting yes
here rookie 8 still loses easy to mess
it up this is very easy to mess it up
for wow b4 wasn't the first move that
came to my mind either no i mean i've
been resisting i was always trying to
play rook to e7 and e5 6
and just as a christian pointed out rook
f8 czech and rook f1
really hurts my feelings i mean also
understanding that rookie draws is it's
pretty hard wow what is the difference
by the way at the end of that line
rookie eight would be
just the end game is lost with the pawn
on d4 on b4
yeah so you go on that variation that
we're looking at with you know you start
with b4 rook age g7 or whatever king f8
and then b4 okay and then we go back
into that variation with rookie one okay
uh rook h7 and we we force you to go to
g8 yes you do you go rook bg7 king of f8
yes you take on g6 here and in the other
variation we're playing rookie 8 which
might be one of the only moves
so guys yeah just one thing i want to
mention
which position do you feel more
comfortable right now as white with the
rook on e3 or with the rook on e1 the
way i see it with the rock on e3 i feel
much more comfortable not only that
you're not giving us from afar but also
you don't have the move d3 no i i
underst i understand if you go down the
line you like you'll understand but
psychologically it's very difficult to
just give up a tempo like that i agree
completely with what you're saying i'm
just reading the engine uh the point is
that if you go uh rookie in this
particular position yes
i can trade the rooks with rook h8
and pick up your pawn
and with the with the pawn on b4 as well
as on
e5 yes and with the rook coming to d6 i
pick up d4 and defend b4 if the pawn was
on b2 i know
b3 that work was on b3 or on e3 or
wherever yeah and you go rook b3 you go
to the b file you attack my pawn exactly
and then of course it's not it's a drawn
end game it's three grandmasters with
two engines and we barely made it
um
this is not gonna be easy
he made he made his life much more uh
much harder than it was supposed to be
yeah we all agree at that point that
this one should not have reached this
position exactly because
no question about it on his birthday ali
received a gift
had
richard just played the move e6
rook takes and king c4 thanks to the
pawn already on e6 the fire power of the
doubled rooks along with the passer
would have just won the game on the spot
uh the
too fancy the fancy
king e4 made things a little bit
difficult now because
the desired e6
walks into rookie three and what is your
king doing on e4
he got thrown a lifeline
is essentially what happened and we are
catching know that i want to refresh my
board and catch up with the players
richard has just reached this moment all
right so
one of the things that i had also asked
and i don't know if you guys answered if
i just take the pawn and like the most
ugly mundane way
and we're here we love bugger monday
yeah i do too uh i've got ideas of uh
using my two rooks for mating that
is that
yeah rook
yeah
unbelievable just exactly
unbelievable is the right word wow yeah
this is crazy but he needs he needs to
understand everything that we're
analyzing without an engine with a
clicking uh i mean i don't understand it
with an engine exactly that's crazy and
knowing that he got to where he is from
a completely winning position
and we know that he has this tendency to
be a bit self-defeating at times richie
that is yes that might kick in
that might kick in yeah that is a
definite weakness of uh richie is
i don't want to say self-confidence i
think all of these players have a great
deal of self-confidence but he does
allow
moments of doubt to creep in and
he's got to give that up i mean you know
especially here yeah
long tournament even if he doesn't win
this game he needs to be able to come
back to the tournament not the way that
happened in bucharest where i felt that
the moment that he wanted to move 40
against that day this tournament was
over and he never
really recovered from that
just like nepo in the world championship
match he lost that one marathon game and
it was a tale of two two matches uh the
first half very very competitive the
second half
yeah i mean uh yeah but sleepwalking
through uh those
games and let's jump over to hikaru as
this rook ending has really flummoxed
us
for quite some time and
we thought hikaro was putting some nice
finishing touches
on the game is
that timor still in there with a shout
knight f3
rook
what is what
what do you play against rick c6 that
was my question i mean i understood that
he played the move rook
a7 to stop rook a6 yay
but after rook
c7
why can't we do this
because that's where you have christian
christians
why can't i play
because he went rookie four
oh maybe you just go back rookie sound
yeah you're right ricky simon and rookie
but still like well wait a second is
that the way you win the game not really
yeah rook and bring it back to him
what yeah rook c6 was a decent move
yeah very decent move yeah now i have to
go rookie seven and bring back the rook
to e3 there's no other way right that
allows uh black to kind of sort of ease
back into the game at least uh from the
point of view of the activity of his
pieces versus the activity of his
opponent's pieces now i kind of like it
the last piece
i'm harassing you a little bit like this
and it's not going to be as easy for you
to start pushing your pawns if you don't
manage to do that then i might even
involve somehow my king into the play
and this is what i'm dreaming of right
of course but in that particular
position christian that you have on the
board rook c2 defends the pawn yes it
does prep oh
sorry look c2 it does prep knight d4
on a good day sure let's go 36 94
or e4 actually i have to go for the
counter play yeah vih-4 and i take the
pawn you take my team that's the thing
yeah this is kind of positions yes in
rook end games pure work in games you
want the work behind the point that's
clear
in this particular rook end game not
really right might be a problem this h
pawn is quite advanced right let's not
forget about that if you manage to get
it all the way to h3 it becomes
extremely problematic oh come on
come on the power it's not easy
okay
okay let's go with king g3 uh sidestep
rook h2 you know what the nice thing
about having less king h2 i only have to
push one of them true
king g1
sure yeah check me again and i'll play
i'm going to win this game i'm i'm
continuing with my threats rook to h1
followed by rook to h2 and i'm picking
up the rook you have to be careful
computer is saying already zeros wow
three connected past pawns that is just
two endings that are really that
foundation might have been a very decent
option oh
this rook is c6 move
but he didn't play that he played rookie
four no he did not he played rookie four
followed by king to f7 afterwards to d8
so still staying quite passive on this
side i understand the rook is active but
it can easily be kicked out with rook to
d4 ideas um
still a game still obviously hikaru is
in the driver's seat and very close to
proving his medal in this one and
bouncing back but um there's some work
to be done it seems like a
really really surprising for me there
seems to be a lot of work to be done
it's not
just
i mean you know in bridge you claim you
say you know this is it i make the
contract uh here i thought it should be
easy with the three connected past pawns
but
that move bishop d5 really rock rocked
my world rook h1 check
remarketing
um christian i understand that you have
a very nice special for us
uh about the openings uh but he's
reluctant he's shy he knows a lot but
he's not he just doesn't want to show
his prep ah
he's saving it for the candidates
this is this is your job guys look at
those beautiful graphics coming your way
this is a surprise for us because we
haven't been shown this graphics opening
uh opening moves the caro khan e4 c6 oh
we have to show it on the on the board
uh on my board i guess so absolutely
well let me go back to uh
[Laughter]
did i hear that right just like when you
rehearsed hello e4 c6 a specialty of
mine i love the car cod when i'm playing
against one e2 e4
there's essentially two approaches you
allow the e pawn to lift and you play
moves like e5 or c5 so you don't attack
the e pawn
e7 e6 is the french defense so you
attack the e pawn with d5 and the karo
khan the one i like is to attack the
d-pawn this way
because in the french defense
uh and you were telling me this is like
hilarious
um
uh
in chicago the
uh game between alexander shabalov
and uh jeffrey young jeffrey young is
black
now everybody tries to play knight c6
here and he develops the bishop outside
the pawn chain jeffrey played this move
e7 e6 transposing back into a french
a tempo down that was like the word you
were saying it was the worst opening
you've ever seen
that was pretty i think about three
moves it's pretty up there
with the
c7 and the c6 and d5
yeah i would just say that caro khan
is currently
topical
at one time it would i felt it was more
topical today the berlin the joco pianos
e7 e5 is kind of pushed everything even
even this is the wanted sicilian i mean
everybody played the sicilian at one
time and now e5 has become the go-to
defense
yeah i feel that outside e4 c5 e4 e5 and
e4 c5 though outside of those two i
still do think the karaoke has a
comfortable third right above pretty
much anything else i mean the other
or the other one as far
at one time the alakan defense even
played by bobby fisher in the world
championship match against boris baskey
he played the alekhine defense
only love albert in the entire world of
top grand masters and evancha when he
dabbled in the in the allegheny not
killed i mean people uh
and then
we're being challenged
do we know what a benodium
d4 all right the benodi let's go right
f6 bononi uh son of sorrow from uh the
hebrew c2 c4
c7 and c5 d5 now talking about an
opening or a defense that has really
fallen out of
favor
right
uh one time michael tall
was one of the
key proponents if you will uh
dr john nunn also played the
one one magnificent game i remember
against left polygayevsky he wrote about
it in his books a book of best games g7
g6 the bononi
okay you're not being very uh testing
here uh to our production staff i mean
uh
uh well choco piano get out of here
that's all we saw today was the joke of
piano
piano oh my goodness
all right how do you pronounce it
it's actually
but uh
it means slow game
yes um
in italian in italian uh bishop c4 uh
bishop b5 of course is the rui lopez but
bishop c4 there's the two knights
defense and that's interesting i've
always thought of the joke of piano i
don't think of the joker piano now i
think of the joker piano now when black
plays bishop
so i think that you know there's the two
nights that's a nice defense on the joke
which is transposing to each other right
but not necessarily i just had this
great story bobby fischer so bobby
fischer's wife and his opponent
he plays a knight f6 i think this was
from the u.s junior open
and bobby as a team
played the move knight to g5 and
everybody understands that the main line
begins d7 d5 normally speaking you're
trying to block this threat but bobby's
opponent played bishop c5 and bobby
openly laughed
at the board
and he kept laughing and then he stopped
and then he started thinking
and he thought for the longest time now
he started to realize that the desirable
knight takes f7
will walk into bishop takes f2
and things start getting really really
crazy so now he starts respecting the
move bishop c5 and after a very long
thing you know what he did it's really
remarkable he played bishop takes f7
check
king e7
bishop to d5 which today is considered
one of the best
ways of meeting this defense
that's the board for the genius exactly
queen's gambit declined one more time
coming they keep coming okay so white
usually has a choice open with a king
pong or open up with the queen park so
in the queen's gambit declined you open
up with the queen pawn black does the
same
d4 d5 c4 now this moment you can capture
the spawn and that becomes known as the
queen's gambit accepted the queen's
gambit declined
is when they play move e7 e6 and get on
with life and specifically e6 you could
decline it with c6 or other moves but it
does have their own
yeah that is considered the slaw of
defense with c7 c6 but e7 e6
and i remember the soviets especially uh
the armenian school of chess they they
developed this whole branch of the
queen's game that declined with the new
bishop e7 it's another opening that's
really making a comeback yes the queen's
gambit decline has become exceedingly
popular in the last five years and just
very solid for black and positions that
were thought that were worse
they're considered very holdable now and
people are not really afraid of playing
straight up into it exactly
and that was our look at opening moves
great so richard that's the challenge
excellent richard robert has blown his
advantage no
happy birthday uh ali right
yeah we saw this position yeah and we
said rookie two is a draw
we left it out that we didn't analyze
any further we need to analyze it a
little further now that way because now
that we're now it's very relevant so the
idea and you might ask why put a rook on
it when not only you want i assume to
take on b2
yes
but it's in a very specific moment and
that is that after look to f6 i'm not
going to give a check and exchange on f6
i'm actually going to go d3 and now with
a rook on e1 you have the extra option
of going rook to d6
unfortunately with the rook on e2 rook
to d6 would not be possible because then
i would just be able to exchange you
cannot take for example wait actually i
will give you a check can i exchange i'm
kind of curious
yeah you can also change yeah
take take you cannot take with the pawn
because of d2 that's a problem you have
to take back with the rookie
king goes to g7 and right on time not to
get cut and this is just a draw
so
if you do go with the rook to e1 which
to my naked eye seems like the much more
natural move you're getting further away
but also d3 d2 just feels a bit more
supported right with the rook on e1
because i'm already controlling the
promotion square
now after rook to f6 it does seem like
it still gives white an advantage it's
not that easy and let's try to
understand why so rook this is rook to
f8 rook to f6
rook to e8 wow it still feels like a
dragon
yes but somehow even this feels like
white has some chances to win it
already
more chances than you deserve
yes yeah the computer is saying zero
zero but it's not an easy no no no no no
by any means you still have an extra
point still plenty of chances especially
with the king on h8 with the rock on it
is a completely different story because
you always have
this capture on b2 so quite a different
uh and difficult moment actually for ali
reza but if he finds rook to e2
he might actually escape
this one remarkable
just a remarkable houdini like this
i have to say but wow
i have to say this is rich's fault yeah
absolutely i don't know 100 percent
could i just ask 100 99 whatever you
want to call it this is really just a
quick question for you um
uh christian after the move rookie two
yes which you think is the only move and
i go e6 at last sure i get to push my
pawn let's push it as well okay i wanted
to go e7 and i'm hoping for rook f8 but
what if i give you a check first
because there's no actual checkmating
threats right
with the roofs like this
there's no checkmating threats and every
time you promote i'm going to sacrifice
my pawn is going to be closer to
promotion as well okay take my take my
blunder e7 back for just a moment yes
um it's not a blunder i just don't see
anything well i was looking at rook
d7 but you do have rook f8
yes yes oh man kg3 and i think there
should be more than one way to skin this
probably more more than one way i'm
curious if root takes b2 works or if
this is just losing probably this is
losing
well yeah this is losing but yeah well
it goes to show how easy oh but d2 you
can fall
not sure about d2 yeah this actually
still works it must be a joke
yeah d2 also works
rook to f2 also works and once again
once you double check your own rooks
this is actually much easier i think
yeah yeah yeah you're giving away i like
to a lot yeah i remember the line that
victor corchland made famous with
trembling hands
don't don't mess it up
uh a really wow a very very double-edged
game i feel like you know we use this
kind of a tight rope walking you know
like any moment
anybody slips
you fall you die uh what about hikaru
he's brought his rook all the way back
to d2 so
yeah he's defended his pawn
i thought we were trying to win i
thought so too
i mean uh it is a perplexing he's not
really made any progress right in the
last i don't know how many since he's
one since he won
yeah he's kind of moving the rook around
right
is it i don't like the knight on f3 uh
for me the knight on f3 is
absolutely ridiculously on the worst
square because
it can't go to
g5 or
e5 due to the pawn on f6 my whole
purpose is i'm kind of defending this
pawn on h4
make a move here just king g6 is that
okay sure okay
uh let me
let me bring the knight to a more
favorable square sorry
boy that was really bad in my mouth yeah
okay it's working it's still working uh
knight g2 knight f4 knight
g2 uh
king g3 knight f4 i just want to put my
knight on a on a nicer square
how do you like it
or not and if i go rookie four then you
have uh rook d4 that that that was what
i was willing
specifically here rookie two but i
understand that generally the concept is
to play rookie too
exactly i wanted to trade rooks uh
and i'm hoping it's a win it's a win it
looks like it win it feels good you know
you don't agree christopher jump in i'm
going to trade uh after king f5
so after rook d4 i'm going to go king f5
ah no no no no no no no no
no no no
although even though
i want to take on d4 and then go king e4
as soon as possible gotcha
it's not so easy right so easy gosh
all i wanted to do was
reposition my knight to a better square
and f3 maybe met with something along
the lines of bishop to c6 later on i
think that's right maybe you're liking
it
king f3 you could even take on the four
go bishop c6 sorry show me yeah here
because i think christian was saying
instead of after king f5 king f3 you can
take on d4 and bishop c6 and i yeah you
know for three years who's winning it's
true who's winning this one yeah it's
not uh it's suddenly as you say a three
result game not
not exactly what i
you know if i had my knight on f4 life
would be so good right now i mean it
just what is going on how come i'm
having trouble here i like the move king
g6 to begin with uh rookie four probably
also a very logical move i would say but
i'm kind of liking g6 uh unless i'm
really afraid of rookie two but i i
don't know how clean this the same games
are i go if i get my king to g4 you're
very active you're very active and this
bottom b5 is crucial that it's on b5 it
was on a5 it's lost if it's on c5 it's
lost but with the bottom b5 i'm kind of
controlling i mean everybody yeah
remember gary kasparov making an
annotation for the new in chess magazine
where he's playing a very very
double-edged sicilian where he he only
had a pawn on b4 that was it he was
blackhead upon him before the white hat
a2
b3 bb b3 c2 and this pawn on b4 was like
a bone in the throat that the majority
just couldn't move and gary was
chortling you know in his annotations
you know how great it was
uh are are we sure though here you you
get an active kick
no i'm not shaking i'm not sure of
anything yeah it is
all right guys i found a way to make
some progress good share some progress
and i'm not sure if i should call that
progress or not all right let's see so
knight to d4 i was thinking about okay
for inviting rook to e4 was kg6 played
by the way no no no no no but king g6
just feels like the right yeah rookie 14
g6 i think are my two top
picks and now this allows me to go rook
to e2 now you cannot take on h4 because
the bishop on e8 without the supports uh
the king support on f7 you're dropping
that you cannot do that so you have to
give a check first king to g3 check
again king to f3 you don't have bishop
to c6 now that the knight is on d4 king
to f7 and knight to f5
and at least somehow i activated my
knight
this is why i said this might at least
look like some sort of progress bishop
to c6 king to e3 rook to e4 king to d2
rook to f4
did you make any progress
from one side to this side right so
right again this is why i said uh i'm
not sure if this is progress but at
least my king is not cut on the king's
side it's ready to help the pawns
somehow wow um that's a bit vegan and by
the way the computer is saying
it's nothing zero get out of here yeah i
lost my advantage right right my
progress is no more in the words of ben
larson nobody believes you
it's a funny position because it feels
the more we analyze it
the greater the difficulty the greater
the difficulty the more
usually in this kind of end game we're
going to end up in this situation
conclusion right pretty early we're
going to end up this is exactly the
ending that i thought i was going to win
by claiming the game and it wasn't that
easy not at all not at all and
it feels that
it feels that
the real canyons are not so clear the
bishop versus knight enemies are not so
clear
and that the white has just like moved
the rook around yeah so what i think has
to happen right now we need a plan for
hikaru no no but this is what i think
hikaru's plan should be okay maneuver
the pieces around okay patient for a few
moves right 10 15 moves okay without
doing anything but try to pretend like
you're doing something
make your opponents spend their time
get down to your last five minutes get
down to the next time control the final
time control and after that you will be
able to swindle your opponent and then
transition into this crazy position
three versus two some sort of a race in
every single variation
go there but later
wait for a second well for a few moves
that is and then get positioned i agree
with you approach
generally yes
there's an extra difficulty in this
particular tournament that we are 11
moves away
from getting another 15 minutes
seconds
but that's the last one at least make uh
make roger buff play on his increment
yeah
well as a skater will ferrell said mind
bottling
i mean i thought these end games were
easy and they've turned out to be
nothing but difficult
it's amazing yeah
both of them both of them are very
confusing specifically
i understand that the rocket game in the
rapport game once it got to after the
move king e4 which was inaccurate then
it became very complicated and i can
understand that these rook end games are
very difficult to understand very messy
very uh computer like
but this one of hikarus to me is just
confounding because i would have thought
extra pawn
somehow you convert this right i mean
and
and so many variations you do end up
with three three
uh pass bonds versus what i would call
scraggly split pawns and those i i
thought create counterplay
man chess is hard chess is hard but man
this end game to me is incredible i i i
thought that by this point
tamer would have already resigned like i
thought hikira would find a plan and
just take the game
upon you
that's also one of the things i've
always admired about uh ikaro's play
when he does calculate a win yeah it's
it's bang bang bang bang bang he doesn't
hesitate he just goes right through it
it's not like he has any doubts about
bringing the point home uh clearly the
fact that both players have consumed so
much time and there's only a what a 15
minute difference between the two clocks
40 minutes for cairo yeah it's four he's
spending a lot of time he really is uh
now it's teamwork that's in the think
tank but in general
okay all of these chess engine
evaluations aside
come on in a practical game
i mean if you if you asked me at the
beginning of the end game i would have
said everything everything every time
yeah every time but
now that hikaru is kind of
wobbling right he's not fumbling the
ball he's just kind of like you know
wobbly stage at the moment he hasn't
really made any progress i'm starting to
wonder if he's not making any progress
because
the position is just difficult it's just
too difficult to make progress right now
right
the fact that also that is rook ended up
you know coming back to d2
really is off-putting uh i tried a
moment ago after the move king g6 to try
to reposition the knight if i don't
reposition the knight the only other
idea i really have in the position is
rook c2
followed by c4 allowing you to trade off
your wiki but in return i do get two
connected past pawns how do you like
them apples i actually like that pun a
lot g6 rook here let's say
how would uh
do you want to go king f5 i don't think
your king really waltzes into my my
position
because of c4 let's go rookie four rook
edgar four
okay on an active square
take it yes yeah what do you think back
with well rook takes i just want to i
want to keep the integrity of my
passers
so how how clean is this
take take bishop
knight d2 king at five right right
i don't want to see oh you want to see a
race you want to erase it king g4
yes yes yes yes you're happy to see a
race
actually maybe i will go even bishop to
you no
king takes h4 king f4 i might be doing
something awesome yeah yeah blocking my
king but right okay
but somebody said f5 was that you
christian take responsibility
no that was not me
i don't know what you're talking about
f5 here in this position okay and now
the race let's go
push him baby well therefore he's
mentally picking four and then you get
into c5
king g3 help yourself my knight cover is
f1
fair enough yeah let's go
all right no no this is too much no
but that i don't know check on
jack
and let's go all the way to the end and
make sure bishop e8 but now i go bishop
uh king c5 don't allow the king to come
to c5 don't give the check go bishop e8
first you're waiting too long to go
bishop
you're waiting too bishop but this race
feels
bad for
black yeah bishop c6 and where's the win
i mean i'm sure there is this just feels
bad like if you go f4 here
i tickle you no i'll take on h4 right
now
no no no no i think i want to go to g4
actually no
later we can always figure out where
sure the the king might be
yeah the knight is actually pretty good
because c6 h3 knight f1
and if i have my king to g3 how bad is
that well you don't try an h2
like in this position like if you're
king g3 you're not running h2 at the end
so okay g3 c5 that's the problem h4 c6
you're not h3 it's not a threat and with
c8 you actually actually threatened my
bishop yeah here's the problem yeah yeah
and h2 i'm i just uh but that's one
tempo
that's one tempo and we're loosely
making moves right yeah very loosely
making wait a minute wait a minute i
mean that was like
one of the first lines that i've won in
like four hours
but it's something to look at right yes
for for since the start of the show and
i don't think i had a winning line
since uh the the fabi game yeah a long
time finally right right okay so timor
actually went for the move rookie four
first okay which makes a lot of sense uh
with the king still on f7 rookie four we
were considering those that's the two
logical moves to the position very very
logical but if i i'm going to play for
c4
can i do it like this or oh my gosh you
have rook a7 a7
how is this position so full of problems
i know
whether i'm trying to reposition my
knight whether i'm trying to
make a pawn break on the queen side like
i'm starting to get angry that he car
was not just winning
i mean you're up a pawn you know a good
structure the bishop on eight is not
really
chess is not easy no chess is not easy
when you're facing the toughest defenses
in the world it's actually chess is not
leaders yeah
there's no easy games against this field
simple as that
wow
rook e4
oh boy okay a quick uh gander once again
at
richard's position after the move rook
g6 ali reza is sensing the critical
moment yeah he right here right now and
you know these four rook end games by
the way
can be mystifying i mean your your your
mind starts
you know like doing strange things
you you feel it become mush right right
right right like you think you're
calculating line after line and then
suddenly you see oh my god rook at five
i get mated on h5
and you suddenly forget
that you have a defense yes
like and and you panic
22 minute thing for alireza yeah it's
the time to do it right right this is
the time to do it this is you got the
extra hour
uh
this is the critical this is the
critical moment rook to e2 actually
equalizes the game of course you still
have to find a lot more moves after that
right but it becomes much easier and
rook to e2 on the other hand not an easy
move to make okay and the other move
which is very suggestive
in order to to cover the promotion
square does that blunder the game no no
question no no no no not entirely but
you will have to defend a more difficult
position after rook two f6 d3 and rook
to d6
and this was the big difference with the
rookonito you can exchange the rooks and
take on b2 gotcha and that helps your
case because that's just an easy
technical draw everybody knows that
especially at their level but rook to e1
allows this rook to d6 and then you have
to go to e8 then you have to contend
with this uh very dicey let's say uh end
games with four rooks i have the extra
pawn you have the king all the way to h8
it's not that easy gotcha yeah
at the highest level of stockfish the
moves are equivalent because stockfish
draws it but one has a much more humane
human path
towards good yeah take the pawn and the
other one is just you know you hold an
end game that you hold by a tempo yeah
it's super super super complicated right
so my and i am i believe
that those are the only two logical
drawing moves
rookie two yeah rookie one apparently
rookie eight is not losing but i don't
know whoever plays i move
that would be a difficult move to play
for sure
no but that's insane so it's either
rookie to a rookie one what he's
calculating exactly
um
long think
wrong thing yeah sometimes
sometimes uh
that is a saying
that we've used uh for decades in fact
and it oftentimes happens that a player
goes into a deep think and somehow
all the lines that get calculated end up
being unsatisfactory and then something
poor is played how often did you feel as
a chess player that because you spent
more than 10 minutes on a move you made
a better move than if you hadn't
not as often as i would have liked
truth be told but i do feel
that over my career
i have spent 12 minutes and 15 minutes
and i've come up with something that
really felt maybe made me feel really
good like yeah i did something
and you know i always felt that way
about classical chess
that you know i
i'm amazed by how well these top players
played blitz and rapid but when you see
a game for example like these world
championship match games that gary
kasparov and anatoly karpa played
and
it was art it was just unbelievable what
ideas and conceptions they came up with
and uh i was thrilled and that was the
only chess we really played because
there wasn't a world bliss championship
you know sadly enough i would have loved
that
all right um questions no rookie to play
rookie to play to play wow wow
the youngster finds it and he is one
step closer to saving this miracle draw
on his birthday
who said he's a weak endgame player that
this is his weakness and you got it
the haters
and not me
no that's a nice move and a very very
difficult move indeed to find
wow and he found it but let's take a
look at what's happening in hikaru
versus uh timur right now after rook to
d to rook to e4 rook to d5 and this is
another uh question that i have for you
guys and i've been thinking about this
how often do we see this time control at
the lead level where you don't get the
increment the last time i can think of
is actually the world championship match
exactly
but outside of that and nobody else
outside of uh
nepo recently as well as fabiano right
in
2018 they don't have the experience to
play under this time control and this is
what i'm seeing
right now from timor you were mentioning
alejandro okay there is 11 moves to make
until the next time control how easy it
is to make those 11 moves because for
the last move
rajavov spent 12 minutes rookie four
d5 immediately played by hikaru and
right now he's once again already on a
three four minute uh long thing well
temer's right table rajabo's last
tournament had no increment until move
40.
which one norway norway norway norwich
has was two hours for the game and then
you get an increment and i think he
scores something along the lines of
minus and then they yeah yeah
they're terrible then they had these
i really have a problem with a lot of
things about the fide cycle i'm not a
big fan of the feed a cycle and one of
the problems i have is at the time
control so if you're going to play this
world championship cycle then every
aspect of the world championship cycle
should be the same time control yeah i
agree i mean if you're going to play in
the fide swiss which qualifies the fide
grand prix which qualifies
the candidates which determines the
challenger
they should be all the same time control
when you play for the world championship
it's it's a very strange thing
to play uh different time controls in
the same cycle
and i don't like it i agree
we'll do something
[Laughter]
give you your marching orders
what am i here
how about you christian what's your uh
perspective about these different type
controls you said it perfectly yeah i
mean it feels like you're playing almost
not different games right you cannot
call a different time control a
different game but the way you're
spending your time the way you calculate
variations the way you allow yourself to
assess positions how much time are you
going to spend on assessment in the
middle of the game
everything differs with this type of
different time controls and as you are
mentioning they should be playing in a
whole cycle with the same time control i
feel this is the most fair way of
getting to the world championship match
and potentially winning a title yeah i
remember boris gelfand way back in the
day
also complaining exactly this that you
know like he would show up at
tournaments and he didn't know what the
time controls were going to be and he's
like what's you know like can't we all
just agree this is classical this is
blitz this is but we haven't no
we just haven't yeah which to me is
fascinating now if you had to pick one
for classical which one would it be
i like the
the increment i like the 90 minutes and
30 minutes end of story
with the 30 minutes of time to time
control with the two with the increment
so you get 90 minutes for the first 40
moves and then you get 30 minutes at the
end of move 40
and you play on the increment and i've
seen a lot of players playing on the
increment and the games are they have a
good flow good and
the players
have learned to play that time control
and they play it very very well well
guys we we have a move please e6 e6 was
played rich in the ali reza versus
richard game richie versus ali reza e6
was played but
the natural response right now is to go
d3 exactly bang d3 what do you do next
we've seen after rook to d7 relationship
faith get the rooks doubled
on the second rank give perpetual checks
make a draw we've seen that that must be
easy to calculate now
how is it testing ali brezza is the
question after d3 the ego e7 is this the
big test but after rook to d4 and then
d3 let's say king to f3 d2
perhaps this is the position that he's
trying to achieve
oh my goodness check this out
that's a mate don't get the queen
right boom boom boom and the pawn
defends the f8 square right you cannot
do that but we can play rook takes e7
yeah it looks like a drawer rook takes
c7 is also a draw yeah
just in time
yeah i i i'm not seeing the test
okay
can we try it again rook d7 rugby seven
first okay yeah rook f8 check king g3
you played rook ff2 yes and you said
that uh okay so let's try uh rook g4
rook g4 yes so now you can't take the
pawn on e6 because your rook is hanging
right king h4
if i can maintain the b-pawn
but how about how did because
rookie's x right
once again the rook is on the second
round ready to uh grab beats pretty
depressing i know
oh
i have a discover check
yeah go ahead take my pawn be a hero
rook takes
rook takes b2 christian do it do it you
can do it no no no no no no way party
boo no wait
did you see that all right we're going
to show it we're going to show it to
it's important very nice very nice
discovery check follow it up with rook
h7 the rookies lost yes beautiful
thank you i'm not happy
you're not going to catch me with these
type of things yeah i know i feel better
how about you
i don't feel anything by this point
and by the way yes
other things have happened
oh a6 rook to e8 whoa now we have a
couple of checks repeating the position
that's right
and what if we continue with rook to f6
now this looks kind of dangerous right
can i give you some checks on h6 and
g6
after d3 yeah yeah okay
and i can drive you to f8 check yeah and
check some more
check here yeah
and check on
g7
oh king f6 oh
and the rook is protected right the rook
is protected you ride on time
to protect you and another reason why
rook to itu is better than rook to e1
yeah wow
okay this guy might have just simply
calculated the whole position that's and
decided on rook to e2 the perfect move
that's amazing by the way one of the
things that i've always felt about the
world champions is uh you know they get
typecast somebody like michael tall is
only
a
a tactical wizard no
these guys had great technique i mean
from the karpovs the kramniks the
sparrows the smithslavs the petrosians
uh all of these world champions uh
calculated end games wonderfully well
and they could
write books on the end games as well
and they did and they did smith wrote
about uh
well it's a move finally
by ikaru tonight i mean you know you go
through a whole plethora of menu of
moves like i could play this i could
play this like
and you come after a long thing to the
move a3
all right what if i
go back
brook
e57
makes sense because now you can tickle
from both the a7 and the c7 squares
exactly
um i just want to win this point
i feel knight d4 is box
i
what else can i do you can go back to e4
you can go rook
to a7 um
i don't
i don't think i want to take on on a3
right let's go down the line just
curious for k7 knight takes b4 b5 is b5
sorry bishop takes rook they must be
winning right and i just hope that these
pawns go as fast as their little
legs can take them scurry up the board
that's very nice so rookie 794 is the
issue right
and again in that moment where i played
knight d4 you could return with your
rook
in in previous
positions you were getting
counter play by taking the h4 pawn no
that must be the way to do it right
94 rookie four okay and
we're we're i mean we're back in these
waters yeah the modern a3 didn't help
you it's just the same thing
are we sure
pretty much
um let's say i well it did help me in
the sense that any rook check
that's what it does
okay
so
yeah
uh
you're you're not obliged to give me a
check either
but
wow uh guys uh we're gonna keep an eye
on these games we'll certainly come back
we'll be very flexible with our break
time but i hope you're enjoying our
coverage as these two very very
hard-fought games
are going down to the wire seriously it
does feel like perhaps the other razor
game is closer to ending but not quite
there yet we'll keep an eye because the
hikaru again guys it's gonna go on for a
while we're not gonna miss a second of
it we'll take a quick break and we'll be
right back
[Music]
if you have kids you already know st
louis has a ton of fun stuff for
families to do like the magic house or
the science center and if you really
want to be a stellar parent come see all
the new stuff there is to discover at st
louis union station
with a new mirror maze light shows and
the 20-story high st louis wheel it's
enough to make any parent feel like a
star
st lou is always exploring
welcome to our show
[Music]
you guys gotta see this
[Music]
that's our show now go start yourself
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and we have our standings it's fabiano
caruana and yanaponyacci here after two
rounds of the candidates with one and a
half points the answer is drew his game
against dingley around a game in which
the foliage player said i am satisfied
with this game right he felt that his
preparation landed him in a place where
he did not know what to do and it felt
so over the board meanwhile we have two
games remaining and they are still up
for grabs it's richard rapper pressing
against all the rest of furuja and it's
hikar nakamura in a borderline winning
position i think against tamura chavo
but let's go to the uh ali reza game
right because
the engine
kept the beat yeah the game has been so
unpredictable and when we kind of left
it we left it just around the
these spots
and we
kind of convinced ourselves uh thanks to
the chess engines that it was zero zero
okay rook f6 is kind of a very tricky
move and then suddenly ali reza played
rook e7 and the engine burped and said
uh oh that's not a good move
and it instantly suggested the move king
f5
as much much better for white and we
were trying to figure it out as we were
coming on air yeah it isn't the easiest
but i think the idea is that you defend
the pawn and you prepare the move for g1
or rook g anything so for example d3
let's say let's say and i go rook g3 i
attack your opponent oh rookie one is
fine okay i don't think it's a
difference at this point okay
and i have a very salient thread right
i'm threading checkmate in three
starting with rook f8
so
you need to defend from this somehow and
it's actually not not so easy so just to
be clear your checkmate in three threat
is what cafe yeah king h7
what am i saying
good morning or good afternoon st louis
right
no actually what the idea is of this
rook to g1 is to double up on the h file
so you go check on each one
uh after d2 we go check it out check on
h1
g7 is checkmate yes king g7 is rook to
g6 kf8 rook to h8 mate that's a nice one
christian nice
and if rook h7 i have rook f8
correct yes and if rook h7 you have rook
f8 that's that's and then i get to care
and then i get to
pick up the rook for free with the rook
on h6 this wouldn't be possible so
that's why you drop first on the first
rank gotcha so
and i think the critical line is after
look to h1 okay so g1 d2 rook h1
king to g8
okay
because now rook to g6 is going to be
met by rook to g7 okay so what you do is
you go to h6 first oh my goodness so
you're threatening maiden 2
exactly rook h8
and rook h
1 to h7 and if i go rook f2 rook f2 i
think it's k5 right king g5 or king e5
king e5 i'm going to decision
g7 there's no way you're winning
all right no no no no but i can kind of
warm my way here right i want to go to
d6 yeah i'm warming my way there
wow so
there was that very very
window
uh of opportunity it's hard
king f5 but king f5 is one of those
moves that you kind of aspire to play
that's
you want to get closer to the guy's king
so you can give deliver a checkmate you
want to defend the pawn on e6
uh but richard said hey look i've got a
passer b4 and
d3 is on the board we're up but did this
move christian b4
cost richard the victory it does feel
like it
what do you do now i mean how do you
the same line don't work anymore the
same lines don't work anymore because
now my pawn is already on d2 right right
so after rook to g1 in
any sort of situation so for example if
you go king to f5
d2 and now rook to g1 i have rook to e1
and actually i think it's what you
probably have to find some sort of
perpetual okay
can i just uh yes you want this one can
i go king to g8 king to g8
oh i don't even though excuse me i don't
get my rook don't i have just
one second don't i have rook h7
no that was the that was the line i
wanted actually it was rook h76
locations
yeah i'm attacking both routes that's
the problem exactly
and i thought i was going to play
with my rook
recovering
i can i can take either one of these and
still draw and still draw okay so let's
say you bring your king closer
and this is a
draw
probably well what if i give you checks
right so i started with a check on f2
where do you put the kink that's already
a problem right there because you cannot
go on the d files you have to get away
from the part and now i don't even have
to hurry i can just go king to e8 i
think that's easy yeah even even d1 is
just a draw uh d1 you take king on e7
you have to go rookie one otherwise okay
pretty basic draw but let's go back to
the game uh position because we do have
a move
g3 was played okay
so
rook to g we think that d2 should be
well why isn't the e pawn now hanging oh
well you can think that yeah
and then richard's happy he's a pawn up
and maybe not that one i think is
winning yeah b-pawn will run for a
touchdown because after rook to d4 at
the end you have rook to e4 covering it
in fact this is exactly the ending i
wanted which was d2
rook check you have to play rook h7
i was going to trade and this was the
ending i more or less wanted
which was
oh
i was going to trade the e pawn for the
d-pawn good luck but how did that
yeah this is a draw
your king's not cut off nope
i mean i i i i'm just reading
oh
right i'm not going to argue with the
table faces yeah i think that would be
bit also remember it's a b-pawn right so
if i passively defend on v8 yes it's
still a draw
okay so we do have b4 and rook g3 on the
board d2 has been played by the way and
we've caught up with the players
uh you were mentioning uh christian the
idea that you need to test your opponent
as often as possible
what are the tests
that ali reza still has to pass i don't
see any more tests the position has just
become a bit uh too simplified at this
point my pawn is already on d2 so i have
a real threat that you have to defend
against you don't have anywhere
anywhere to run away from my threats
right now so you have
to decide the position as it is with
rook to h6 rook to h7 exchange a pair of
rooks
there's nothing else you can already
done
rook h6 rook h7 as you said is on the
board do we have the trade of the root
cesar we have the trade of the rooks and
then rook to d3 will come on the board
the only exactly to stop the pawn from
promoting we assume the king will slide
over probably to g6 or g7 it is a bit of
both surprising and depressing to me but
the table base says that even if you
take on e6 directly it's a draw yeah wow
again your king is just bad on f4
to quote the king's
trembling hands i would take on e6 i
just like look at everything i would
never take one
i would be frightened that uh you get
you get right on time right you get to
have sex on time exactly team g6 rook b2
king king f6
and on b5 you have bc i can't even go
king e7 i think and your king just
marches over with mine
to c7 and b7 fair enough that looks yeah
and that has
appeared on the board now king g7 king
g6 is normal rook e6
again trembling hands but that's good
enough it's good enough but even if
that's good enough the other variations
are probably easier i don't know any
human that would take on e6 in this
position you can just do it later right
uh so we do expect to move king g7 after
king takes rookie already on the board
king g7 to us is a lot
more natural of a move sure you'd rather
take with the king then look at the get
the get your rug yeah
you know once you neutralize this pawn
then you want to play d1 and get europe
behind exactly
and the only dangerous move here would
be king of five but we kind of
neutralized it by just giving a check
exactly
guys this one seems to be headed for a
drop but the other one has changed quite
dramatically and let's take a look at
what happened in that one i think we
left it somewhere around here after the
move a3 rook to e7 knight to d4 and we
saw rook to e4 and the transition into
this sort of uh racy looking position i
have three pawns on this side you get
two pawns on this side and which ones
are going to go faster let's take a look
rook takes h4 knight to d4 check rook to
d2 i have three of them so i'm going to
use this one first then i'm going to
push the a pawn as well king to h4
bishop to f7 which appears to be
a big mistake
by timur rajabov
allowing white to get a winning position
rook to c3 it seems like it would have
held equality no way yes that's typical
yes way but why why is that the case
well h5 because you take
and apparently this is get out of it
you're stuck
this is a study-like position no way
this is a draw you don't have i'm going
to keep checking you
come on come on this is incredible guys
i don't believe it i'm just going to
keep on checking you
if you try to get close to
i'm going to you cannot catch the pawn
well you can but you're going to have to
give me some resources the night is
going to be a huge resource and then i'm
just going to get the king
you know i'm going
and say you know what
this is like i don't understand chess
anymore how can that not be a winning
position guys i'm telling you this is
the era of alien chess i'm done wow i'm
done with trust yeah knight on d4 rook
on d5 passport on the a file against two
disconnected pawns right that are really
ugly looking weaknesses and the kings
and the king the black king isn't doing
anything specifically bishop f7 was the
mistake oh my crucial mistake and after
rook to d8 look to d1
now excuse me a4 came on the board now i
have another passer running down the
board and you cannot include your bishop
into the defense anymore because right
now the bishop one f7 is stuck
controlled by my pieces e6 is controlled
e8 is controlled d5 is controlled that's
why he played the move c4
this is after king to g3 h4
king to f4
seems to be giving
white a decisive advantage what a game i
mean what a grind by hikaru nakamura in
this one i mean the game goes on right
but why is it like it does you go here i
know bastard though i'm still kind of
confused you're not in time what do you
do what do you do next how do you push
without the help of the bishop how do
you push
i don't know i see king g5 now i'm i'm
i'm going forward
and if i go after the a pawn no no this
is fine i like f5 you do okay
i like forcing this knight back then i
push the other pawn what that is crazy
i mean i have a lot of pawns again it's
all about how controlled this bishop is
oh my god you cannot get it to this
diagonal to stop my c pawn by the way i
i really feel like i
i mean
i just
i'm struggling to understand and make
sense of go with a check uh check the
guy that's okay you can check it it's no
problem i hide
you don't have the next check on c2 so
you can you're going to have to lose
another tempo defending this pawn and
then i can go c7 at some point or pc
depending on what you do wait what what
it means
well depending on what you do
if you go bishop to c4 or c7 this way
yeah so here who goes bishop c what does
this mean so you could go b5 bishop
takes bb oh good job
yeah this is just simply over
again the bishop is so controlled by the
knight is dominated by the knight on d4
as well as the rook on d8 um to quote
off anderson i'm in pain
i'm physically in pain i don't
understand anything is in pain as well
right now i can tell you that let's see
if icaru understands how good his
position is i'm just wondering king g2
still winning
because this would be the move that i
would miss i
of course you you you sidestep any
further checks by the rook in fact you
attacked the rook hello yes and now
you're ready just to push him baby c5 a5
not as easy but it's not as easy not as
easy king to g2 is not as good of a move
after if i go one maybe were once again
within territory of of equality
a5 kmg2 was played okay but can rugby
one a5 i don't understand
oh you're just like he's too active
king f3 is going to be made with bishop
h5 is an actual thread wow
king f4 was a dominant move over the
king that was the point it's the king
needed to dominate the other
you actually want your opponent to
advance even further with the pawn to h3
now that makes sense i can after that
you control the pawn entirely yeah and
then the king g5 is going to be about my
knight f3 i'm a happy camper wow
yeah
i'm scratching i
forget about it guys i forget about it
king to g2 still any well not anybody's
game
uh still within reach for hillary i have
a feeling at least from a practical
perspective of winning this one still
some work ahead and we've seen a lot of
decisive advantages being spoiled in
difficult end games through that through
that and the players uh
richard and ali reza have gone into that
line that you were mentioning
uh oh he didn't play rook v6 i thought
yeah
they're
are okay it's it's it doesn't matter
it's easy
so rugby took e6
i mean time b5 k5
are you even if you're not on time i
have rook f1 work a favorite v8
one move away nice you found the only
move very good very good it was a 50 50.
you know actually i didn't know
you even did better than expected
exactly
sweet
always nice to
over perform our uniform yeah we are
king g i
i mean if you sit there and tell me you
know like you spoiled the game because
you played king g2
what do you what do you do right how can
you blame king jutsu i i it's just such
a logical move it's so natural you
attack the rook you keep the king next
to the past h-bone right you keep the
passer under lock and key
and your very next move you think it's
all good you're ready to push your pawns
so you win a tempo and it's king f4 and
what you said
uh alejandro
was this idea that oftentimes very often
in these endings
uh you use your king as a blocker
to keep the opponent king
and king f4 and
if you see h3
now you're happy you just come back the
pawn is more of a weakness than it is a
strength and you don't have uh moves
like a king g5
um
wow easy for us to say because we've got
engines here and
we're not exhausted having uh played six
hours like these are not exhausted
i'm just warming up let's go
and have y'all
i can't wait for round 14
i'll be at my best
yeah round 14 and six hour game
i'll check in on you
[Laughter]
guys but another thing that we need to
keep an eye on is that these players are
actually have entered
their a final time control so right now
they are getting 30 second increment but
they no longer have
any extra time added to their clocks
exactly
yeah so uh 61st move right now 15
minutes for timora job of 30 minutes for
hikaru nakamura and still a game to play
wow everything to play it's just the
beginning that's true that is it it
really is just beginning you know they
they used to say this about anatoly
karpov at his height
he's such an enormously strong player
people don't realize that he was
in his first match with gary kasparov
five nothing yeah
dominating right
uh that to beat
anatoly you had to out prepare him in
the opening so he had an advantage and
you have to outplay him in the middle
game and keep that advantage and then in
the ending you have to win a technical
game like you had to win the game three
times
uh to beat anatoly karpov this is what
i'm feeling with this game between timor
and hikaru that it's gone through these
different stages
and hikaru uh well we'll see if he can
uh oh we do
we do congratulate our birthday boy by
the way
wow uh a little bit of a gift uh real
save there and well we can't blame
um
we can't blame but uh i'm just looking
at this position where we were just so
enthusiastic about this one moment sorry
happy 19th birthday eloreza the newest
member of the french olympic team and
well number one prodigy in the chess
world right now but
he uh gets a bit of a gift here as c yes
up to one point tied for third with john
schuster of duda and richard rapport
trying to see if he will be surpassed
actually caught up by hikaru nakamura or
uh caught up by taymor rajab i think
it's either a draw or win for hikaru
exactly and everything to play for still
uh
sometimes you have to survive these
games with black and sometimes you need
a little bit of luck to win this
tournament and i think alireza he got
that today you got it for sure so i had
this moment
on the board uh in front of me and uh
richard he's got these double rooks on
the seventh so he's ready to give all
kinds of check mating
patterns but he needs to include the
pawn on e6
he played the move king e4 and walked
into rook takes and rookie three and
made his life very very difficult had he
started with the immediate e6 rook takes
g3 king c4
now the pawn is already here we're going
to play rook g7 jack and eventually we
get to play e7 with shaq and we would
win the game e6 essentially won the game
on the spot and it's not that difficult
no not at all i think king e4 was just a
big big mistake he even had a chance
later but this one i'm not that hurt
yeah i'm not gonna blame the king f5
missing king of five i think was totally
awesome but not not seeing e6 here
especially with the time situation
because at this point richard had 16
minutes and 33 seconds where sally reza
had like two minutes and 40.
and again you know you flush your past
pawn and
get it to work for you let's jump back
to the at the same time it almost feels
like karma right yesterday he skated
against yan shishtav duda in an
incredible ending he was lost at move 10
in the opening finally he got a winning
position in exactly the same structure
quite an interesting duel of games uh
this first and second for richie rapport
but unfortunately for him
not taking the chance and playing the
move king to e4 is indeed going to hurt
and we've seen that well fabio caruana
also drew his game and we saw that he
had a plus two advantage according to
the engines but he's not going to be
kicking himself out after that one after
repeating the position in that position
this one is going to hurt for richie
rapport and let's see what uh lubomir
lubovic is going to be able uh to sued
let's say our challenger absolutely
okay and how serious
is the position for timor in other words
we know that the engine likes the move
rook b1 is rook b one christian
only move or is it not that critical
it's it's it's uh pretty critical yeah
so rookie one or bust is what you're
saying yeah so what is the difference
between rugby i understand not going
rogue c1 because the knight on d4
controls check
on c2 right i understand not playing
that move but why not rook
a1 so the idea behind
a rook to b1 is that you have to be
meeting
c5 with bishop takes b3 the only way to
do that is by putting the rook on b1
if you go to a1 then i can go c5 okay if
you go to c1 then i can go a5 now you
might ask yourself why not a5 after rook
to b1 right
now i get king to g5 a6 and only now
once the pawn is not within reach of the
b pawn
now i'm going to go
rook to a1
and this is the big difference between
the two positions
impossible to understand with the naked
eye not impossible obviously nothing is
possible
extremely extremely difficult and this
is why he's spending so much time
it looks like uh
he has only one choice if you look at it
with the engine he does he has so many
choices rook d1 rook c1
rook b1 rk1 all of them
without the help of an engine are
looking very very similar right so right
now he's trying to understand the
nuances the differences between these
two uh these four moves and well we're
going to have to wait and see
whether he's going to be able to make
the right choice now i think a lot of
players most especially myself when i'm
worse
i'm looking at the most forcing moves to
try to make a draw so tell me i you you
shocked me by telling me that
rook c1 a5 bishop takes c4 a moment ago
you said that this was a drawn ending
is
this at what yes this is much uh much
different right yeah this is this is a
very different ending from the one you
showed earlier
but so why is that because the rook was
on d5 in the other one yes and the rook
was getting behind the pawn so i was
basically locking your rook to the
defense from the side to the pawn on a5
not only that but i'm not giving you any
chances to escape with the knight so i'm
starting to give you checks
as soon as possible
it was also black to move so it's a
completely different story so for
example
in your position is why the movie if i'm
not mistaken i just played yeah rotate
c4 yeah yeah this is a completely
different story and uh
you you
this is over like this is completely
winning i would assume maybe just well i
assume the other one
what if i call me out here
i want to play oh i wanted to do that no
but it's true i would want to see it
right
which move sorry christian let's go king
h3 king h3 i tickle your pawn
all i want to do is trade off everything
i mean this guy's going to come here and
tell us that rook d5 is winning but
it probably is somebody's going to get
hurt
but i think rugby 5 is winning
so wasn't the pawn on h5 previously yeah
one was on h5 and king on g4 okay so
just a second no but rook to d5 and then
i just pick up the pawn no no i agree uh
fair
no the pawn was on h5 so i was giving
you checks and only when you go to f4
then i get h4 in and then h3 as well
so that was the big difference between
these two positions
okay
yeah okay we're definitely being tested
you're poor panelists and by the way he
played the rook c1
which is losing
okay
mind-boggling mind-boggling position
mind-boggling and
bottling because of a5 right because of
a5 which
and
through my explanation i caught myself
and i was like wait a minute but what if
you actually just wait to go a6 as yeah
like
one right came to g5
don't tell me it says draw the winning
move right now is king f2
and i guess there's no check on c2 right
which by the way was why i didn't hurt
our feelings here uh
but what what what what okay okay so
what happens if i go into what is the
point of this move
what point of the move king f2 crazy
move
two k to f right what if you just go
rook to a1 right
now i go c5 i understand that part we
got so i'm waiting for you to go a6 and
then i go rookie what did you get we
know that what what did you understand
about rook a1 c5 that means no that's no
sense to me you know give up a5
rook a2 i didn't understand that at all
we've seen that before though we've seen
this mechanism before once again
i'm okay i'm waiting for you to go c6
first a6 a6 excuse me so you have to
make a useful move what is your useful
move h3 is going to be met with king g3
so you're saying king f2 is a useful
move to sidestep
uh it's a tsu's one it's a zoox one
you're good out of here
it's tom is disputing you i know it's
not it's not a zoo i said that's what
you do
oh
is is that really it no no that cannot
be so
if i have my rook on b1 c5 bishop to b3
and now without
the king here no more no that cannot
guys because c6 is always winning i am
usually okay with one game per
tournament making me feel really stupid
right like i'm okay with that there's
like it's destroying it but this round
is killing me i i don't understand the
danger
game yep
which was so strange the two bishops and
white has
the doubled rooks on the b file duda
looks like he's in charge of draw draw
the fire game was complex but it was
complex and i understand it was complex
nah we'll leave it at that right but
even we were having trouble with his
complexities too understanding why and i
understand i didn't feel stupid i just
felt the game was hard right but then
you get these end games where there's
like five pieces on the board yeah that
should be easy that should be easy and
right we don't understand it at all this
one
i don't get it i don't get them with
king f2 it wouldn't cross
my mind
it would to play the move king f to here
right
where my king on g2 cannot be checked it
cannot be checked by a bishop it cannot
be checked by the rook right
and
you you would be thinking that the king
is
wonderful
because it protects against h3 yeah why
move the king why move my king and let's
go with the wit with the pesh keys let's
push him right right every legal move
that i'm considering involves either
pushing apache or improving my rook
right right night i think is fine yeah
uh tough oh my gosh
what can i say i mean uh chess is hard
and it's been that way throughout once
again we do have three results okay guys
all draws i guess so far one
winning position we think i question
take over first all right please i get
it i'll explain it to you oh thank you
don't ask too many questions
don't ask too many questions all right
right nice overview would be nice so
rook to b1 now the king is on g2 we're
looking at the position from the
beginning after rook to b1 which we said
was the right move okay right leaving
the king on g2 not getting this extra
move king to f2 okay a5 king g5 a6 okay
sure rook to a1 c5
okay
yeah and now i go king to g4 you don't
even take the pawn on h i don't take the
pawn on a6 and now i have a big threat
either h3 or rook to a2
with the king on f2 there's no threat
because rook a2 is i'm just going to
escape on e3 okay and http but like this
is a completely different story what do
you do now
king f2 seems to be the best move but
then i just have enough time to get my
pawn to h3
knight to f3
bishop to b3
c6 yeah at that point i can also now
give chat
it's probably easier so this is
the nuance the difference that you have
to
i know what i'm going to give my
students next time
don't torture them like that
i can see they're not going to like you
yeah they they never do they they never
do one of my great stories i was just
laughing so incredibly hard
was uh the dutch
junior players erwin law me johnsmates
daniel stalwagen were getting chess
lessons from luke vandelli
chest lessons from luke van noy so they
had gone to his house he said look guys
i just won this ending in the bundesliga
you see it's easily winning it's a
bishop's same color ending
unfortunately i have to go and i have
this thing to do i'm going to be back in
two hours
you guys take a look and figure out this
ending which they did and they got out
their notebooks engines
and they quickly determined that it was
a draw
you know luke has won this game but
but then they found this unbelievable
way of winning
this like uh stutter step like three
stutter steps with the bishop and they
go oh luke is so brilliant that he
trapped us with this ending oh my gosh
and so then they found a way of
overcoming that ending
and then they were sure it was a draw
and everybody was happy until once again
the exact same thing happened and they
went spent the entire two hours
and finally they convinced themselves it
was a draw luke came back and said well
what did you guys discover draw he goes
you idiot you don't know nothing and he
didn't understand that
he just found it
and he won the ending and he didn't know
it at all it was brilliant i loved it
so yes sir those engines man yes exactly
nowadays we kind of trust the engines
right whenever we get to an assessment
then the engine is saying something is
especially then in reality we believe it
right yeah
how often were you guys wrong in your
analysis
so let's say openings you analyze an
opening and you analyze it for a week
with your team and then you feel
super comfortable with it you feel happy
and then you play it a couple of times
and then somebody else comes and smacks
it yeah how many times did that happen
well it's really hard because
unfortunately it was like these eras
yeah you know the era before deep blue
nobody trusted the engines and in fact
we we had a great deal of laughter
then the engines didn't really
understand fortresses and they would be
saying plus five all the time and it was
an easy draw so those types of things
but then
after deep blue
uh suddenly it was like it was a new era
of computers it was just
totally different we were going
about a
i mean i don't understand chess i don't
understand yes that was what we were
facing so
uh at first we were contemptuous in fact
of
engines and i remember this was really
really sweet
so i played in the tournament in the
hague
and it was man versus machine
and i played six computers you know
there was like the the world champion m
chass uh
hydra
uh oh gosh i'm thinking the old engines
marty marty hirsch's emperor
fritz
um et cetera et cetera
i go 6-0 very nice yeah and there was a
jose the cartoonist yeah drawing where i
was like spanking you know six engines
in a row it was like really really nice
in a row right right
i go to uh
new york and uh gary kasparov loses to
deep blue
i it's like what i was just contemptuous
of the engines and now gary the world
champion
loses to deep blue i was shocked
yeah that was a moment that really
changed our uh our world yeah yeah yeah
i remember when gary played dublin such
a big worldwide event two were two
matches the first was in philadelphia
that gary has won
the second was a rematch in new york
that deep
uh blue one and then they and then then
they just discombobulated
uh the engine the computer and no
rematches for gary after that he was
like furious and there have been eras
after that i would say that as someone
that grew up entirely in the computer
era there has been very marked
differences right i would say that there
are some
some years and some technologies that
have been invented throughout ever since
the blue okay that really changed uh how
strong engines were because even after
deep blue uh i would say we were still
competitive against dungeons you still
had these matches junior against
kasparov
yeah yeah where he famously got made it
in one yeah that was great but had he
not again made it he wouldn't have lost
that game right uh so we still had
chances right and then
come around by the time stockfish comes
around we're hopeless but there's kind
of this in between
uh
ripka
which fell out of grace but replica was
a very strong engine for
was already killing us rivka was already
killing us but
it was
i think it was the first engine that
you're like yeah we really cannot play
ripka right uh whereas fritz i still
felt
we had a chance right yeah as did
vladimir kramnik right uh and ever since
i think ripka was invented we just
stopped playing against engines yeah
it's
as magnus famously said it's depressing
it's depressing yeah they beat us and we
don't even understand why i actually get
a lot of questions like that from chess
fans not really chess fans but people
outside of the chess world if it's it's
beneficial to play engines and it really
is none at all zero there's no there's
no reason to play an engine you will
lose and you will not know why you lost
and wait a minute hold on i have to pull
you i have to challenge you on that one
because my nephew yeah yuri is now 18
years old he's got
the magnus carlson app okay and he loves
playing the magnus carlson as a child
right and then a little bit older and a
little bit older so the engine is being
terribly handicapped right and so he
puts it on a level he can win and then
he goes to the next level until he loses
and
so he likes playing against the engine i
like i like that one i meant as a
training tool for gm's of course yeah
that was just the caveat that i wanted
yeah i thought i think also the engine
represents magnus in that particular
case and magnus has a general appeal
especially for the young generation
right he's the world champion he's
probably the most popular chess player
on the planet right now right so you
feel like you're playing magnus right
there is a story behind that but if
you're playing a faceless stock fish i
don't think you get the same engagement
even at a young age like that i don't
see young players actually playing
against engines using chess base or
anything of that nature trying to match
their strengths against that they only
played as a way to have some fun right
but you need to put a face to that
engine okay well i've got two great
experts sitting right in front of me so
i'm going to take advantage of the
moment to ask yourselves the question
how can you use the engine so it's the
most useful and efficiently how can you
use an engine to better your play
it really depends on the level of
your level as a chess player i think
that if you're just starting out and
you're you're a beginner
it's what i call a blunder check
okay why can't i make this move right
and then the computer says well if you
do this i will win a piece like that
yeah and then it becomes more
complicated the longer you go right at
the moment uh for a grand master using
the engine is something that's very
tricky because you're completely relying
on it in some of your opening analysis
but at the same time the engine is very
happy to throw you in a position where
it gives you an evaluation and good luck
it doesn't tell you what the plan is it
doesn't tell you what the next few moves
will necessarily be it doesn't tell you
how a human is going to react right and
i feel that very often in the chess
world especially the 20
200 to 2600 level master level to gm not
not this strong yeah
very often i feel that players get to a
position that they analyzed
and then they kind of wonder what on
earth they're doing
and i feel there's an over reliance
for a lot of people
on on engine analysis i see and if you
asked me for most of our viewers what is
the best way to improve chess yep you
grab that engine and you turn it off
and then what do you do then you try to
analyze the position yourself when you
have questions you ask the engine right
why can't i play this you have a
conversation with the engine right but
before you have this conversation if you
first open the engine and it tells you a
move you're immediately biased into
looking at that move
what you should be doing is looking at
the position and reasoning yourself
critically right reason critically
yourself this is what i would play right
and then the engine might tell you how
you're an idiot right but then you learn
exactly if you just go through the first
line of the engine you will never
understand
why a move was played and this goes all
the way up to the gm level right it is
highly recommended by many of the top
coaches of the world at the moment to
look at chess especially broadcasts
if you're not looking at the commentary
if you're just looking at the games
yourself don't turn on the engine right
just just leave it alone
i just i just toasted luke van gaali a
moment ago let me toast myself so eric
hanson grandmaster handsome he comes
over from canada he stays
uh with us and you know like eric he
doesn't know anything about anything no
no no history nothing like that i said
look
let me show you this absolutely
absolutely wonderful game by anatoly
karpa and of course he didn't know
who olman was and
yeah i know
and uh so i show him this game and
karpov wins a magnificent game and
eric says yeah but
but that was a blunder you know
uh karpov's opponent should have played
this move okay and then it's easy draw
so i was like pissed right yeah so first
of all
in the annotated games in the book
karpov doesn't look at the move eric
suggested right so like now i've got to
do some work
and i'm looking at this move by eric
and i go no this can't be true that that
this move refutes of brilliancy it
really does right i go okay okay okay i
give up we'll turn on the engine the
engine goes zero zero yeah
i i think
it's just i think it is incredibly
depressing to go through a lot of these
games of the past
and run them through an engine for
example a modern engine modern engine
capablanca's best end games are actually
all terrible end games right when you
think about it because we learned from
him and we know how to play them but he
would like a lot of the technical
technical games yeah the evaluation go
up and down up and down up and down and
slip horribly it would slip horribly and
the engine would be like okay it's a
table-based drop what guess it isn't
anymore oh table-based again wow and it
just goes like that the
even at the modern level right i mean
gary's games some of the earlier once
you run them through an engine and don't
withstand the critical things
but it doesn't matter yeah i want to
really point that out it does not matter
exactly
those were brilliant games anyway true
true uh we do have something very
different on the board christian we have
it's the critical moment we have the
critical moment right now okay because
we basically followed what we were
discussing after auto c1 a5 came on the
board king to g5 or king to h5 it
doesn't really make that much of a
difference okay king to f2 is the
critical move if hikaru finds king to f2
he's going to take this full point home
if he doesn't
then is going to slowly become more
difficult as it has been for the past 20
30 moves so big moment right now for
hikaru nakamura he needs to find the
move king to f2 and if he finds this
then i think he's going to go on and win
this game
five-time u.s champion here uh facing a
very key moment king f2 i have to say
honestly
i'd be looking at everything else
exactly
i want to go rook f8 i want to win a
pawn
i want to go a6
i don't know what other choices i have
but
those two come first a6 rook f8
i give it i give it a thought for king
f3
yes but f3 might especially the shoulder
to shoulder the king right the king you
never know when rookie chad is actually
checkmate ryan and
although i do see rook f1 i wonder why i
put my king on f3 but the king f2 is
just such a hidden resource to me yeah
and you said uh
yeah king f3 and king f3 by the way wins
as well
i don't know why
that's why they pay you the big bucks
that's right that's why they playing f2
and or king f3
actually turns out to be winning by the
way
by
by the way after king g5 king f3 kg5
king f2 is the best move i give up i'm
done i'm done find another commentator i
am i i get him
g5 and you're telling me the winning
move is now i'm not guaranteeing that
it's the only you're not guaranteed i'm
not guaranteeing that is the only
winning move but for us
not so winning
c5 doesn't make any sense king f2 what
else right
what else what other piece are you going
to touch i understand but like i just
wouldn't think of this
human right right you don't want to you
don't want to step on the knight's path
i think that's where i understand that
that makes sense yeah right to f3 yeah i
understand that okay so
what he's saying is that king h5 king f3
and maybe king to g5 and then the knight
doesn't go to f3 that makes a lot of
sense and then you go king f2 and other
like okay
check his pockets yeah i mean i mean if
the guy does he plays if the guy goes
king f3 king g5 king of two and beats
you you say well maybe he should be the
one playing magnus because
you found that yeah exactly exactly uh
christian you were in bucharest
uh but uh you weren't here in studio
when peters fiddler ourselves we were
analyzing the grand chess tour of
bucharest and it was this game of shock
nepo and shaq
and this was a game that went back and
forth and essentially shaq won
a really really really hard-fought
battle
and he had missed that nepo has a
one-move win
he had missed something else
king f2
f2 wow tip your hats hats off hats
that's off wow
king f2 and then
after the game
shaq comes in the studio
and he goes oh i won brilliantly look
look how i played oh my god it's so
awesome i went here here here yeah but
what if he had played here
he goes oh
[Laughter]
and then it comes again what have you
done this oh come on
come on
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's great king f2 wow
what a move
what a find that is that's the card
wow he found it and he's going to win
this game
why is he going to win this game what
are you going to do next as black you're
going to go king to g4 i run into rook
to f8 or a6 a6 is the big problem that
we discussed okay let's try it king to
g4 king to g4 a6 replica
actually no not even
forget about it
okay so yeah because right now
this is actually different
than what we were looking at
okay
why why is it i'm getting confused
i'm getting confused myself why is it
different
okay i'll go bishop g6 there was a
bishop on g6 in the previous variation
no no we're discussing yes this was the
position and bishop to g6 now you go a6
this was the line that i was remembering
okay
but if you do go king to g4 yeah we
actually never looked at this
look to f8
and that makes sense because you're
going to i would assume just grab the
pawn is that it yes
ah you don't because bishop to e4
covers not convinced by this no no
knight to e2 and 92 actually is a fork
because we're good for this just
sorry rook f4 now so rook to f8 after
king to g4 if you go away uh too far
from the pawn on f6 then you have this
rook to f8 and these bishop takes c4
ideas do not bail black out of his
issues i think it's too late right now
because rook takes a6 and i'm going to
take on f6
whatever you you don't have time to take
on these no rook a4 a4 take on a and
i'll take
ah you're supposed to oh my
my you're one temple away you're one
temple away rook and rectangle for a7 if
i hide the king but the king is uh not
covered by any pawns
so you go here you take i go here now i
finally give you the check
that wins the game
insanity okay i'm in pain
nice and insanity
under five minutes
for timur raj above right now 12 minutes
wow he's putting the final touch to
zikaro he's grinding out a win after a
very difficult and painful
loss yesterday against fabiano caruana i
have to commend his mental resiliency
it was never in doubt we know that
hikaru has extreme mental
resilience and capabilities and this is
exactly what he's showing right now but
to come back after
as you said a very very painful loss in
fact uh bouncing back
is what champions do all the time
absolutely we talked about the fact that
you need to score more or less a plus
three score in this tournament so
chicago needs to put four wins together
that's a great way to start it sure uh
teamwork
well he's defended incredibly well for a
long time so well i mean wow
ever since he lost that pawn ever since
he lost that pawn i don't know like five
six eight hours ago right right right
it's just out of the opening or whatever
it was and he's made it so hard on his
opponent we thought he was dead right he
lost the pawn and it's done exactly and
he fought himself he caught himself all
the way here
almost to a draw with this win should it
happen should it happen hikaru would
then jump into a tie for third you would
have a fifty percent score just behind
the leaders
yeah king g4 is on the board okay so is
all right i'm gonna stop suggesting
anything i'm just gonna ask christian
from now on is rook f8 the only winning
move
it's a logical move because you pick up
the ball
yes i get that much but is it the only
moon
i don't know
let's see let's try another movie thank
you christian
[Laughter]
it does seem that's the case that's
great i don't know
it does seem that's the case at least
for a decisive advantage
i've had a lot i don't know i i've gone
through a lot of lines i'm getting
concerned about where the rookies
do you guys want to just take it away
and do some more opening movies
came on the board
may not be the only winning movie
[Music]
all right so if i go bishop h5 i don't
like bishop g6 this move makes no sense
to me because it's always getting hit by
rook takes f6
right
so bishop h5 and then you take on f6
check this out no i'm not
oh come on
come on
i go rook g8 and now i go rook g1 and
you don't have a check on the second
rank
because the rookies on c1
and you trap the rook after rook c3
somehow no i just pushed my pawn
probably now you push your punch
or rook to rook that you want
or rook what i would assume
my guess is i wasn't sure because 86
have rook d3 and then
yeah this is still winning
this is still winning you cannot go king
to e4 i understand that so my king is
going through he's going to go right
no but here i have rook d2 yes that's
fine and then rook here but then i go
knight before you cannot knight d
you saw how casual well because i wanted
to go through the scenes right the night
you put the king and the rook in a
position with the knight
get out of here you're going to shoot me
right my goodness
this is the position that looks studied
like so you played the move rook f8 the
bishop moves obviously to h5 so that the
pawn is not captured rook f6 is equal
what rook f6 is equal on the spot
h3
the computer doesn't even consider
this any sort of one like plus zero one
zero two no nothing zero zero zero
i'm in pain
so after bishop h5 the only way it seems
to me is rupture look g8 followed by
rook to g1
um
it's really really hard in a bullet game
you're taking the pawn and a blitz game
you're taking the pawn and a rapid chess
game just maybe you think you you think
for 10 seconds and then you're like yeah
but in a classical game i can imagine
that hikaru is thinking all i got to do
is trade rooks and it's
it's crossed his mind numerous times for
the last two three hours how do i trade
rooks
right now maybe this is why he split h3
kimura understands
he goes back through the memory of the
last few moves and he understands why
rook to c1
when he spent 15 minutes on his decision
was the wrong decision and this is why
chess is cruel the chess is painful and
then you die and then you die uh by the
way did he play h3 h3
but then rook takes f7 is suddenly easy
h2 on the board ram rook check rook
check is the best move and this is what
we've been discussing whenever hikaru
sees this type of technical winds
he just makes them no no no no it's easy
because where's the king right right
king f4 yeah
knight g3 yeah
knight
i
thought and i worked uh a lifetime to
understand chess and i feel like i've
wasted
we've we've broken alejandro yes
alejandra is done but we have the
technology we can bring him back
better stronger faster
remember
as long as i'm gone
back did you ever watch the six million
dollar man and lee majors yeah
the the cyborg uh bionic man uh knight
g3 okay that's finally finally i can't
i'd say that's all she wrote folks what
is it yes you get i'm done i'm done king
f3 right king f3 just wins king f3 rook
c3 all right king g2
i take on b3 right but now i've got two
pawns christian come on i understand i
get it
what do you mean a6 okay hold on you're
telling me no i'm not saying anything no
no no it's still winning you're you're
challenged it's it's still it's still
winning man versus machine look what
he's saying to us he's saying after king
f3 which is on the board
rook check king g2 rook takes now aren't
we just running for a touchdown over
here sure
a6 i assume you've got to get behind not
at some point no i want to maybe throw a
check in here
any time you want you can put my king on
h1 it i really don't know i want to go
king d4
what yeah okay i'll let you go to a7
that's fine okay wonderful i'm happy
okay over here now i'm a pawn grubber i
work very hard
takes g3 thank you very much
thank you very much yasser oh rook takes
g3
i thought i had h1 totally
totally covered g3 oh so you actually
see four and then you will say seven i'm
not saying you lose a seven i'm pretty
sure you're still winning
i can go 94 check right so here let's
let's uh
so you defend like that okay king c5 now
you can't take
because i've got a fork
that probably and then i get to go
knight takes f6 and i finally think
wow what a marathon you know sometimes
you know and that's where these types of
tournaments it's it's an anvil
and you're you're you're just being
challenged each and every day and by the
time the anvil is over you're like the
sharpest sword
uh on the block and you have really
really been challenged
this was a very very hard game to win
and boy i gotta say that timor put up
extraordinary fight rook takes g3
rogue g4 is not clean at all by the way
we do have
all of that all of this happened on the
board and rookie for rook g4 even though
it wins is far from far from clean
far from clean you say yeah why is that
because of king d3
rook g4
king d3
my goodness
oh the wind guys where's the wind
are you kidding me you mean after
working so hard to get to this position
it's still difficult
cannot be right
i mean this is and that's the way the
human mind operates right you finally
get to this point you're like i'm going
to relax a sense of relief yeah i don't
think i could relax i've won this game
finally yeah
oh i get my knight to c8
that's wow that was
oh
thank you thank you that's really simple
okay
takes and knight to e4
so
d6 to c8 and if i go through d5 oh sorry
i did it the wrong way of course yeah no
knight knight
keep going
knight f5 to d6 to c8 so then my rook
king david five uh knight e7 check ah so
you go knight to five not knight d4 yeah
and i put my so it this is my dream
setup right so now i've got my knight on
c8 it's untouchable one second if you go
knight to five i go king c5 wait a
minute
knight what are you doing f5 sorry i go
king c5 now king c5 sure
makes sense
it's no i don't have a threat it's
technically a win i actually don't have
a threat because king b6 is going to be
met by knight d6 to quote tom zugswan
yeah king king over now you can't go
towards the pond because then i do get
my knight this one is has to be winning
yeah wow has to be winning in a lot of
ways just
make sure you don't blunder something
just make sure you don't you need to
calculate this one out a little bit do i
need the h2 pawn though alejandro can i
just jump right away towards that uh
desired uh c8 uh square
i mean the pawn on h2 lift well but a
rookie rook a2 right of course rocket
king h1 and i go king c6 how do you make
progress
i attack well i go to b8 no no i go rook
g3 rook b3 rook
v8 yeah
not on g i mean on g2 is fine as well
yeah you take the rooks and no no i win
but
i don't think you win that no but what
do you mean
[Laughter]
that's because i sacrificed all my pawns
right okay and you'll be able to
sacrifice all of them that's hilarious
so king c6
and we still can't no we can claim the
game easily i think no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no g3 just go rogue g3
rook b3 rook v8 this is the practice
very easy i agree thank you so much
christian all right all right
on the board is doing it easier knight
five on the board and first rook b7
yeah that's a nice improvement that's a
nice improvement so that i can just get
my knight to c8 97 8690 it's a threat 97
is a threat okay now game over
he done it
he came over
i'm going to go to bed tonight
hearing this word
echo in my mind you know game over no
it's not over till no that lady sings is
over oh 97 knight c8 rook b8
exactly the next three moves unless you
give me chests so the pre moves are
knight e7 knight c8 rook to b8 and
a8 equals queen and there's no way to
stop it and you can't stop it wow
guys it was tiring it was exhausting it
was hard fought but it was dramatic as
well i mean all the way
to this very ending and deserved
right this earth thoroughly deserved for
hikaru he came up with uh quite
remarkable preparation i have to say
timur fought off very well he found this
d5 pawn sacrifice which gave him a lot
of chances not only for survival but
potentially even for finding some sort
of dynamic play that would give him more
and after that he currently transitioned
into this endgame and masterfully
managed to outplay his opponent exactly
for those of you who are actually
joining us late in that
in this game um
what is christian speaking about
where did the the preparation come in
right here this position has actually
been seen before we mentioned a game of
kramnik and fabi fabi played knight f3
christian also cited a4 as being played
previously hikaru
queen h5 queen c6 rookie 1
rook e8 knight f3 offering up the e4
pawn which you don't
capture
d5 throwing the ball back into ikaru's
court and after a very very long play
ikaru nursed a superior ending for
five hours
wow actually it was a
little bit more than five hours i'm i'm
sure
thousands of hikaru's chip
twitch his stream uh are cheering him on
thousands of thousands tens of thousands
wow actually i think it's a million
million
millions at this point a million
followers on youtube our congratulations
to her cause he made such a successful
chess streamer and again knight e7 to c8
is the winning plan the time is not a
factor anymore no but it's two minutes
for
roger that's all he asks wow
uh
you know it
what can i say uh for
timor
this type of a game is one that could
really sink his ship yeah this is
this is this is really tough for raj
above because he starts bat
and he he cannot be the player that
comes with the most amount of confidence
into this tournament he already came
comes from a bad tournament in norway in
norway and
um
he has to recover somehow i mean he's
playing even stronger opposition now
that he is playing in norway better
prepared hungrier uh and you can see it
here right where they're going to ground
you down in every single game right
starting with a draw against ali rasa
with white and then losing to hikaru i
mean that's tough yeah and that draw
with uh ali reza as well was a great
game this whole exchange sacrifice was
just
genius i want to say and then
the fact that timor uh flipped the
script and was actually upon up in a
rook ending uh
nice nice so this is and i think we just
saw the king coming from c5 to d5 which
indicates that seymour has
resigned timo rajavo has resigned
finally in a marathon game against
hikaru nakamura whoa we've been here for
quite a while six hours and 32 minutes
was today's round
uh fabiano caruana and jana pognacci no
reels changed in most of the standings
as uh they drew their game they are
currently the leaders with four and a
half points the big difference is that
hikaru overlaps uh tamo rajavo who leaps
over him anding lorraine and uh ding
loren still on the bottom in the bottom
with teamwork uh fifty percent for most
of the players john chisos richard
rapport and alireza all of them also
with one point out of two wow
uh another very very
dramatic round i want to say christian
get some final thoughts in here as we
appear
prepare to say good night well uh all i
can say is now i understand and i'm
appreciative that these players have a
rest day after only three rounds because
i have to say in the first two rounds
these players came here to fight and
fight they did because uh all the games
up to this point were remarkable even
the quickest draws that is the one
between yarn shisht of dudai and dingley
ren it had a lot of content every single
game had a lot of content these players
are definitely bringing the hit and will
be here to call all the action tomorrow
as well of course
uh don't miss it
check the predictions out guys
look at the climbing back a little knock
us back neck is back baby yeah
yeah good job yasser i'm thinking wait a
minute dingle has been around
don't count this man out it's two rounds
out of 14. it's still a very long
tournament and that's why you can't miss
round three will be here bright and
early as usual to bring you all of the
action from the very beginning clearly
to the very end don't miss any of it
join us tomorrow same time same place
thank you very much
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the
saint louis chess club any reproduction
or distribution of this content without
the express written consent of the st
louis chess club is prohibited
you